hey everyone in this week's episode
we'll talk about the most popular and
commonly used programming language
python so let's begin and learn about
the development of python and gain
insights about the current ID Trends but
before that make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to get
notified every time we come up with new
content python is very famous for its
simple programming syntax core
readability and English like commands
that make coding a lot easier and
efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language python
has interpreted high level general
purpose programming language developed
by Guido van rossim at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after the snake python was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
Flying Circus Guido van Rossum
formulated python in the late 1980s as a
successor to the ABC language in 1994
python version 1.0 was released with
features like exception handling Lambda
map filter and reduce python 2.0
released in 2000 introduced features
like list comprehensions and a garbage
collection system capable of collecting
reference Cycles python 3.0 was released
on the 3rd of December 2008. undoubtedly
Python 2.x and 3.x have proven to be the
most used versions as of today python
3.7.4 is the latest stable version
released in the summer of 2019. python
is popularly used for development
scripting and software testing top ID
companies like Google Facebook Instagram
Spotify and Netflix among others use
Python some major applications of python
can be seen in the fields of machine
learning artificial intelligence data
science and iot python also offers many
libraries like numpy sci-fi Keras
tensorflow Django and flask pep 8 is the
official style guide that defines the
styling conventions for python code a
few popular open source python projects
include with E and B statistics solving
the traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing maps and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include NLP
ml from scratch pytorch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry python is
a widely popular programming language
that is used for web development game
development data analysis as well as
data visualization
hi everyone
welcome to this python developer full
course by simply loan in this session we
will cover all the important python
Concepts techniques and projects that
will help you become a successful python
developer a highly experienced trainers
will take you through this live session
but before I begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply learn Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update
so we will start by learning the history
of python and understand the top 10
reasons to Learn Python you will look at
the job role of a python developer the
skills they need to possess and how the
resume of a python developer should be
then we'll see how to install Python and
the Anaconda distribution of python
then we will shift our Focus towards
learning the basics of python such as
data types variables operators lists
tuples and dictionaries next we will
understand about loops and conditional
statements after that we'll get an idea
about object oriented programming
Concepts and functions in Python we will
also cover some important Advanced
Python Programming Concepts such as
iterators modules generators as well as
packages finally we will see the
important python interview questions
that are often asked so let's get
started let's begin and learn about the
development of python and gain insights
about the current ID Trends python is
very famous for its simple programming
syntax core readability and english-like
commands that make coding a lot easier
and efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language python
has interpreted high-level general
purpose programming language developed
by Guido van rossim at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that python was named
after this snake python was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
flying circuits Guido and Rossum
formulated python in the late 1980s as a
successor to the ABC language in 1994
python version 1.0 was released with
features like exception handling Lambda
map filter and reduce python 2.0
released in 2000 introduced features
like list comprehensions and a garbage
collection system capable of collecting
reference Cycles python 3.0 was released
on the 3rd of December 2008. undoubtedly
Python 2.x and 3.8 have proven to be the
most used versions as of today python
3.7.4 has the latest stable version
released in the summer of 2019. python
is popularly used for development
scripting and software testing top ID
companies like Google Facebook Instagram
Spotify and Netflix among others use
Python some major applications of python
can be seen in the fields of machine
learning artificial intelligence data
science and iot python also offers many
libraries like numpy sci-fi Keras
tensorflow Django and flask pep 8 is the
official style guide that defines the
styling conventions for python code a
few popular open source python projects
include EnV statistics solving the
traveling salesman problem using
self-organizing math and python to BPF
converter some of the trending python
repositories on GitHub today include nip
ml from scratch pytotch Transformers 100
days of ml code among others popular
websites on the internet like Reddit and
quora are built using python
civilization 4 Battlefield 2 Sims 4 and
World of Tanks are some popular games
developed using python according to
indeed the average salary of a python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the US is around 124
000 US Dollars users and admirers of
python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
pythonous pythony stars and pythonians
since its Inception python has come a
long way to become the most popular
coding language and continues to
revolutionize the IT industry so what
really is Python programming language
python is an object-oriented high-level
programming language that supports
built-in data structures and dynamic
semantics
it's supposed multiple programming
paradigms such as structured
object-oriented and functional
programming
python is often described as batteries
included language because it has a
comprehensive collection of standard
libraries
python supports different modules and
packages which allows program modularity
and code reuse
python was developed by Guido van Rossum
and its implementation started in
December 1989.
python 1.0 version was released in the
year 1994 python 2.0 came out in October
2000 while python 3.0 was released in
December 2008.
now that you have got an understanding
of the Python programming language let's
now look at the top 10 reasons why you
should learn python
so at number 10 we have ease of use
one of the most common reasons to like
python is that it is quite easy to learn
and code
it provides a simple syntax that
improves stability and makes it easier
to understand so developers can create
any desktop or machine based application
using this language
python is very versatile and is
instrumental in artificial intelligence
and machine learning
we will talk about this later in the
session compared to Java or CC plus plus
it has fewer lines of codes
in the example here we are printing a
hello world program in Java as you can
see
if you have to write a program in Java
you first have to declare the class name
along with its scope
next using curly braces you need to pass
the main method along with its arguments
and then using system.out.print element
method you can print hello world that's
quite a tedious task isn't it
the same task for printing hello world
can be done using just one line of code
in python as shown here you can write
the print function and pass whatever you
want to display inside the brackets and
that will print the output it is so
simple
that is why python is considered as a
high level language and its open source
you can just download it from the
website and start using it
at 9 we have active community
you need a community to learn new
technology and friends are your best
asset when it comes to learning a
programming language python has large
community support
it has an extensive and active Community
to assist Engineers developers analysts
and data scientists with expert support
in case of programming errors or issues
with the software
you can just go ahead and put your
queries in the community forum the
community members will address your
queries in real quick time
communities like stack Overflow also
brings many python experts together to
help learners
python enhancement proposals or pep is
where the proposals and the improvements
are announced
also there are a set of recommendations
or core values called the design of
python written by Tim petos that
represents the guiding principles for
python development
up next at 8 we have portable and
extensible
multiple cross-language operations can
be performed effectively because python
is portable and extensible in nature
for example if the users have a python
code written on Windows and they want to
execute on a Mac operating system or
Linux operating system or Solaris they
can easily do it without any Amendment
they can also run this code on any
platform flawlessly and without any
interrupt
due to its extensibility feature you can
integrate other programming languages
such as java.net C and C plus codes with
python
the components of other programming
languages can be used with python and
thus it can be used to make a
cross-platform suitable application too
so it is a really good feature that
python provides
the next Reason To Learn Python is
testing Frameworks
python supports several built-in
Flawless testing tools and Frameworks
that help in debugging and speeding up
workflows
some of the tools and Frameworks
supported by python are Pi test selenium
and Splinter
this is the reason for which every
tester tries to use python-based tools
and Frameworks to test any application
or code or to validate it in an easier
manner
pie test is the most recommended testing
framework for functional integrational
and unit testing
you can run selenium test scripts using
Python programming language to automate
various tasks and Splinter is an open
source tool for testing web applications
using python
it lets you automate browser actions
such as visiting URLs and interacting
with their items
at number 6 we have libraries and
packages
another reason why python has become so
popular in the industry these days is
that it has a massive collection of
libraries and packages that make your
task simple and easy
it has a range of libraries packages
Frameworks and modules for data
manipulation statistical calculation web
development machine learning and data
science
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via python
package index the repository of python
software
python provides the default package
called pip Anaconda is a third party
python ecosystem other examples include
numpy scipy and xango
then we have scripting and automation
python is not just a programming
language it can also be used for writing
scripts for automating tasks and
workflows without human intervention
the code can be written in the form of
scripts and executed later further it is
interpreted by the machine and checked
for errors at runtime
the machine is used to read and
interpret the code
once the developer checks the code it
can further run or be used several times
without any interruption
this allows you to automate a set of
certain tasks within a program or the
same code can be used with other
applications as well
at number 4 we have web development
another reason to Learn Python is that
it makes the web development process so
much easier
it provides a wide collection of
Frameworks that make it easier for
developers to develop web applications
some of the examples are Django flask
pyramid turbo gears cherry pie Etc
these Frameworks are written in Python
which makes the code a lot faster and
stable
the task which used to take hours in PHP
can be finished in minutes using python
python is also used for web scraping
Django offers many elements of intricate
programs such as template design
management panel signing in signing up
signing out URL routing Etc
once the user establishes the framework
all these features become ready to use
flask
is a microwave framework written in
Python
of all the components that are part of
this module they are all ready to
execute in the server context
the Pinterest and Linkedin use flask
pyramid offers more attributes than
flask it will assist users with URL
routing and authentication support
turbo gears is a highly recommended and
scalable framework that supports
features such as authentication caching
identification management of sessions
and pluggable applications
up next at number three
we have machine learning
the growth of machine learning has been
phenomenal in the last five years and
it's rapidly changing the world return
functions in Python the system can learn
and train itself from past data
once the system is trained it can then
learn to adjust itself to new inputs
finally it can make predictions and
perform human-like tasks automatically
at number 2 we have data science
machine learning and data science go
hand in hand
python is robust scalable and provides
extensible visualization and Graphics
options hence it is widely used in data
science
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas for
operations to manipulate data on
numerical tables and time series it also
provides simpi for symbolic computation
and scipy for Technical and scientific
computations
it has another Library called Pi brain
which is sought for python-based
reinforcement learning artificial
intelligence and neural network library
scikit-learn is the machine learning
library for creating classification
regression and clustering algorithms and
finally it provides Pi torch and
tensorflow for deep learning
finally coming to the most important and
the top reason to Learn Python which is
career opportunities and salary
Python language provides a variety of
job opportunities and Promises a high
growth graph with huge salary prospects
it has been used by most of the tech
Giants
industry leaders using python are Amazon
Google Facebook IBM NASA Netflix and
YouTube
next you can see the Google Trends
but I have considered three programming
languages python Java and C plus I have
compared them for the past 12 months you
can see it clearly on your screens that
python has become a front runner in
terms of popularity and web search
volume
it means people are interested in Python
they want to learn it and use it in
their work
you can also check for the YouTube
search
there also you will find that Python
programming language is the most
searched language on YouTube
now on your screens
you can see the report of pypl which is
popularity of programming language index
it is created by analyzing how often
language tutorials are searched on
Google
it is a leading indicator
the raw data comes from Google Trends
the bar graph depicts that python is the
most popular and widely used programming
language across the globe followed by
Java then JavaScript and c-sharp
the popularity of programming language
index can help you decide which language
to study or which one to use in a new
software project
the next graph shows the popularity of
python and Java over the years starting
from 2004 till the current period which
is 2020 worldwide python is the most
popular language
python grew the most in the last five
years by 19.4 percent and Java lost the
most by minus 7.2 percent
now let's talk about the different
career opportunities and the job roles
that you can get into If You Learn
Python language
first you can become a python developer
where you will be asked to write and
test codes debug programs and integrate
applications with third-party web
services
second you can become a web developer
here you will be responsible for writing
server-side web application logic python
web developers usually develop back-end
components connect the application with
third-party services and support the
front-end developers by integrating
their work with the python application
you can also become a data analyst if
you know python as a data analyst you
have to gather data from multiple
sources using scripts analyze that data
develop and Implement databases and data
collection systems
you can become a data scientist
as a data scientist you need to
understand the challenges in business
and come up with the best Solutions
using modern tools and techniques to
analyze visualize and build prediction
models to make business decisions
lastly you can be a machine learning
engineer where you can develop
intelligent machines that can learn from
vast volumes of data and apply knowledge
without human intervention
so there's a lot of Scopes If You Learn
Python
now let's have a look at the salaries of
some of these job rules
so if you become a python developer you
can earn an average salary of 76 526
dollars per annum in the United States
while in India you can earn an average
of 4 lakhs 98 000 rupees per annum
also
If You Learn Python and become a data
scientist
you can expect an average salary of 113
000 per year in the United States while
in India you can earn an average of 10
lakhs 28 000 rupees per annum
let me now go ahead and call out the 10
reasons for learning python once again
at number 10 we had ease of use at
number nine we had active community at
eight we had the portable and extensible
feature of python at number seven we saw
the testing Frameworks
at six we had libraries and packages
then at five we saw scripting and
automation followed by web development
then we had machine learning and data
science at number three and number two
respectively
and finally at number one we had career
opportunities and salary
so who is a python developer let's
answer this so here are some of the
Technologies used by a python developer
pandas Anaconda tensorflow python Ides
Django web framework and patreon
a python developer is one Who develops
backend components of a web application
using python when working as a web
developer now the web Frameworks like
Django and flask are used for this
purpose
a python developer is also the one who
writes effective testable and scalable
python code he also performs data
analysis when working in the field of
data science so basically a python
developer develops deploys debugs and
maintains a project so let's go through
the skill set of a python developer now
the core python skills that a python
developer possesses are data structures
like arrays list stack queues trees and
graphs there's oop Concepts like
inheritance classes and objects and
abstraction thus packages and functions
that is importing external packages into
a python code database and its
connection that is connecting a python
backend to a database like MySQL when it
comes to data science skills there's
numpy that is a library for performing
mathematical calculations
let's pandas that is the library for
storing and manipulating data
efficiently this sci-fi and then there's
matplotlib which is a library for
plotting charts and graphs for a given
data and finally there are machine
learning algorithms which consists of
models like supervised learning
unsupervised Etc now coming to web
developer skills there are Frameworks
like Django and flask for back-end
development of web applications
and then there's web scraping which
includes taking data from websites and
converting that data into usable format
there's API handling which is basically
handling API requests for a web
application to perform server-side
operations and finally there is back-end
connection which basically involves the
back-end part of a web application
usually handled by python Frameworks
now moving on let's look at the python
developer job roles
first up this python web developer now a
python web developer usually writes
server-side code works on the web
Frameworks like Django and flask
collaborates with the data team together
end users requirements develops the
server-side platform deploys
applications performs tuning usability
Improvement and automation
moving on next job role is data analyst
now a data analyst generally works on
python libraries including matplotlip
numpy pandas Etc carry out data analysis
collect by using the scripting language
explore data sets gather requirements
tune in applications analyze problems
communicate findings with the team or
stakeholders
the next job role is automation test
engineer
now an automation test engineer usually
works on python test framework tools
including Pi test Pi unit perform
complex system tests troubleshoot code
issues create test scripts design the
automation framework perform a b testing
next up is machine learning engineer
now a machine learning engineer has the
following roles to perform statistical
analysis of data put machine learning
models into production research and
transform data science prototypes
research and Implement appropriate ml
algorithms and tools perform ml tests
and keep updated with the ml trends
the last job role is software engineer
now a software engineer is expected to
write server-side code collaborate with
the design team to gather end users
requirements develop the server side
platform deploy applications perform
tuning usability Improvement and
automation
moving on to the next topic let's look
at the python developer salary trends
now software Engineers with python
skills are offered better salaries
across the globe
the average salary of a python developer
in India is around 7 lakhs 55 000 rupees
per annum the average salary of a python
developer in the US is about 79 000 US
dollars per annum
moving on to our last segment python
developer resume
so let's go ahead and understand what a
python developer resume should portray
just keep a few things in mind when
you're preparing your resume
your resume should be clear updated and
concise
you should prioritize the skills
according to the job role you're
applying for and do not write anything
extra that's a big no the recruiters are
smart enough to know that so do not lie
and do not write extra firstly let's
look at the fresher resume so if you're
a fresher these are some of the points
that you need to know
first you have the resume header now the
summary is supposed to be clear and
concise just say what exactly you want
and some of your strengths next is the
profile links and your portfolio so you
can mention your LinkedIn profile link
and also your GitHub repository link if
you have next up is the projects now
clearly depict the goal of your project
so just in case you worked on like C5
projects make sure you keep it concise
and crisp next up is your education do
not lie here make sure you give a
relevant education with grades next you
have the certifications if you have any
certifications or achievements go ahead
and write them down next you have the
technical skills now again prioritize
according to the job role and lastly you
have your non-technical skills this
could be your communication analytical
skills problem solving skills Etc moving
on to an experienced developer so again
mention the resume header
then you have the summary again very
crisp and clear go ahead and mention
your portfolios and your links coming to
experience now here you have to clearly
depict your work you'll have to make
sure that you write down all your
responsibilities in that company do not
go overboard and write extra keep it
very concise
again relevant education and your grades
you have technical skills the same goes
for this as well prioritize according to
the job Rule and finally you have your
non-technical skills now let's go over
some of the features of python and these
features are actually why it's
considered that using python is
advantageous over using other languages
so let's start with some of these points
now as we mentioned python is very it's
a very readable program code readability
is very important it's one of the design
philosophies behind this when it was
being developed it's very easy to learn
which is why python is an entry point
for many people that are just beginning
to learn programming and as I mentioned
earlier it's a high level language in
Python we since python is open source as
as I had already mentioned so it gets it
benefits from all the the benefits you
get from any open source technology now
it's also portable so what this means is
that if we create a code in in Python
and we create it in a particular system
here on Windows we don't need to make
any changes if we wanted to use the same
script or this is that same piece of
code on some other system say on a Linux
system or a Mac system python itself
comes with a very large standard Library
this this facilitates us a lot because
we don't need to create our own
libraries or modules or have to download
very specific libraries most of the
problems that we do encounter uh quite
commonly can already be solved by the
standard libraries that have already
been provided by the developers of
python right right from the beginning
now later on during the course we will
encounter what is the meaning of a data
structure a data structure is
essentially a manipulation of a if of an
object of an object of data and as as
you will see later python has one of the
most user-friendly data structures that
can be found in any language especially
compared to some of its contemporaries
now python is a dynamically programmed
language and this is very important and
what this means is that in most
compiler-based languages we there are
certain processes that can only happen
during the compilation stage so what a
dynamic programming language does is it
takes all those compilation specific
tasks and processes and it does it for
us as we actually type the code so we
don't need to waste time or spend extra
time to do something that would
otherwise be needed to be only done in
compilation we would have to set out
specific runtime just for that so this
allows us to create our programs and
solutions much faster and allows us to
debug much easier and yeah so it's a
it's a very important feature about
python Now quickly I will just go over
some of the areas of python where like
areas of or different domains where
python is very heavily implemented and
the first one the first few ones that
come to reminder like web development
and Ai and machine learning so you have
Technologies like Django and Flash that
are built on top of python that I use
extensively for web development when it
comes to something like artificial
intelligence or machine learning you
have distributions such as Anaconda you
have pandas and many other libraries
like scipy and numpy that are used
extensively too so tackle problems in
this domain and similarly python finds
used in most of the scientific work that
goes on nowadays because of again some
of the libraries that I have already
mentioned such as sci-fi interestingly
if you are into game development or
gaming in general you would see that
python actually has certain libraries
and certain technologies that facilitate
game development very very well one very
popular game in fifth in case you are
into gaming is a world of tanks that is
built on python some of the other
applications are of course desktop be
creating desktop guise image processing
graphic design applications and uh
something that is very relevant to me
and of course you as well is a creation
of education programs and training
courses uh there are many Technologies
in the environment of python that were
almost designed for the specific purpose
of being able to present certain
Concepts or to be able to teach certain
classes and I can't think of too many
programs or too many environments
outside of python that are better to
solve these Education and Training
course related problems and situations
let's uh let's get to actually
installing python so now that so I will
show you how to install python on
Windows since I have a Windows system uh
however I will also point out the way
you you would have to install python on
a on Mac OS or Linux or even on mobile
so yeah let's get started so to install
python on your Windows computer it's as
simple as going to the website
python.org and selecting the download
section when you reduce click on
downloads you get redirected to this
website that uh this webpage that I'm on
out here it by default it will ask you
if you want to download python 3.9 which
is the latest version but of course if
you for whatever reason if you needed a
particular version of python you can
download that as well by just scrolling
down and choosing the option that you
want now it's important to note that
whatever option you choose of course I
would recommend the latest one but no
matter what option you choose I would
recommend you choose a version of python
three point something because previous
versions of python namely Python 2.7 and
uh and basically every version of python
two point something has it will not
receive any more maintenance and updates
because the developers have decided that
python will that trying to shift towards
maintaining and updating python three
point whatever completely right now so
yeah let's not delay this uh any further
and let's download python 3.9 so once
you select the option out here uh you'll
be you'll get an installer all you have
to do is click on that and it will give
you two options to customize
installation or install now I would of
course recommend this blue install now
since you're a beginner do not worry
about what a custom installation is if
you have multiple drives in your system
by default the python will be downloaded
into uh the drive where your windows is
actually installed your your main drive
so as you can see now that once my setup
is done it should give me a pop-up soon
so my setup is done for Python and this
is essentially how you would
um download python on your Windows
system but what if you had Mac OS or if
you were using Linux well for Mac it's a
it's actually almost as simple you just
go if you see out here below this
download button python option you get
the website asking you are you looking
for python on a different OS and it
gives you the options of Linux Mac and
even other os's but for Mac if you
wanted you would just open this tab and
just like the windows option you would
choose a version and you would choose an
installer for that version so if I
wanted say python the latest one I would
just download this installer and I would
install in my Mac system now when it
comes to Linux I cannot show you exactly
how you would install it there are
certain commands that you have to
execute but essentially again if you
just choose the Linux option out here it
will take you to a page with a different
installers and essentially packages for
Linux systems in specific what I would
recommend to you if you are a Linux user
and you need python is to go over to the
realpython.com website and they have a
very good essentially instructions on
how to install Python and since I don't
have a Linux system I cannot directly
show you how to install python on Linux
so yeah if you do have Linux please head
over to this website and this should be
of a lot of help to you now as I had
mentioned you can actually install
python on your mobile devices as well so
if you were say an iOS user you would go
to the iOS App Store and download an app
called the python is the app for iOS it
essentially is like a full-fledged
python environment where you can develop
in Python on your iPhone or even iPad
and if you're an Android User you could
you would go and download an app called
the pi Droid 3. there's a free version
and a paid version for this app and of
course the difference between the free
and paid is that the paid supports uh
code analysis and code prediction these
are certain details you don't have to
worry about right now and honestly if I
wouldn't worry too much about installing
python on your mobile devices currently
since I am assuming most people would be
learning program programming and
programming in Python on their PCS or
laptops what I had actually shown you
was installing what is called an
implementation of python on your system
and implementation is essentially a
program or a software or an environment
that allows you to actually work in
Python so what I showed you was how to
install the by default or the most basic
or reference implementation that has
been created by the developers which is
actually called C python even though you
would not you would not have seen the
word the letter c or the prefix C but
yeah that implementation that I had I
had downloaded myself and I had shown
you to download is actually the C python
implementation which is python built on
top of C the the C language essentially
there are other implementations such as
iron python which uses the.net framework
and J python that uses Java virtual
machines that you could use if you were
interested but again these are things
that I would not worry about too much
right now so now that we have tackled on
how to install your implementation of
python I want to introduce what is
called a distribution to you this
distribution is called Anaconda Anaconda
is a very important distribution
especially if you are looking to use
python in data science and machine
learning and AI which I am assuming is
the motivation for many of the people
that are actually watching this video
that they actually want to move into
data science and they need to learn
python as a foundation towards moving
towards data science and if that is your
goal or in any case whatever your goal
may be I would recommend that you
install Anaconda distribution now do not
get confused between anaconda and python
their Anaconda is python with in the
form of a bundle and this bundle
contains not only the basic python
implementation that I had shown you to
download but it contains a lot of extra
libraries and Technologies and software
as well so of course this means that
what you need to download both of course
not if you download a python you do not
need Anaconda to work on Python and if
you have already downloaded Anaconda
which I will show you how to do it in
some time if you have already downloaded
Anaconda you don't need to download
python separately so I'll just speak
about Anaconda little briefly so as I
said it's a distribution it it contains
a bundle which includes the basic python
implementation and a lot of Technologies
and softwares and applications that has
essentially help us to use python in in
in specifically managing their big data
applications and data science related
projects so so now I will show you
actually how to install python I mean
anaconda on your system it's as simple
as it's actually as simple as
downloading just this thing so if I did
a quick quick Google Anaconda
so the website that I'm looking for is
anaconda.com and I'm looking at products
and I'm looking at individual Edition
there are other editions as well like
commercial Team edition these are for
companies usually or uh for more
professional sort of projects so of
course we are looking at the individual
Edition and if you selected this page
you would be taken to this particular
web page where It'll ask you if you want
to download and again there are options
depending on which machine you're using
if you're using a Linux you would choose
one of these two if you are using Mac OS
you would use one of these two and since
I am a Windows user and I have a 64-bit
system this is the option I would use so
again it will it will first download and
install it for you and as you can see my
installer has been downloaded so upon
opening it it will open up this
installation thing you can you can just
click next on most of these again if you
want to specify your destination folder
you can change it here mine will be with
a default folder in the C drive and you
can leave this unticked you can you can
change these options much later so this
is how you install anaconda and windows
and it's pretty much the same on other
systems as well now once it's done I
will show you what exactly what are some
of the things that Anaconda contains
that are not there if you installed
python like the way I had shown you
earlier just the bare bones python
implementation so as you can see here my
installation is actually complete and
now I will open anaconda and I'll show
you what how you can actually use this
Anaconda so if I search for anaconda in
my system I would look for something
called Anaconda navigator to actually
get started with this and when I open
that it should open something like this
so this is what opens when you click on
the Anaconda Navigator and as you can
see there are a bunch of applications
you don't need to worry about what these
mean right now just understand that this
this is essentially a bundle of uh
different applications and technologies
that come along with just the normal
installation of python that you get when
you install Anaconda Navigator now now
that we have actually tackled where
we've seen how to install and I'm hoping
and I would recommend definitely that
everyone is watching this video installs
Anaconda not just the normal python
installation or implementation now that
we have gotten all the introductions and
the basics and the installations
regarding python aside let's get right
let's get down to actually creating our
first script so now the question is how
do we actually start doing this task of
creating our first python script how do
we how do we realize uh now that we've
installed uh python like uh now let's
how do we start doing something so the
answer to that question is that
typically when you're working on python
the one of the most basic thing that you
can do is create a python script and
execute a script script is a essentially
a sequence of commands and instructions
that you give for python to run and
execute to give you a certain result so
I will show you how you can create a
python script now there are multiple
ways of creating a python script you can
create it directly from command line
which is obviously something I would not
recommend because it is not convenient
and easy and it's not very useful for a
beginner another way is using a text
editor such as the one I have opened
right now which is the notepad plus plus
text editor now it's very important to
not get confused between notepad plus
plus and the standard notepad that comes
with your windows or wordpad for that
matter in fact text editors such as
notepad and wordpad that you are more
familiar with create text and files in a
form that is called Rich Text Now Rich
Text is something is text that contains
formatting thing and fonts which is
actually a hindrance when it comes to
creating actual code so what we need is
a text editor that creates or writes
text in what we call as plain text plain
text is obviously text which does not
contain these fonts and these
formattings and it only respects white
spaces and indentations those two being
actually useful towards creating code
unlike fonts and formatting which are
only a visual thing so notepad plus plus
is obviously a text editor that creates
a plain text documents that is very that
was actually created with programming in
mind obviously you can use a bunch of
other text editors such as vim and atom
and you can Google for these there are
plenty of them so without any further
Ado let's create our first python script
so one of the most common one of the
most famous examples of it a first
program in any program for that matter
not just python is creating a print
statement that gives us a statement
saying hello world so enter in Python
this is how you would go about oh this
is the syntax you would use to create
the statement all right now weight is
very important when you are saving your
Python program that you use the dot py
prefix so so if I were to save this I
can choose whatever folder I am going to
choose yeah this folder seems fine so
now I give the file name over here as
say I want to keep it as test I need to
prefix this Dot py and this tells any uh
sort of interpreter or anytime we need
to read the script to know that it's a
python script we need to add a DOT py
otherwise it will not be treated as a
python script it'll be treated as some
normal document sort of a thing so now
that I have stored it as dot py I have
created my first python script now
obviously the next question is I need to
see what happens when I execute this
line when I run this script essentially
so to see that there are multiple ways
the first way that I will show you is a
command line method which is obviously 3
again before we get into it it's not
something that I will be using to teach
you it's not something I would recommend
you to immediately start using
um but for the sake of showing I will
show you how to execute a script in
command line well to do this you go
since I have installed anaconda in my
system and I will be using Anaconda to
work in Python what I will look for is
something called the Anaconda prompt as
you can see this is the option that I
get Anaconda prompt this will
essentially open you a command line
under the environment of anaconda or
python so in this now I am already in
the folder I believe that had my script
so how do I call this script or how do I
run this script well the command is
python space the name of my file which
was test of course the prefix is very
important so I enter test.py if you if
this was in a different folder you would
have to change your folders in command
line which is again something that I
might show you later but since my file
is already in the folder that I am in in
my command line I would just have to
enter this Command right now so if I
execute this as you can see it's given
me an output of hello world which is
which is what I wanted I wanted it to
print this uh these two words and of
course the command line is now waiting
for the next command for me so this is
uh one of the most simple ways for the
most rudimentary ways of executing a
python script now another question would
be well this isn't the most visually
appealing or not the easy to read or
easy to use way of executing scripts and
I would agree and that's why I'm going
to introduce a another technology or a
software called the IDE so the IDE in
python or in any programming language
stands for integrated development
environment it's essentially a software
that not only allows us to run scripts
but it allows us to create the scripts
it allows us to debug it allows us to
see outputs it allows us to the
intermediary outputs it allows us to do
a wide variety of tools and tasks and it
comes with a bunch of robust features to
enhance our Python programming
experience so let's let's see so I will
show you a an IDE called spider which
comes bundled along with the Anaconda
distribution that I had mentioned
earlier so if I open the Anaconda
Navigator as you can see the Anaconda
Navigator shows me a bunch of
Technologies and options and I'm looking
for something called the spider IDE
which is over here as you see here it's
a Scientific Python development
environment this is exactly what I'm
looking for so I am looking to launch
this so now that I've launched it you
can see out here this is what an IDE
looks like now this looks very
sophisticated and it's a it's a one and
any almost any IDE is a wonderful
software that where you can create your
code you can debug your code you can
check the results you can make
adjustments changes and you can do a
wide variety of tasks and functions with
relation to your programming so this is
the spider ID in particular and this is
how it looks don't worry about the exact
details just know that on this left hand
pane is our current script that is open
out here and out here we will get the
results in this this is what we call a
console console essentially
so now that we have we have already
created our script in notepad plus plus
and I want to open that script and I
want to see uh how an i how it would the
result of that script would look in an
IDE so let's just open it so we can
browse for our file and as I had named
it test this is the file over here I
open this and as you can see out here in
the left hand pane my script has opened
and the commander had given or had
written is out over here now if I want
to run this application I press this
green button and as you can see the
result of my my execution essentially is
over here it's in slightly small font
but as you can see over here it says
hello world and its way and the next
line is essentially it's it's waiting
for me to do another execution of the
script and then it will give me new
results so let's actually give the
system new results so now that I have
printed something called hello world
let's let's change what's written over
here let's say I will perform
basic maths all right and let's actually
perform the basic maths again don't
worry about the details the syntax uh
what I'm exactly doing these things that
we will actually cover in the in
upcoming videos and modules so let's
create a variable called a let's store a
number three let's create a variable B
Story number five all right let's create
another variable C uh which will store
the result of what's in a and b in the
addition of A and B all right and let's
print the result or print what's in uh
this variable C or what's the result of
a plus b I will print a statement saying
the result of the addition of three and
five is all right and I will put my
result over here as you can see I should
get the result in this pane so let's
execute this and you can see uh my first
line is executed saying I will perform
basic maths and the next line says the
result of the addition of three and five
is eight so this in this script what
I've done is I have performed uh two
print statements and I performed a basic
expression some variable assignments all
of these things we will be doing later
this is what I what I'm essentially
trying to show you is that Ides are a
very convenient way of not only creating
the scripts but actually seeing the
results and then making adjustments as
well we can come we can create a
completely new script we don't need to
create a script from some special file
or text editor I can just create a new
file here and this is my new script
essentially so I can start working on
with this new script right over here
from the get go so Ides are very
powerful spider IDE comes bundled with
Anaconda there are other ideas such as
the idle IDE it stands for
indicated development and learning
environment so the idle IDE comes as
part of the basic python implementation
that I had shown you in the previous
video where you if you just installed a
basic uh python implementation it would
come along with a basic IDE known as
Idle or integrated development and
learning environment but of course since
we are using Python and this is what I
would recommend it comes with a more
robust IDE called spider which is
actually very very helpful for
scientific and numeric applications and
was designed specifically with that in
mind now this is not the only way we can
actually work with python there's
another very interesting and a very
educative method of it in Python let's
say python programs and it's something
that I will be using extensively
throughout this course to explain
different concepts so this technology is
called or the software is called uh
notebooks now before I get into the
details I will state I will just open
node a basic notebook so the notebook
that comes as part of anaconda is called
the Jupiter notebook and when I open
when I launched the jupyter notebook
this is what I get now a very important
feature or a a feature of notebooks is
that notebooks are a web browser or a
web-based application so you it's not
something that you can use if you are
offline or disconnected basically if
you're disconnected from the internet it
is something where which for which you
would need an active internet connection
however it is way more robust and it has
very very good properties that allow it
to be used in education or for
presentation and such so as you can see
this is my Jupiter notebook these are a
bunch of folders don't need to worry
about what these are right now I will
show you how to create a fresh notebook
so if you go here and you go to new and
you select under notebook the Python 3
option it will open you your first
notebook as you can see this line is
essentially waiting for me to enter some
sort of a command or a statement that I
would give in a normal python thing now
if you would have noticed the diff in uh
until now everything that we were doing
involved us creating a script which was
the whole series of commands and
functions so if I go back to my spider
IDE as you can see like this is a whole
script and this script contains multiple
different tasks and functions that are
individually being performed so this is
a separate print function this is a
separate Edition another separated print
function and for longer programs or
larger program Rams you like you have
multiple different tasks being done and
if you were using a script you can only
see the result of something like this by
executing the whole thing at once you
cannot see exactly like what is the
result of just this print statement or
just this uh it's not typically what an
IDE is used for and this is where
notebooks come in super handy if I had
to break down my previous script
essentially where I first did a print
statement where I said some random thing
say hello
yeah so if I execute this particular
line you can see it gives me the result
now I want to do what is 5 plus 3 it
should give me the result over here
eight now in the next another part of
your program might be storing five and
three into variables so I can do this
and I can do this so now this line will
store the variables now I want to do the
addition of what is five plus three but
I want to use the variables and I want
to see what's the result as you can see
a plus b means 5 plus 3 which is 8 and
I've essentially broken down various
different parts of my previous script
into into its individual tasks and I'm
able to see what each part of that
script does and this is very good when
it comes to making presentations or
trying to teach a class so I will
personally be using notebooks a lot to
explain different different concepts of
um different concepts when it comes to
Python and I would recommend that you
get used to notebooks in general because
it's an amazing way to Learn Python
Programming or programming in general in
fact and again as I had mentioned
earlier notebooks are something that
it's an online application it's a
web-based application so I will have to
need a active internet connection to be
able to work on a notebook which could
be a disadvantage if you do not have a
consistent internet connection and in
that case you would probably use your
Ides or text editors which you can be
used offline as well in this video we
will be introduced to the concept of
variables and expressions let's start
with Expressions well an expression in
Python is anything that results in a
value its difference although the
difference between an expression and a
standard statement in Python is that a
statement in Python is something that
results in an action or an execution of
a command there is no calculation per se
or any sort of manipulation or as I said
earlier calculation resulting in between
two different same numbers or other
objects that results in a value and this
happens in the case of an expression so
for example if I were to add two numbers
say 5 plus 10 this is an expression
which should where two objects 5 and 10
are being added and a result has been
given to me which is 15. now let's see
an example of a statement well a
statement could be something like a
print statement so when I ask python to
print something for me it's not
calculating anything it's not evaluating
anything it's simply performing an
action that I have or a command that I
have given the system which is to print
whatever I have entered over here as you
can see so this is a statement similarly
there are another type of statement
known as assignment statements which we
will learn actually right in the next
section well let's move on to variables
right now now earlier you might have
learned about objects in Python so
objects are essentially data that we can
work with a manipulate in Python now
variables are a place to store these
different objects
usually it's much easier to store
objects in Python instead of using the
objects explicitly themselves because
objects may be very compute complicated
whereas variables are very simple to use
and very simply very are named in a very
simple manner so that we can use them
quite often in our programs now it's
important to note that in Python we do
not have to explicitly declare or Define
a variable to create them in fact
variables are created in the same
statement where we assign some object to
the variable in Python the assignment of
variables happens using the assignment
operator which is the equals to sign so
if I were to if I wanted to assign a
number say 100 to a variable say B well
it would be as simple as doing this now
anytime I want to know what is stored in
B I just have to enter B and I will get
the value that is stored in it and we
can store different types of objects
inside any variable let's say I store I
want to store this particular word in
the form of a string now this is stored
in X and if I want to know what is an X
I can just see what is here and it's a
string hello which I had stored earlier
now it's very important that we follow
certain naming rules when it comes to
naming our variables in python or else
we may be thrown error so we might get
some problems in our program so the
first rule is that you cannot start your
variable name with a number so if I were
to give a variable name like 4 num is
equal to something say the same string
hello this would be an illegal variable
name and I would get an error when I try
this so if I were to choose a num 4 is
equal to hello this would be perfectly
fine I won't get an error the second
rule is we are not allowed to use any
non-alphanumeric characters except the
underscore character while naming our
variable so for example if I were to
name my variable num underscore 4 and I
stay I said random some random string
this is perfectly fine however if I
change num underscore 4 to num hyphen 4
this will throw me an error as you can
see over here next the third rule is
that variable names are case sensitive
so if if I have a variable called num or
say n-u-m if this was one of my
variables and I stored say the value 50.
this is not the same as me writing num
all in capitals and say storing some
other value 60 these are two different
variables so it's very important that
when you name your variables you are
aware of what case you are writing them
in because python variables are case
sensitive now the final and probably one
of the most important rules in Python is
that you're not allowed to use what we
call Reserve words in Python now python
has a bunch of reserved words these
words essentially are performed or they
are used to perform certain special
functions and are user identifiers for
certain special functions in Python that
we that have a special purpose like that
particular word has a special purpose
within the Python programming language
and you cannot use them to name our
variables so a list of them as you can
see over here some of them are like
false def if Del Rays and there are like
are there are around 33 of them and
sometimes some of these words are taken
out sometimes there are more words added
as python gets updated now let's let's
move on to a concept uh where we try to
really understand what do we mean by
storing data inside a variable now when
I say that we are storing something
inside a variable you get an image or
you get an idea in your head that this
variable is like a container where we
store or we put a particular object
inside it so does this mean that
variables have a place in the memory are
they are also an object that is placed
in the memory where we can put other
objects inside of well I'll show you an
example where this idea is kind of
disproven or where I'll show you that
the idea of variable is kind of
different than what we understand by
storing something inside a variable now
let's say I'm storing the same object I
will take this object as some random
number let's say 100 and I'm going to
store it into two different variables so
I take X is equal to 100 over here and
in the next line I will store 100 in y
as well now if objects were I mean if
variables were objects that we placed in
our system then X and Y should have two
different IDs but let's see what happens
when I check the ID of X and the ID of Y
they should be different in case
variables were their own objects however
as you can see the ID of X and the ID of
Y are exactly the same so well obviously
we know that two different objects in
Python cannot have the same ID so does
this so what does this mean when it
comes to the nature of a variable well
the the fact is that variables are not
actually objects in Python in fact
variables are more like pointers or
references to the actual object so when
I said X is equal to 100 and Y is equal
to 100 what I am actually telling the
system is that there is this variable
name called X that I want to refer or
Point towards the actual object that is
in my memory called 100 and I do the
same thing with another variable y so I
am not exactly creating a different
space in my system for these variables
these variables are more like
placeholders or references that point to
a particular place in the memory where
this object is located and that is what
happens when I do ID of X and ID of 5
it's not giving me the idea of something
called X or the ID of something called Y
is giving me the ID of 100 each time
because 100 is stored in X and Y so as
you can see this is something like a
visual representation of what I'm trying
to say and similarly if if I were to so
in this example on the left as you can
see I've used the value of 50 to explain
my point so as you can see initially X
and Y are pointing towards this value 50
because I have stored 50 and 50 in both
X and Y now what if I changed the object
that is stored in X well that means X is
now pointing towards this new object and
I have stored this new object called
hello the string called hello as you can
see here so now X is pointing to a new
object in the system and it's called
hello and I haven't changed anything
with respect to Y so y will Point
towards the same thing and I can also
make the pointer of Y different or what
I'm trying to say is I can store
something else and Y see I stored this
list in y 50 1600 and when I do that now
Y is pointing towards a different object
in Python and X is also pointing towards
something else so what happens to this
object 50 well now that there's no
variable referring to this object 50 it
becomes what we call an orphaned object
and we can actually see that when we do
the ID of X now let's go back to my
example on the right where I stored X is
equal to 100 so as you can see it gives
me some ID represented by this number
now let's say I stored x i stored
something different say 200 now if I do
the ID of X as you can see variables are
they should be and they are treated more
like references or pointers instead of
containers for a particular object in
this video you will be introduced to the
concept of objects in Python now what
are objects in Python well all the data
that we manipulate or use in our
operations in our code are represented
as objects or relations between objects
so if you want an example two numbers
that you add in your code well both of
them are objects and the usually numeric
type objects similarly if you want to
store someone's name or an address of
your hometown in your code you usually
store it in a form of text and that text
is also an object usually a string
similarly you might want to create a
container of different smaller objects
inside them and that big container is
also a type of an object effect and one
of those containers are called lists and
similarly we have many different types
of objects which we will be covering
during the duration of this course the
following pictorial representation gives
us a broad classification of different
python data types and objects as we can
see there are five broad classifications
numeric which contains integers complex
numbers and floats we have the
dictionary data type we have the Boolean
which essentially consists of objects
that have only two valid values true or
false then we have sets and we have
sequence data types such as strings
lists and tuples every object in Python
has three important properties that kind
of Define that particular object they
are its identity its type and its value
the identity of an object is it can be
considered as a place in the memory or
its address in the memory where an
object is stored an object's identity
does not change one at once it has been
and created so for example if I took an
example of say a string called hello I
can use the ID function which is this is
how you use the ID function to find out
the ID of this object and it should be
the answer should be in the form of a
particular long integer so as you can
see the ID of hello is this integer two
three two six four seven six six two
three zero two four similarly all
objects in Python have an identity we
have another operation with regarding
the identity of an object it's the is
operator and the is operator compares
the identity of two objects so if two
objects have the same identity it should
give the answer true otherwise false now
the next property of objects is the type
type of an object is essentially what
defines what kind of values and
operations that that object can have so
for example in numeric data type in
Python such as an integer would allow us
to do arithmetic operations and
similarly string object type in Python
will allow us to do concatenation
operations much like its identity the
type of an object cannot be changed as
well now let's see what's the type of
that particular object that I had shown
you above as you can see it should be
string Str stands for string similarly
if I did a type for a number say 50 it
should give me int as you can see now
the third property of an object in
Python is its value now the value is the
actual data that is contained in the
object it's the thing that we use that
we display that we can manipulate and
that we can perform operations on so for
example if I were to talk about this
string this string is hello so the value
of the string is the word or the
sequence of letters that spell out hello
and similarly this particular object is
a numeric object with the value of 50.
let's see in this in this pictorial
representation I have shown you that you
can assume this dodge Blue Area as the
memory of the system now within this
memory we have objects created called 50
and hello and this list containing
smaller objects called cat pen and 40.
now what I'm trying to show you here is
each of these objects have a type and I
already seen the type of 50. now let's
find the ID of 50. as you can see we get
this unique ID for the object 50 which
is obviously not the same as the ID of
the object hello above and the value of
this object is the value of s50 itself
so that was a brief introduction into
objects in Python in this video we will
cover the topics of numeric object types
and type conversions in Python now let's
get started numeric object types in
Python are a broad classification of
objects plenty of common real life
applications that we associate with
numerals such as arithmetic operations
and calculus are done in Python using
numeric object data types there are
three main types of numerals or numeric
data types in Python they are integers
float and complex integers as the name
suggests represent all integer values in
Python these can be such as 100 minus 3
to 305 and so on floats are used to
represent new models that contain
decimal points such as 100.3 3.9 4.8
minus 6.8 and so on then there is the
complex object type which is used to
represent complex numbers in Python and
this is an example of a complex number 3
plus 7j this is a complex number three
plus seven J where the real component is
3 and the imaginary component is 7. all
complex numbers have a real and an
imaginary component and this is how we
denote them now it's important to note
that this J is a very common symbol in
maths and Engineering used to denote the
image engineering portion of a complex
number and it's the same in python as
well so moving on let's talk about type
conversion in Python type conversion
refers to the conversion of an object
from one data type to another for
example from string to an integer and
there are different types of conversions
and let's go through some of them first
of all let's consider the conversion of
something to an integer and more
specifically let's consider the example
where we convert a string to an integer
so let's consider my example string to
be some something called 145 and I'm
sewing this within a string for a reason
because I want to convert a string to an
integer so as you can see I have stored
this one for 5 within my within a
variable X and if I were to confirm that
is actually an integer I can use the
type function and see that it is
actually an integer Str now let's
convert this into an integer using the
int function so how would we use it is
simply passing the End by passing the
variable that we want to convert into
the in function and as you can see this
is what I've done over here but before
this I will also store it into another
variable all right now let's see what's
in y well y gives us 145 but are we sure
that it's an end you can just check it
by using the type function and as you
can see the type gives us the answer end
that means that we've converted the
string to an end interestingly we can
convert something and also specify what
base we have to treat the number as by
default when we pass something in the in
function the program or python will
treat whatever we have passed within the
string as something in base sub decimal
but what if we were to pass something
that is well not in a decimal we could
do it like this now let's store y I and
in y let's store
let's do this and I will show you what
this means X and I will give a comma and
8 what this tells python is well I want
to convert the string in X into an
integer but I want to treat whatever is
an X as a number of Base 8 so 145 is
actually 145 in the base 8. now when we
see what's in y we get 101 which is
different to 145 because well 1 0 1 is
actually the decimal equivalent of 145
in the base 8. similarly if we were to
give it in the base 2 we would just
replace 8 with 2 over here now next
let's talk about converting something to
a float now as we know float is just
simply something that has a decimal
point so let's convert an integer into a
float how would we do that simply by
using the float function so if I give
120 and I pass this integer through the
float function I should get 120.0 and
these two are not the same though they
may mean the same things to us but in
for python 120 is an integer and one
with 120.0 is a different object which
is a float and this is how we convert
something to a float now what if we
wanted to convert an integer to a string
well we can use the Str function we can
also use the hex and the awk function if
we want to convert a particular number
to a hexadecimal or an octal string
respectively let's look at all three
examples say I have a number 688 and I
want to convert this into a string I
just use the Str function around this so
as we know just to confirm let's see
what the type of 688 is this is this
should be an end as we can see but when
we pass when we let's say we convert it
into a string 688 and let's store it
into some variable let's call it a all
right now let's see what's in a it gives
us 688 in the form of a string but we
can confirm by checking the type of a it
is an Str so it is a string similarly we
can use hex if we wanted to convert an
integer into its hexadecimal equivalent
in the in in as an output of a string as
you can see this complex is sort of
complicated thing is actually telling us
that we have converted 688 in terms of
hexadecimals now how do we read this
output this zero should not be treated
as anything it's more like a an
identifier which says that the letter
after this first 0 is the base of this
whole number so it's saying that x x
stands for hexadecimal so it's saying
that 2 B 0 is to be treated as a
hexadecimal number and if you did basic
maths you would find that the decimal
equivalent of 2b0 is 688 similarly if I
did opt if I use the opt function for
688 it will give me the result something
like this so again how to read this the
first 0 is to be treated as an
identifier and not part of the number
what it's saying is the letter after the
first or after this 0 is the base of the
number following these two following
these two characters so as you can see
as you can see what's this saying is
that this whole number is an OCT
represented by this letter O and the
number itself that we are dealing with
is one two six zero and one two six zero
in octave system is the equivalent of
688 in the decimal system so this is how
we've converted a an integer in an
integer into a hexadecimal or a an octal
string now what if we wanted to convert
two numeric objects into a complex data
object well for that we can use the
complex function as you can see here
if I passed complex 5 and say say
something like 3.1 let's see what this
gives us as you can see it gives us an a
complex object where our real part is 5
and our imaginary part is 3.1 so what
this does is essentially you pass two
numbers the first one is the real
component and the second is the
imaginary component it combines to give
you a complex number as you can see here
now let's look at some other type
conversions the next type we will be
talking about is converting something to
a tuple or a set or a list so what if I
wanted to convert a string into a tuple
I will use the Tuple function and as you
can see over here so let's say I have a
string called random let's call it
random all right now if I want to
convert this to a tuple I will use the
Tuple function as you can see over here
the output will give me tuples where
each individual compound end of this
Tuple are the individual components or
the individual characters of my string
random similarly if I wanted to convert
the string to a list I would use the
list function and this will give me a
list of the individual characters of the
word or the the string random and I
could do the same thing with the set
function to create a set of individual
characters of the string random as you
can see here so yeah these were some of
the basic python type conversions that I
have shown you as we learn about more
complex data types and different object
types in Python we will learn different
type conversions and functions
associated with them in this video you
will be introduced to the concept of
strings strings are an object type in
Python used to store textual data this
textual data could be something like for
example someone's name it could be an
address of a place or it could be
something like a word or a sentence now
strings in Python are an object type
that is actually a subtype of a broader
classification of objects called
sequences sequences are objects in
Python which contain components placed
one of the other where each component is
given what we call an index a numeric
Index this numeric index identifies the
component in the sequence and
disposition within the sequence now
since python is a zero index based
language the first object of any
sequence is always index 0 the second is
index 1 the third is index 2 and so on
now let's move on to defining strings
how do we Define them well strings are
defined using what we call delimiters
and delimiters occur in pairs in opening
and a closing delimiter in Python these
derivators are pairs of single or double
quotes so for example if I were to use
single quotes to define a string I could
I would do it like this this is a string
as you can see this is a string is
printed over here this is delimited
using single quotes similarly if I were
to define a string using double quotes
it's as simple as doing this this is
also a
as you can see now a valid question
arises what if I wanted to include a
single quote within my string well if I
try to let's see what happens if I try
to print a statement with a single quote
naturally inside it so say I'm saying
it's my birthday all right let's see
what happens if I try to print this
statement it says invalid syntax and
this is because as I had mentioned in
Python single quotes and double quotes
are delimiters so they have a special
function in Python and we cannot simply
just use them within a string because
python will treat them specially for a
special purpose so what python will do
is it will pair this and this delimiter
so single quotes and say okay this looks
like a string to me and it's not going
to understand the rest of this and then
it will find a random single quote and
it won't find its pair and it will
basically throw us an error because of
this so one way or one word around to
introduce single quotes into a string is
simply to delimit our string itself
using the other type of delimiter or
double quotes So if I want to include a
single quote I will close my string
using double quotes So if I did this
instead of what I had done earlier
this is a perfectly valid and legal way
of defining my string and I could I
would do the opposite if I had to
introduce a double quotes within my
string I would use single quotes to
close it so if I were to write a speech
statement she said
I am
hungry all right I have I want these two
double quotes to essentially show that
this is a speech and I'm gonna close the
string using single quotes and this is a
valid way of doing it as you can see my
string has this two double quotes now I
had mentioned that strings are sequences
well let's describe how other sequences
so first of all all sequences in Python
are a
um it's a essentially a sequence of
smaller objects that form the sequence
right so let's try to understand like
how do how are strings to be treated as
sequences some sequences that we will
learn later are like lists or tuples and
in all sequences we can retrieve any
particular object or component in that
sequence using its index and how do we
use indexes in Python well we enclose a
numeric index within square brackets now
let's see what I'm trying to talk about
by this example now say I'm storing a
particular string called say random
within so now my variable name here is
test and I'm storing the string random
within it all right and this is the way
of retrieving a particular index from
test I write the variable name and then
next to it I put the square brackets now
I'm supposed to put a numeral within the
square brackets to tell python like what
a particular index I'm looking for so
let's try 0. now as I said python is
zero index based language so the zero
index essentially means the first part
of or the first component of a sequence
so let's see what happens when I ask
python to retrieve the first part of
what is stored in test it gives me the
string R in fact it's just one character
R and it's a string so as you can see it
has given me the first character of the
string random which is R so what this
shows is that this string random is
essentially a collection or a sequence
of one character strings so this is so
Random is essentially a collection of
the string R the string a the string n
and so on together combined to form the
whole string that we call random
similarly if I wanted the character at
the third position of this thing I would
use well since the third position and
since we're working in Python I would
use the index too and it should give me
the letter n as you can see it's given
me the letter N so this is how we can
show that strings are also sequences in
Python well now let's move on to certain
string operations and functions that we
can perform well as you have seen
already that we can retrieve any
particular character within a
um within a string using numeric indexes
well what if we wanted to know what
index is a particular character at and
we can do it like this we use the index
function so let's say my test and I want
to know where where or what position the
character D is in my string random so
this is how I would use the index
function index and within the index say
I'm looking for the character D and now
I it should give me the answer 0 1 2 it
should give me the answer three so if I
execute this it gives me the index 3. so
this is uh the index function that we
could use for our strings now what if we
want to
um say slice a string into a into its uh
into a smaller part you want to slice it
and we want to retrieve only that
particular size well here is an example
say I'm gonna I'm gonna use the same
string called random and stored in test
right so let's so one way of so the way
of doing this is like this
now let's see what this let's just see
what this does first as you can see it's
given me a and d and if I went to my
string random A and D is this particular
slice now let's try to understand what I
have done by entering one colon for well
what this has done is it's retrieved a
slice from the first position uh the
first index which is the character a up
until the fourth position which is the
character o but it has not included o so
it's very important when I index like
this every every time I put something to
the right of this colon I am not
including this itself all right so it's
essentially one when I say one colon
four what I'm telling python is give me
the first the second and the third
character but not the fourth one so it's
given me a n and d and it's that's this
is how we do a slicing operation in
Python similarly if I were to say slice
from the first if I wanted only first
and the second character I would do this
is what I would do if I wanted the first
and the second character I would do one
two three so this way it sets python
that I want the first I want the second
but not the third off so as you can see
I get a and N now so this is a basic
slicing what if I wanted the portion of
a string from a particular Point all the
way to the right or all the way to the
left well let's consider the example of
where I want the portion of the string
random from the say fourth character
until the left well the way I would do
this is test now since I want it all the
way to the left I don't enter any index
to the left of my colon sign and since I
want everything to the left of the
fourth character I enter 4 here so as
you can see it gives me A R A and D
which is everything from the fourth
character of my string random to the
left similarly if I wanted something to
the right of it I would just do it like
this I would enter some index here and I
I would leave the portion to the right
of the colon blank so this will give me
everything including the third character
since this is how we treat the indexing
in Python everything including the third
character all the way to the right so
this is Dom as you can see now another
perfectly valid um slicing is say I want
to slice or take out different
characters from the string but I want to
skip certain characters like I want this
one then I want to skip one and I want
to take the next one and then I want to
skip one well in that case we have to
introduce a step so one way of doing
this is now how do we read this so as
you can see I've written 0 colon six
colon two so what this is telling python
is I want every character from my string
test starting from the zeroth character
up until the sixth but not including the
sixth after skipping or taking two at a
time taking two at a time can also be
assumed as uh skipping one at each step
or skipping one character at each step
so what this will do is it will go to
random it will take the zeroth one we'll
take R and then it will skip the next
one so it will not consider a and then
it will pick n and then it will not
consider D and then it will consider o
up until the sixth character whichever
that whichever that may be and if you
see the output it gives us R and O which
is exactly what we wanted we wanted R we
wanted n we wanted o where we skipped uh
A and D or we skipped the every second
character essentially so this is a way
of um slicing strings while also
skipping certain characters or skipping
characters and steps now python is also
an uh there's another interesting
technique that we can use in Python to
where we can start retrieving characters
from the rightmost side of a sequence or
a string we can use negative indexes so
if I were to for example show you let's
see what this what this gives me test
what what is the minus one index it
gives me the character M now remember a
string Is Random so minus 1 gave us the
last character of the string random
which was m so this is a way of using
negative indexes and similarly if I used
to test minus 2 it would give me the
second last character which should be
the character o as you can see here now
there are some other important functions
that you may use in Python for that
let's create another let's create
another string let's call it upper lower
all right now I'm sorting it again in
the same variable test let's see what
happens when I use the upper function
and what happens when I use the lower
function
now I'm going to use the lower function
for this so these two functions will
respectively give out or give us the
result or give us our string in
uppercase and lowercase respectively so
as you can see the upper function
created the first string in full upper
case and the second one created this by
the string in four lower case now
another important and probably one of
the most important methods that we use
for Strings especially when it comes to
data science is the split function so
let's see what I mean by split function
let me create another string let's call
it hello world
all right I'm going to use a split
function and I'm going to see what
happens when I use this function
essentially so what I'm doing in these
in this these three lines is I'm
creating the string hello world I am
storing it in test and then I am using
the split function on the test and
whatever result I get I'm storing
another variable called sliced and then
I'm just going to show you what is in
sliced as you can see what's happened to
the string hello world is that I have
broken it into its components or its
component words if that makes any sense
into hello and world and I stored both
of these into what we call a list now
you might ask well how does python know
that it has to separate at a blank space
well the split function by default will
break up a string at its blank spaces
but if we wanted we could break it up
using or at every comma so for example
if I wrote hello world using comma and
if I put a comma inside over here and
now if I try to execute this
like for example I am going to find I'm
going to look for commas in the string
and I'm going to try to split it as you
can see there's no splitting happening I
have one list with my original string
itself because it's not found a comma
what if I introduced a comma over here
now let's see what happens as you can
see the splitting has happened it's
found this comma and is caused a split
between hello and World similarly if I
in my string if I put this comma again
and I put something else it should give
me the split over there again so we can
Define our split using some whatever we
put between these Circle brackets after
the split function it's just important
to note that by default if in case we do
not enter anything over here it will use
blank spaces to do the splitting another
very important operation and very common
operation in strings is what we call
concatenation so if I have two strings
first and say another string second and
I want to join these together well the
operator I would use to do this is
called the plus symbol this is the
concatenating operator when it comes to
Strings so what is the result of this
let's see let's print this out let's
print this whole thing and let's see
what is the result as you can see what
uh this has done is it has combined the
first string first and the string second
into one string called first second so
this is the concatenate concatenation
operator now finally uh the last Topic
in this lesson is the topic of Escape
sequences now Escape sequences are
special commands that tell python to
either suppress special meaning of some
character or symbol in a string or give
or give the special or give some special
meaning to an otherwise ordinary
character in a string so let's look at
the first example now remember my in my
for earlier in this video where I was I
was telling you like what what is the
way of writing or how do we introduce
single quotes or double quotes into a
string and I had told you the trick if I
want to use a single coat in my string I
just close it using double quotes or if
I want to use a double quote I close it
using single well another way of doing
this is using what we call an escape
sequence and an escape sequence in
Python is the backslash character all
right so let's see what happens when I
use the backslash character where I want
to introduce my single code so if I use
my previous example where I wanted to
introduce a single quote and say I am
going to close it using single quotes as
well so I'm going to go back to my error
example so as to speak now this would
throw me an error right as you can see
it has thrown me an error so what if I
used the escape sequence that I
mentioned the Escape sequences is
backslash character now this is the
point of the string where I want my my
single code so I introduce a backslash
now I have my single quote and I
continue writing the rest of my
statement let's close the string now
will this work as you can see this has
worked so what this has done is this
backslash character has told python do
not trade this special character or the
single code to not treat it specially
and let it be as a part of the string so
as you can see that's what's happened
here now the next case or the other uh
use case of Escape sequences is when we
want to give a particular character that
is otherwise just ordinary some special
meaning so let's take the example of the
character T and the character n we use
the character T to introduce tab space
and Views a character in to introduce
what we call line break well let's see
by an example so normally the character
T has no special function so the
character T within a string will just be
outputted as the characterity itself
however as you can see here I'm going to
introduce a backslash before this
character t
let's see what it does it introduces
this thing that we called a tab space
which is the larger than normal space
similarly if I were to use the backslash
n combination this would introduce what
we call a line break
and if you were to see the output of
this you can see at the point of the
string where I have this combination of
backslash m a line break has occurred so
there are plenty of other Escape
sequences that you may choose to learn
and uh these are just two of the
probably the most common ones that are
used in this video I will give you an
introduction into lists and tuples
starting off with lists lists are a
collection of ordered orbit arbitrary
objects that are similar to what we call
an array in other programming languages
but lists are way more flexible when it
comes to python python lists are a type
of sequence and we might have you might
have seen what the sequence is when we
were learning about strings and much
like in sequences or any other sequence
list objects are assigned a numerical
index and whenever you want to
manipulate an object in a list we use
its respective index how do we Define
lists the lists are defined using square
brackets so this is a simple way or a
simple list that I have just created and
assigned to a variable a which contains
three objects one two and three let's
talk about some of the features of
python lists python lists are ordered
and what this means is that even if two
lists contain the exact same elements if
they if the elements are placed in a
different order the two lists are
actually unique and different and I can
check that over here I have created a
list one two and three and see if I
create another list two and one and
three the same elements were in
different order I will use the is
function to check whether these two
lists are the same and if they are the
same when I use is function it should
give me the value or the answer true and
if they are not the same it should give
me the value false and as you can see I
get the value false because even though
I have two lists with the same elements
they are in different orders and so they
are different and that's what we mean by
lists are ordered the next property for
lists are that they can be manipulated
using their indexes or the elements and
the objects inside a list can be
manipulated using the indexes and we
will see that in the section where I
show you list operations the next
property is lists are mutable what this
means is that once we create a list
object we can actually make changes and
modify them without having to create a
new list object the next property is
that lists are Dynamic and what this
means is that as we are making our as we
are programming we can actually make
changes to an already created list as we
are programming without having to go
through a compilation stage so if we had
to say increase the or we had to add
certain elements to an already created
list that original list grows in size to
accommodate for these new elements the
next property is that lists can contain
any arbitrary objects so if I created a
list right now where say if I want to
store some numbers
say some floating Point numbers now
and I can put strings as well into my
list all of these are valid uh when it
comes to objects that can be put inside
a list we have no such restrictions so
we can put any arbitrary objects inside
our list the final property that I want
to talk about is that lists are they can
be nested to any arbitrary depth what
this means is that I can put a list
within a list and I can keep nesting it
essentially by putting as many lists I
want within my list and I'm only
essentially restricted by my systems
memory so if I created a list like this
within this say I put any other list and
within this list I put another list I
can keep going on to by keep going on
doing this and I'm only restricted by
the memory of my system that I'm using
so moving on let's move on and talk
about some important list operations
that we will be doing when it comes to
lists so let's create a basic list
called a where I'm storing six numbers
so now say if I want to retrieve a
particular element say if I want to find
out what's on the index 3 this is how I
would do it if I wanted a slice of my
original list and much like strings I do
it the same way so what this does is it
tells python that I want all the
elements of list a from index 1 to index
4 but not including index 4. so it'll
give me one two and three index objects
so it should give me 2 3 and 4 in this
case as you can see here two three and
four I can do the same thing by
considering elements say two at a time
if I wanted to consider elements or
consider every second element what I
would do is this syntax I would use this
syntax and when I give this command to
python what it tells what it understands
is I want every element from a from
index 1 to index 4 but not including
index 4 but I am going to consider
considered to every second
element essentially so what it will do
is it will go here and then it will skip
one and then go here and then Skip One
and that's essentially what we uh what
it's essentially what we call they are
slicing by using strides so I'm taking
strides I'm not considering elements
consecutively but I'm skipping certain
elements in between if I wanted to
consider every third element I would
change this to three and fourth element
I would change this to four all right so
let's see what happens when I take every
second element it should give it should
give me uh it will consider say from one
to index three right so you should
consider essentially this section but
since it's going to skip one it's going
to consider this skip this and then
consider this it should give me two and
four as you can see it has given me two
and four and like in other sequences we
can use negative indexes as well
negative indexing essentially starts
looking from the right hand side of the
list so when I say A minus 1 on it's
essentially looking at the last element
of the list so it gives me the sixth or
the last element which is the which is
the object six if I did a minus 2 it
gives me the second last element
similarly another neat trick that we can
use for sequences is the following
syntax double colon and we give a minus
one what this tells the what this tells
the system is I want the list a but with
all the elements reversed so as you can
see I get my element uh my list a but
the elements have been reversed right
now let's move on to uh concatenation
and replication well concatenation much
like in strings is done by using the
plus sign so as we know on either side
of the plus sign should be two similar
objects so if I'm doing a plus something
a being a list on the other side it
should be a list as well so let's add a
list like this now let's see what's in a
as you can see my origin list has a 789
added to it and I can also add things to
the beginning of a list similarly so if
I wanted to add say zero you know at the
beginning of a list I just do it like
this
and I get the element 0 added to it it's
very important to note that I I actually
added 0 within a list because if I did 0
like this
it would throw me an error because like
this 0 is just an end object and it's
not a list but when I put the square
brackets I make it a list and then this
concatenation becomes valid because a is
also a list similarly if I did a star 2
this is essentially replication all
right replication function where I'm
repeating the values in a twice if I did
a star 3 it's the same function but now
I'll have the elements repeated Thrice
as you can see here let's move on to
modifying list values uh this also shows
the mutable property of lists that I had
mentioned earlier so let's consider this
example so I created a list with
elements where it is the three strings
eggs apples and carrots and I have five
int objects one two three four and five
now if I wanted to change say the first
element all I have to do is take the 0th
index and say if I want to replace eggs
with same mango this is how I would do
it now replace eggs with mango if I
check what's in B you can see the eggs
have been replaced with the element
mango similarly I can use the slice
syntax to replace a particular slice
from my list with a slice essentially so
let's look at this I'm replacing I want
to replace the first three elements I
want to replace mango I want to replace
apple and carrot so what I will do is I
will consider this since this carrot is
the second index so I will consider 0 to
3 because third is not counted now I'm
going to replace this with three
different
um let's see kiwi
and it's a sponge now let's check what's
in B you can see my three elements have
been replaced in fact I don't have to
replace like for like if I want to
replace say three elements with only one
or two elements that is also possible so
now if I want to replace the first three
elements give you orange and sponge
with
um just one element this is how I'll do
it let's say
wine now let's check what's here as you
can see three elements have been
replaced with one mine I can double vice
versa as well I can replace smaller
number of elements with a larger number
of elements but here there is a slight
caveat that I want to show you so an
obvious way of doing this would be say
if I wanted to replace the first element
wine with three different elements an
obvious way would be just consider that
elements index and then put whatever
objects you want say I want to add
instead of wine I want to add beer I
want to add ball and say Club yeah well
let's see what happens now if I say B
check what's inside my you can see my
elements have been added but they seem
to have been added as is you know I had
entered a list over here and that whole
list has been replaced uh or this wine
has been replaced by this whole list in
the first position but that's not
exactly what I want it I wanted the
elements within this list to be
individually placed into my list and the
way to do that is not this syntax but
actually what I'm going to show you now
if I want to replace one if I want to
replace the index of the object at index
0 I would give this statement a slice
statement where I will give 0 colon 1 so
when I do this and if I
um so let's create my old scenario again
where I add wine and I had one two three
four and five now if I do this B 0 but I
give a slice then this slice is
essentially a single object slice it's
essentially the zeroth index again but
because of this formatting or this this
type of syntax that I'm using what
python will do is now when I say peer
and ball and club now what python will
do is it will not consider this whole
list and add it to in place of uh wine
or whatever I want to replace it will
actually consider the elements inside of
this individually and then replace so if
you see here now if you see my list I
actually have the I've removed wine and
in place of it I've put beer ball in
club but these three are actually
individual objects within my list and
not objects within a list that is then
placed within my original list so this
is an important caveat that you should
take note of so moving on let's talk
about certain methods Associated to
lists let's take a simple list now one
two and three the first operation that I
want to show you or the first method is
the append method so when I do a append
and say if I want to append the list by
one object called four I just do it like
this now let's see what's in a I put so
as you can see the append has put the
object 4 into my original list now say
if I wanted to append three different
objects I want to append five six and
seven now let's see what a pen function
does oh no as you can see it's done a
similar operation to what we have seen
earlier when we gave a single index or
the single element replacement uh that
we saw earlier it essentially put this
whole list into this particular spot
into the list and this is not what I
wanted I wanted five six and seven to be
individually placed and we do have a way
of doing that and the way to do that is
the extend function that is what I'll
show you next now if I want to extend
Say the original list by three different
elements eight nine ten when I use the
extend function it will not put this
whole thing it will consider each object
inside this thing individually and then
add it to a so if you see my result this
is exactly what I wanted now the next
method that I want to discuss is the
remove method so the remove method is
what you how you use it is within the
parenthesis you put the object that is
present in the list that you want to
removed so you don't give an index over
here you give the object itself so if I
want the object eight all right this
number if I want 8 itself removed what I
will do is put the value 8 here and it
will remove it from my list so if I
check my list a as you can see the value
8 has it's gone an X another similar
function to remove is the pop function
now the pop function by default will
remove the rightmost value from the list
but unlike remove the pop function
actually outputs a value and that value
is what we have popped out of the list
so by default it will pop out the right
route right most value of a list a
rightmost element of a list and in this
case that element is 10 so it should
give me 10 but of course if we want to
pop out any particular object in this
case we will not give that particular
object we give its index so now say if I
want to remove this uh this list object
from my bigger list
um as I can see it's in index 0 1 2 3 4.
it's the fourth index so if I want to
remove the list which is at the fourth
index I give the index value inside the
parenthesis and it pops that out for me
as you can see over here so this was it
for list let's move on to tuples next so
tuples are another ordered collection of
objects much like lists but they differ
from lists in two Key Properties first
of all tuples are defined using
parenthesis instead of square brackets
so this is how I would Define a tuple
with elements one two and three and the
next very important property that is
different or that differentiates tuples
from lists is that tuples are immutable
and what this means is that once we
create an object of type Tuple we cannot
make any modifications to it we would
have to only create create a new object
if we wanted something different and
this is obviously a key difference
between a tuple and a list but apart
from this every operation that we have
done on lists are actually possible to
do in the case of tuples as well so any
operation that we did to lists that did
not modify the list or that does not do
any modification we can actually apply
to tuples as well so if I wanted the
first element of this difficult all I
have to do is call it by the index 0 it
should give me the value 1 as you can
see if I wanted a slice I can do that as
well it should give me 2 and 3 and if I
wanted to reverse my Tuple well I can
use my same neat technique that I've
used for this and that I can use for the
sequence I mean strings as well so it
gives me my old Tuple but with the
elements reversed so now the natural
question is why do we use Tuple server
lists well one important difference is
that when we can when we make a program
execution where or where we are
manipulating a tuple if we did the same
thing for the exact same objects in uh
that if it were present in a list it
would be much faster in a tuple
essentially program execution is just
faster on tuples when compared to an
identical list so use tuples over list
when we want to be efficient while we
are creating an ordered list of objects
so whenever we create an ordered list of
objects that we don't need to or we
don't want to make any further
modifications to we don't need to create
a list we can create a tuple and another
very important area where we use tuples
over list or why we need a tuple instead
of a list is when we are using
dictionaries dictionaries as we will see
later is a data type in Python that
needs an immutable component while we
are creating the dictionary so if we
want to use uh something that is like a
list but since lists are mutable we can
use a tuple instead and use that when we
are creating our dictionary and we will
see like what what I mean by the
immutable component for a dictionary
when we actually uh learn about
dictionaries but yeah these are some of
the places where we would use a tuples
over a list uh a brief section on Tuple
unpacking and packing is what I would be
doing right now and what that means is
that when I create when I give this sort
of a statement
you can assume this to be me packing
this Tuple into a object or a
variability now what's very interesting
is and this is something that's very key
to tuples is that I can unpack a tuple
onto another Tuple so let me show you
what I mean by that so now that I have
packed one two three and four Tuple into
T let's unpack it into another Tuple
let's call this let's uh put these
elements into this Tuple and I put this
into T alright now let's see what I mean
by unpacking something onto something
let's see what's the what what happens
when I put a if I just want to see
what's in a it actually gives me the
value one if I see what's in B it gives
me the value 2 if I see what's in three
invalid 3 and D gives me value four so
essentially if you think of it what I
have done is I have matched this Tuple
then put it into T and then put that
Tuple T into this Tuple a b and c d so
what it's what what has happened
essentially is the element a has been or
a better way to say this would be the
element one has been packed onto or
unpacked onto a two has been unpacked on
to B three has been unpacked onto C 4
has been unpacked onto D to show you
what I've done in a single line is
essentially this this is essentially
what I've done
I have assigned 1 to a 2 to B 3 to C 4
to D I have matched these two tuples
together like this and this is a very
neat feature of tuples the only only
important thing that you have to keep in
mind is the elements of this Tuple and
the elements of this Tuple uh should be
equal so if there are four elements here
there should be four elements here all
right in fact another very important
thing about or a neat feature is that we
don't really need to mention the
parenthesis when we're doing this uh
unpacking or packing so if I did X comma
y comma Z if I did it like this if I put
say 5 and 6 and 7 this is also a valid
way of packing and unpacking so now if I
see what's the value in X it is actually
five if I see what's the value in y it
is six if I see what is the value of x
and z it should give me a tuple
containing five and seven as you can see
over here so this is a neat feature of
tuples called packing and tracking in
this video we will cover Concepts
surrounding dictionaries dictionaries
are another type of composite data type
in Python there are also a collection of
objects much like tuples and lists and
like lists they are also mutable Dynamic
and can be nested however a key
difference and property of dictionaries
is that they are unordered items and
dictionaries are paired using keys
unlike enlists and tuples where the
objects are assigned numerical indexes
to define a dictionary we use curly
braces each key value pair in this
dictionary in a dictionary is separated
using commas and the key and values
themselves in a pair are separated using
a colon let's look at an example this is
a dictionary where I have three key
value pairs as you can see they have
been separated by colons and each repair
themselves are separated by commas and
these are enclosed in curly braces to
define the whole dictionary in this
example the these are the keys banana
apple and grape and their respective
values are yellow red and green so this
is very important that in this
particular data type we have what we
call a key and that key is assigned a
value and we can have multiple such
pairings and we have three such pairs in
this particular example another example
or the or another type of way to define
a dictionary is using the dict function
this is how we use it as you can see I
have inputted two value or two object
tuples this is a tuple this is etiopal
and this is a tuple and when I use it in
a dict function when I place it within a
list what python will do is it will
consider the first element of each Tuple
as a key and the second element of each
Tuple as its respective value now if I
check what's in D as you can see the key
banana has a value yellow the key apple
has a value right the key grape has a
value green so this is another way of
defining dictionaries an important note
over here is that the the objects that
we use for Keys have to be of an
immutable data type so we cannot use for
example lists as an example of keys but
we can use say integers or strings for
our dictionary Keys also Keys have to be
unique when it comes to a dictionary you
cannot have two different keys with uh
or should I say the same key having two
different values you can have only one
key and that one key will have a unique
value assigned to it duplicate keys are
not allowed however when we speak about
values we have no such restrictions you
can have immutable or an immutable data
type as a value in a dictionary and you
can have duplicates as well so if I
created a dictionary with a key say
banana and if I give if I associate it
with it
a value green I cannot create another
key banana and Associate a value yellow
let's see what happens when I actually
do this if you actually see what has
happened here is python has considered
the second case so it's it first looks
at the first pair it goes okay so my
dictionary has a key banana with a value
green but right after it it sees another
key banana with a value yellow so it
overwrites my first key banana with the
second key and it overwrites the first
value green with the second value and we
essentially get one key banana with the
second value yellow so obviously this is
python does this to avoid duplicacies
however if I created a dictionary with a
key banana again if I created I gave it
a value yellow or say green if I created
another
key and if I give this also a value
green this is perfectly fine and this
will not nothing special will happen in
this case because values do not have to
follow such rules let's speak or let's
see certain dictionary operation
operations and functions now so let's uh
bring back our original dictionary which
we had created earlier with the three
pairs all right so what if I wanted to
we can use keys to essentially do these
operations and functions let's see what
happens when we so much like how we use
sequence how we use indexes in example
of sequences we use Keys when it comes
to dictionary so let's see what happens
when we use a key over here so we as we
know banana is a key in this dictionary
let's see what happens when we do where
we give this command it actually gives
the value associated with that key which
is yellow what if we wanted to change a
particular value Associated to a
particular key I would give I would do
this I would give the key and assign it
uh the value that I want to change it
with all right now if I check my
dictionary you can see the key banana no
more has yellow value but the value gold
what if I wanted to add a new pair you
know a new key with a new value
completely I would do it pretty much the
same same way as I did in the previous
step I would
um essentially write my new key whatever
I wanted say if I wanted a new key
called watermelon I would assign it a
value red and now if I check my
dictionary at the end of the dictionary
you will see that my new key pair key
value pair has been added watermelon red
as as you can see over here now what if
I wanted to remove if I wanted to remove
a key value pair from my dictionary I
can use the delete function which is
called by using this the Del function
now how do I do it say if I want to
remove the key value Apple in Red so all
I have to do is do del d and within
square brackets I have to only mention
the key I don't even need to mention the
value just the key so you can probably
draw parallels in how we use indexes
when it comes to lists and tuples and
even strings and how we use Keys when it
comes to dictionaries they are quite
similar so if I did this and if I oops I
think red is actually not a key as you
can see red is a value my key is Apple
actually it's not red it's apple as you
can see now if I see my dictionary the
key apple and its value red has been
removed so these are some of the
operation questions that we can do for
dictionaries using keys what if we
wanted to use certain inbuilt functions
that are associated with dictionaries
well some of the examples are as follows
there is a get function when we use the
get function all we have to do is enter
a key inside the parenthesis and it will
get the value associated with that key
so if I gave the key grip let's see what
value is associated with it as you can
see it's green there is also a function
called items that Returns the key and
value pairs in our dictionary as a list
of two object tuples where the first
object is the key and the second object
is the Tuple so let's see what it does
as you can see it gave me a list and in
this list the objects inside the list
are two object pupils where the first
object is always the key and the second
is the value and and it's the same for
each of the tuples so this is what items
function does let's see what uh the next
so the next function is Keys let's see
what the keys function does as you can
see it returns a list of all the unique
Keys within our list I mean within our
dictionary similarly we can there is a
function for values as well and as you
can see it returns all of the different
values that are present in our
dictionary in the form of a list also
it's important to note that if we have a
particular value that has occurred
multiple times in a dictionary it will
appear as many times it has occurred in
the dictionary or appeared in the
dictionary in our list over here when we
use the value function so if say a
particular value say I had another key
where its value was green again so I
would have the value green appear in
this list once more essentially our next
function is pop item what this does is
much like the pop function in list it
gives us the last entered key value pair
that is present in our dictionary so the
last centered pair was watermelon key
watermelon with the value red and that's
what has popped out when we give this
function another important function
associated with dictionaries is the
update function and the update function
is a very neat function that is used to
merge two dictionaries together so say
if I had a dictionary let's say I'm
creating a dictionary using the dict
function where I have say some key
called key V so as I had mentioned I
will use two object tuples in this case
and say I give this also a value green
all right and another pair would be say
mango and
let's give it a value yellow
all right so this is another dictionary
that we have created as you can see over
here we have created a dictionary with
the key called key V with value green
and another key mango with a value
yellow and I already have a dictionary D
with uh these values all right now if I
want to merge these two dictionaries I
can use the update function what I do is
say if I want to merge D with X or x
with d only the ordering will change and
that doesn't really matter when it comes
to dictionaries so if I want to merge D
with X I use D update and then inside it
I put my target dictionary now when I
check what's in D I have the the
dictionary X and its key value pairs uh
merged inside my original Dictionary d
as you can see I have my original ones
here and I have the merged ones over
here so this was the update function in
this brief video I will explain what we
call the type hierarchy or the standard
type hierarchy and fighting it's also
known as the data model in Python and it
probably has other names so essentially
in what we do or what we speak about in
this is uh how the different types that
we use in Python are categorized and
classified and what are their subtypes
so it's important to note before we
continue further that there in future
versions of python there might be new
types that are introduced or the
existing ones may be modified but it's
safe to say that what I will speak about
in this video will still form the core
of what we call python standard type
hierarchy so let's begin so the first
type is the non-type uh it's accessed
through the built-in name none its truth
value is false it's essentially used to
denote
um functions or it's you it's returned
as the value for functions that don't
really return anything so if you have an
expression or a function that returns no
particular value you actually get a data
type called none that is how python
interprets it uh then there's the
ellipses uh ellipse is something that
you might encounter later it is accessed
through the built-in name Ellipsis
um it is used to indicate the presence
of this particular
um syntax this particular symbol or
expression uh or syntax in a slice its
truth value is true again don't worry
too much about ellipses right now next
is numbers and numbers is something that
we are very familiar with we've seen we
work with numbers a lot they are an
immutable type they are created through
numeric literals and they are the
outputs of arithmetic expressions and
built-in arithmetic functions its
subtypes are integers floating Point
numbers and complex numbers within
integers you have plain integers that
represent numbers in the range this
number and this number so this this
number is basically the largest positive
value that you can represent using 32
bit notation induce complement and this
is the equivalent a for the the negative
the negative side long in teachers on
the other hand are used to represent
numbers in an unlimited range that is
only subject to the available memory of
your system so these are two types of
integers and as we know floating Point
numbers represent Machine level double
Precision floating Point numbers or
numbers with a decimal point and a
component after that complex numbers are
numbers that contain a floating Point
number that represents a real part and a
floating Point number that represents a
an imaginary part so these are the types
of numbers then we have sequences
sequences are finite ordered sets
indexed by natural numbers so each
element in a sequence has an index and
that index is a natural number the
different types of sequences are based
on the mutability whether the objects
can be changed or not is essentially
what we mean by mutability right once we
create an object whether we can modify I
don't know and that is how we
differentiate different types of
sequences so there are mutable and there
are immutable types now the different
types of immutable ones are strings we
know what strings are they are sequences
that contain characters Unicode is the
other immutable sequence and then there
are tuples uh tuples are a collection of
arbitrary python objects and unicodes
are sequences that contain Unicode
characters then we have mutable
sequences and uh there is only one
currently there is only one built-in
mutable sequence in Python and that is
lists lists are also again collection of
arbitrary python objects finally we have
well not finally but next we have
mappings and mappings are again
um sets of objects but these objects are
now indexed using arbitrary index sets
you know the difference between a
mapping and a sequence you could
consider sequences are ordered but
mappings are not ordered and the index
is given to the objects and sequences
are always numbers they're natural
numbers whereas in mappings they are not
natural numbers but they are certain
arbitrary objects that we can set for
ourselves again in Python there is only
one built in standard mapping type that
is the dictionary dictionaries are there
they represent finite sets of objects
indexed by nearly arbitrary values the
only condition is that these indexes
must be of an immutable data type so
these uh so what I have mentioned until
now are probably the most common data
types that we encounter or that we have
encountered now so next types are like
callable types such as user defined
functions user defined methods built-in
functions built-in methods classes and
class instances so again callable types
as a whole are referenced using the call
function and this is something that we
will learn when we start learning about
functions when we learn about object
oriented programming and methods and
functions and such the other type are
modules so modules are module objects or
modules essentially are referenced or
called using the import function again
modules can be considered as these large
libraries or larger pieces of code or
applications that we that contain
various different methods and functions
and objects and classes within them
again modules are something that we will
think about a little later files are
data types that are called using the
open function so anytime we and as we
will well during the course of this
tutorial we or during the course of this
this course essentially we will be
working with a lot of files these some
of these files are text files some of
them are comma separated files so all of
these files that we open using uh the
function open or some other certain
specific functions where we create file
objects out of these files these are
what we call file data types finally
there are internal types that are used
by python interpreter again this is
something that does not concern us right
now but just know that The Interpreter
for python uses these data types for its
functioning in this video I will show
you some of the categories of operations
that are possible in Python so let's
start off so the first category of
operations are arithmetic operations and
as you can see in this table there are
different types such as addition
subtraction multiplication so let's go
over them one by one so so a simple
addition operation would be like five
plus six giving me the value 11 I can do
5 minus 3 that's subtraction similarly I
can do a multiplication using five say
five into two there's division where I
use the backslash so say I did division
of 8 divided by 2. now you might
encounter another type of division which
is called the flow division where we use
a double backslash and what this does is
it returns us the largest whole number
that is lesser than the result of our
division so the division difference
between the float Division and and the
normal fluid and the floor division or
the single and the double backslash is
this say I did 9 divided by 2 using a
single backslash it should give me as
you can see 4.5 right so this is the
actual value now let's see what happens
when I do 9 double backslash 2 it will
give me 4 which is the largest number
lesser than or equal to 4.5 that is also
a whole number so this is what we call
flower division essentially finally we
also have if we want to raise something
to the power or something so if I want
to do fire say 6 raised to the power 3
because I would use double asterisks and
this is how I would do it it'll give me
216 as you can see uh if I wanted
remainder between the division between
two different numbers I will use the
percentage sign so if I wanted the
remainder of the division between seven
and three this is how I would do it I
get the answer 1 as you can see so next
category of operations are logical
operations the first one is the logical
and operation where we use the operator
end all right so let's see what we mean
by this I am creating so as we know the
and operation Returns the value true if
both the operands are true so let's
actually let's actually do this for an
example let's give this variable the
value true and this is the value false
so it should be done like this false so
now uh think of it like one and zero so
a one and zero is obviously zero right
so if I did A and B I should get the
answer false or 0 because I'm doing true
and false so it's like doing one and
zero so if you see this I should get the
answer false if I change this to true as
well now if I do this I will get the
answer true as you can see uh the next
logical operation is the or operation
where well logical or is if either of
the operands are true then we should get
the answer to our or operation as true
as well so in this case obviously if I
did or over here it will naturally give
us true if I change this to false
it should again give us true and it will
only give us faults if both are false as
you can see here now it's false the next
operation is The Logical not uh it's
done by using the not operator so in
this case the value that we get is true
if the operand is false so let's take a
as we know a is false over here so if I
did not a I should get the answer true
but if I change this to true now if I do
not a I should get false as you can see
so this was The Logical operations let's
move on to the next set of operations
that is comparison operations so there
are a bunch of them let's go over them
one by one if I want to check if two
operands are equal so if I did X is say
equal to 2 and now Y is equal to 3. if I
want to check if they are equal I will
use the double equals to sign and if
they are equal I will get the value true
if they aren't either I'll get value
false as you can see since X is 2 and Y
is 3 as you can see X and why are not
the same so there's false they are not
equal if I change this also to 2 now I
will get the answer to another the next
comparison is the not equal to or maybe
use the exclamation sign so over here
this is this um the result of this is
true if X and Y are not actually it's
the same so I should get false over here
as you can see but if I change this to
say 5 now I will get true because X is
not equal to Y in this case the next one
is greater than so if I did X greater
than y as we can see 2 is not greater
than 5 I will get false over here
similarly there is a lesser than if I
did X less than y I should get true over
here as you can see well there's also a
greater than or equal to and lesser than
or equal to we simply add the equal to
sign here so let's see now if I say x is
lesser than or equal to 3 I should get
true because X is 2 and if I put 2 here
I should also get true but what if I put
1 here since X is equal to 2 and 2 is
not less than equal to 1 this is a false
statement and I can do the same thing
with like this using the greater than
equal to now it's true because 2 is
actually greater than equal to 1. and so
this was comparison operations the next
set of operations that we can do in
Python are assignment operations we've
already seen a whole bunch we've already
been assigning values to variables we've
been doing assignments throughout
already but let's go over them and see
some of the assignment operations so as
we already know the equal to operation
is assigning everything that is on the
or the value on the right hand side of
the equal to sign to what is on the left
so if I did a is equal to 5 plus 6 it
will assign the value 5 plus 6 or 11 to
a let's check what's in a as you can see
it is 11. there is a plus equal to sign
and what this does is so for example if
I did say a now since a is 11 let's
create another variable called B and
call this 5 all right so now if I did a
plus equal to B what this will do is it
will add B to a and then store it in a
so let's see what this does once I do
this now let's check what's in a it
should be 5 plus 11 as you can see 16.
so this a plus this is this plus equal
to sign is essentially the same as doing
a is equal to a plus b it's essentially
the same thing they're both the same uh
there's a similar thing for this the
negative symbol or subtraction as well
minus equal to so now that a is 16 and B
is still 5 of course if I did minus
equal to B now I'm subtracting the value
5 from 16 so I should get a is equal to
11 again as you can see here and this is
the equivalent of doing a minus B A is
equal to a minus B I mean as you can see
so uh the next similar like assignment
operation let's create a is equal to say
6 in this case and say B is equal to I
will say say 2 all right now if I do a
star star equal to B what this does is
it multiplies B to a and then assigns it
back to a so if I see what's in a now it
should be 12 as you can see here
similarly there is similar thing for
subtraction as well so if I did a is
equal to 6 and B is equal to 2 and if I
did a sorry for division so if I did a
division symbol and equal to sign and
then if I give B what it will do is it
will divide a by b or 6 by 2 and it will
assign that back to a so my value in a
should be 3 as you can see here 3.0
obviously this is a single uh single
backslash so this is a float division
the resultant of a single backslash is
always a float I can do the same thing
with a double backslash so let's see if
I did a is equal to 7 now and then B is
equal to 3. now if I did a double
backslash equal to B now it will do the
same division but uh it will do a floor
function so it should give me 2 in this
case if I did the same thing with a
single backslash just to show you the
difference between single backslash and
double backslash division in this case
it will give me
um the value around 2.3 or something a
float basically 2.33 as you can see here
then there is the modulus you can use
the modulus sign as well with this
assignment uh say a is equal to say 5
now B is equal to 2 now if I do a
percentage symbol equal to 2 I mean the
it should give me it will assign the uh
it will take the modulus in both sides
and then assign it to the left hand
upper end now let's see what's in a as
you can see it it did a divided by 2 the
modular symbol is basically the
remainder of the division between two
objects so in this case it will divide a
by B and then give me the remainder and
then put the remainder back in a and as
you can see the remainder of 5 divided
by 2 is 1 and we get that over here
similarly we can also do exponential so
if I have a is equal to say so 5 b is
equal to 2 and I want to raise a by if I
wanted to raise the value of a by the
value of B and then store that back in a
this is how I would do it so it should
be 5 to the power 2 which is 25 as you
can see here so this is assignment
operations so finally we move on to uh
two special sets of operators one is the
identity set identity operators and the
other is the membership operators uh
let's look at the identity operators so
when we talk about identity operators
what we when what we mean is the is and
the is not operator so what the is
operator does is it checks whether two
operands uh have the same location in
the memory essentially this does not
mean that it does not check for whether
two objects have the same value and this
is very important so let's look at this
if a is equal to 1001 and B is equal to
1000 plus one all right if I did a is
equal to 2. this is an equality check
are they the same values true now if I
say a is B let's see what happens as you
can see it's false this is because this
object and this object are not the same
and this is what the is Operation does
uh we can confirm this by checking the
ID of a the ID of a gives us some value
like this and the ID of B gives us as
you can see a different value so the two
objects are not located in the same
place of the memory as we have seen
using the ID function and that is what
we check uh through the is operator and
is not is essentially just the opposite
of that so so that is the identity
operator now the membership operator is
used for checking whether something is
present in a sequence or not so let's
create a sequence I will create a list
to show in this example my list is one
two and three basically simple list with
three integer objects one two and three
I will check whether now say 2 in a so
is 2 in a if it is it will give me true
as you can see is 5 in a it should give
me false because 5 is not in a and the a
naught n operator is just the opposite
of that it checks the other condition
essentially so this is the membership
operators in Python in this video we
will be looking at the math module in
Python and we will look at some of the
math functions that are associated with
this module in Python so starting off
what is this math module well uh the
python map module is an important
library or a feature that is uh designed
to deal with mathematical operations
this math module is part of the basic
python installation so you don't have to
install this separately to use this math
module all you have to do is import this
module and this is how you would do it
you just do import math and this will
import your math module for you to use
in your programming and in this in the
course of this video I will be showing
you certain Concepts surrounding the
math module such as what are the
constants that come with the mass module
some of the arithmetic functions the
logarithmetic functions power functions
and even trigonometric functions that we
can do using this math module and the
function inside the math module so
starting off let's look at some of the
constants that are part of this so as
you can see the standard constants are
available in this module are Pi there is
Tau there is Euler's number Nan which is
a special it's a it's a programming
specific concept and infinity so let's
look at this one by one so starting off
our first constant is pi
um Pi is as you know in maths it's the
ratio of the of a circles circumference
to its diameter and Pi is an irrational
number you know the value of pi is 3.14
something since it's an irrational
number it does not we cannot Define it
in terms of a specific fraction but it
can be approximated to the fraction 22
by 7. so how do we access this by
constant is as simple as this once you
have imported maths uh the match module
all you have to do is do match dot pi
and it will give you the value as you
can see so as you can see the value
returned to us is a float this is
important to note and the number of
number of decimal digits uh the number
of digits after the decimal point that
we can see here are 15 and this is like
a by default thing for python that if
you call the pi a constant it will give
you the value of pi correct up to 15
decimal points so an example of where we
can use this thing is say we have the
radius of a circle 3 it can be in any
units 3 meters or whatever you want and
you want to find out it's say
circumference so as we know the
circumference of a circle is 2 pi r so
if I had to find the circumference of a
circle in my C in my code for some
application with the radius 3 however
all I would have to do is use the
formula 2 pi r and to call the value 2
pi r instead of specifically writing
3.14 something I can just use this
function math dot pi over here and then
I can enter the r as you can see it will
return me the radius as you can see so
moving on uh the next constant that we
will talk about is Tau Tau is similar to
Pi in fact tau is the ratio of a circle
circumference to its radius Pi is the
ratio of a circle circumference to its
diameter and tau is the ratio for
circles circumference to its radius so
important to know this difference so
because of this definition tau is always
2 times the value of pi this is by
definition and much like Pi if you call
the Tau constant in you from the math
module it will also return you a float
number and to find that this is the
function that we use or this is the
syntax so as you can see this is this is
actually two times the value of pi 6.283
and even this is returned correct up to
15 places to the right of the decimal
point and this is by default uh next
constant is the Euler's number the
Euler's number is a it's one of the most
widespread constants used in the world
of uh in the scientific community in the
mathematical Community you will be using
the Euler's number probably a lot as a
if if you move into data science or AI
or something like that so what is the
Euler's number it is uh it is the base
of the natural logarithm if you know
what the natural logarithm is it is used
to calculate rates of growth or rates of
Decay and as with numbers or constants
like pi and Tau even the Euler's number
is an irrational number with infinite
decimal places uh the value of the
Euler's number in short it's denoted by
the small letter e so this value of e is
our usually approximated around 2.718 so
how do we call this constant is simply
as math dot e this is how we do it so
you get this value again this is also a
float and it's correct up to 15 decimal
places so the next concept that we will
be talking about is infinity now
Infinity is a it's more of a
mathematical concept and this is very
important to note because Infinity
doesn't is not really a number there is
no number called Infinity it is it is
used to define something that is
infinitely large or infinitely small so
positive Infinity is something that is
higher than any known number to us and
negative Infinity is lower than any
known number to us so this is the
concept of infinity and how do we call
this uh function well so let's see what
happens when we call the math function
math constant Infinity so this is how we
do it and as you can see it will return
us this it might look like a string to
you but this is actually a special type
in Python
um which is not a string this is all
also a float it's a type of a float in
fact this Infinity value it's it's a
it's like a special data type it's a
special data type that you can you can
consider as an equivalent to a float but
um it's not it's not a typical float
that we know like you know 3.14 or 2.71
the value of method.in will give us INF
and this is this INF is actually not a
string so we can we can confirm that
over here as you can see when I do a
type when I check the type you see it's
actually a float in fact this was
recently added in Python 3.5 a special
type known as math.inf it returns this
INF data type which is equivalent waste
float so this is this is how we use
Infinity if you wanted to get the value
of say minus infinity all you would have
to do is match dot INF with a minus sign
preceding this constant and you will get
minus INF now let's check if the
concepts or the properties of infinity
are maintained you know like every a
positive Infinity is greater than any
number that we know and negative
Infinity is greater than any number that
we know so let's just confirm this
um so I will take method in and I will
do a check is this greater than say some
really large number something that comes
off the top of my head immediately okay
so let's see if it's if this is true
then this is conceptually correct and as
you can see it is true in fact I can
change this number to anything as large
as I want this will be true because
Infinity is true is larger than any
number that we know and similarly if I
did minus math dot in INF and I checked
some very small number you know a very
very small negative number so just
consider some minus uh 10 to the power
something right this should also be true
uh sorry it should be a smaller sense
symbol this should also be true because
I'm checking minus infinity is smaller
than any known number it was and it is
true as you can see so it's very uh also
if you did a if you did something like
so let's say if we do let's add
something to this you know it's a number
so we should be able to do arithmetic on
this let's actually see what happens
when I add say 10 to positive Infinity
it actually gives us the same value back
infinity because uh intuitively we know
that infinity plus anything is still
going to be Infinity right and this is
exactly what python does for us even if
we add a number to this the math dot INF
or the infinity constant in Python it
will still give us uh the same value the
same data type of INF or Infinity
similarly if we subtracted something
from the negative of maths.inf you know
say minus say again let's say minus 100
so if you subtract something from minus
infinity we're technically still minus
infinity itself so this will again give
us my S and then minus INF as you can
see and this is absolutely what we need
and this is a very very interesting
feature in Python uh finally the last
constant that we will discuss is the na
a n or the not a number constant so this
is not really a mathematical constant
there is no constant in maths called not
a number this is a computer science
related concept that it's used to is
used to denote invalid inputs or in it's
used to indicate a certain places where
say a variable that should have a number
it's been corrupted for whatever reason
and it it now has a text or a symbol and
our code throws an error then in these
in these cases where python expects a
number from us or from your code and it
does not get it it will throw you a n a
n value and this is usually used in
cases where you have errors in your code
so again just to check like what this
this constant like how to call it this
is how you actually do it maths.nan and
it will give you a data type called Nan
also much like the infinity cons
constant let's see what's the type of
this this constant again might look like
a string to you but of course this is
not a string this is enough a numerical
concept and as you can see it's still a
float so this is like um it's another
special uh data type that was created
for specifically this case where uh it's
some it's the equivalent of a float but
um it's not really the typical float
that we are that we associate with so
this is a constants in the math module
so our next topic will be arithmetic
functions that we can do in the using
the math module so some of the common
arithmetic functions that are available
to us are factorials the ceiling
operation floor operation uh there's
permutations there's combinations you
can find the greatest common divisor or
the gcd and the LCM or the least common
multiple and you can truncate numbers so
let's look at them one by one so
starting off with the factorial
operation the factorial operation is
done using the factorial function as you
can see here actually is defined like
this math dot factorial all right so now
what we pass in between the parenthesis
will be uh what we calculate the
factorial for as you know factorial is
so factorial is always for a positive
integer and the factorial for say a
number 10 would mean 10 times 9 times 8
times 7 so on until the number one
obviously factor is only defined for
positive integers uh it is not defined
for negative values or it's uh and it's
also not defined for decimal values so
let's see let's look at an example so as
we know um so let's say we pass match
dot factorial for six and let's see
what's the value so this is exactly what
we expect so we expect the value of 6
times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 uh that
is actually 720. let's see what happens
when we pass 0 this should give us one
since we know 0 factorial is one now
let's see an error case where we pass a
minus 5 as you can see this will throw
us an error because factors are not
defined for negative numbers now Moving
On Let's uh so the next function that
we'll talk about is the ceiling function
so the ceiling function is defined using
math dot CL as you see here so again we
pass the number that we want the ceiling
for in between the parenthesis so what
is the Searing function it gives you the
largest uh sorry excuse me it gives you
the smallest number that is uh greater
than or equal to what we pass over here
so for an example if I give you 6.6 and
I asked you okay what is the ceiling
function for 6.6 it should give you 7
because 7 is the largest integer in
integral value that is greater than 6.6
or equal to it obviously if you give the
ceiling function for an integer it will
give you the integer itself so let's
look at an example 7.8 so this should
give me the value 8 as you can see here
let's look at it now a negative number
so minus 12.3 uh an integer that is
greater than minus 12.3 is is minus 12
the smallest integer that is greater
than minus 12.3 and this should give you
12 as you can minus 12 as you can see
here a similar function is the floor
function which is defined like this
again the floor function what it does it
gives you the greatest number that is
smaller than whatever value we pass
between the parenthesis so if I gave it
2.3 it should give me the value 2. again
if we pass integers it will just give us
the integer itself again it is to
reiterate this ceiling and flow
functions they give you into integer
values so the floor function will give
you the largest integer that is smaller
than what we pass over here so let's
look at 6.7 so the largest integer that
is smaller than 6.7 is 6 and as you can
see this is our answer over here uh the
next function that we will look at is
the truncate function the transcript
function is defined using this truncate
is very similar to what we have seen
this is how we Define the truncate
function uh it is very similar to the
ceiling and floor uh in the truncate
function what we do is
um we pass a decimal value a float
number to the between between the
parenthesis and what we get back is the
number without the decimal component so
only the integral component so if I gave
it 7.8 for example it will give me only
the seven part it will return me only
the seven part and it will chop away the
point eight part if I gave it minus 12.3
uh it will chop away the 0.3 part and
give me only minus 12 back so let's look
at an example 8.9 it should give me only
eight as you can see here see I did
minus 8 or minus
6.9 it should give me -6 so you can
think of truncate function as it does
the floor function for positive values
and it does the ceiling function for
negative values because it rounds down
and rounds up respectively for positive
and negative values so now let's look at
the next set of arithmetic functions
um let's move on to permutations
permutations are defined using this as
you know so in between the parenthesis I
have to pass two values n and K okay so
I have to pass n n and a k the K has to
be less than or equal to n because the
permutation as you know is uh the number
of ways in which we can permute from n
objects K Tire K different objects uh so
what this mathematically what this is is
um permutation of N and K is n factorial
divided by n minus K factorial so if I
pass say 10 and 6 it will give me the
permutation of 10 and 6. so let's look
at what's the value as you can see it's
a very large value fifteen one fifty one
thousand two hundred similarly there is
a combination function and this is a
combinations of permutations are used a
lot in probability so if you're going to
move into that sphere which you will
encounter a lot in machine learning AI
you will be using these functions quite
a bit
um so the combination function again you
pass an n and a k again the N should be
greater than or equal to this K what
this evaluates is n factorial divided by
n minus K factorial times K factorial so
again this is a mathematical concept so
let's look at the permutation sorry the
combination of 10 and 6. so as you can
see it gives me 210 which is the
combination of 10 seconds in the
arithmetic function section
um our gcd and LCM as we know gcd is the
greatest common divisor LCM is least
common multiple so as of the newest
version of python in three point python
3.9 the math module gets these two new
functions that were very lately added
actually
um since uh I cannot show you that
because I don't have the absolute latest
version of python on my system but using
the
math.gcd function this is the function
and in between this we would what we
would do if we had the latest version is
we would pass two numbers or as many
numbers in fact and what this function
will do is find the common divisor
amongst them so if I give these say for
example if I gave these numbers it would
give me the value 10. similarly the LCM
function again added in the python 3.9
finds the common multiple amongst or
whatever we pass over here so if I
passed say 20 and 30 this will give me
uh the value of 60 which is the LCM of
20 and 30. so again these are it's
something neat that if you say you have
python 3.9 or uh if you have python 3.9
or after that you will have access to
these functions as well if you when you
import the math module so that was for
the arithmetic functions let's move on
to the next section which are power and
logarithmetic logarithmic functions so
let's start off with the power function
um there are two there are uh multiple
ways you can actually do a power
function in math in Python so you can do
something like this which is the
equivalent of 2 to the power 3 or you
can use the inbuilt uh module math and
you can use the pow or the power
function which is this is how you do it
and if I had to do same 2 to the power 3
I would just pass 2 and 3 has arguments
like this and it should give me the
value as you can see 8 over here what if
so there's actually one more function
which is simply the pow function and
this is uh not part of the math module
it's a function not part of the math
module but it's still part of the base
python use this as well and you can do
the same thing pow 2 and 3 it should
give you the value 8 again the now you
might ask what's the difference between
these two functions well it's not much
for at least in a beginner standpoint
it's not that much just note that the
maths dot power function is slightly
computationally faster than the simple
power function so yeah moving on their
next topic would be the next function
that we'll discuss is the exponential
function which is defined like this
again exponential function is again e to
the power something so if I did
exponential of 3 this would give me e to
the power 3. so as you can see oh of
course I did not Define the module
beforehand so math.exp now when I do
this it should it will give me some
value which is basically Euler's number
or e to the power 3. so this was the
exponential function and let's look at
an example so we will look at the
example of rate of DK and we will use
the uh this function in that example so
the exponential rate of Decay
um uh for uh is used to calculate the
amount of radioactive elements that is
present in a substance after a certain
amount of time so the the the the the
expression is uh something like the
initial amount of radioactive elements
that were present uh right at the
beginning times the exponent of minus
693 times t t for time divided by the
time period the half-life time uh so
let's just write it down to make it
simple so again as you can see the uh so
this will give me the remaining amount
of radioactive elements right so let's
uh so write down remaining let's assign
this to a variable remaining so the
initial again
um initial is the initial amount of
radioactive elements so let's give it
some value say 100
um the time let's assume it's 10 years
and let's say the half-life
um Half-Life is around I don't know
let's give some value say three or
something again this is uh the details
are not important so this will I'm using
the math dot exponential function over
here as you can see and for these values
uh now when I check what's the value of
remaining after I calculated it's
something uh so this is it's basically
what this tells me is that I started off
with 100 units of some radioactive
element
um and in 10 years if this is what is
left so yeah so this is how we would use
say the X exponential functions in a
particular example of ours so next the
next type of again functions are
logarithmic functions so let's look at
some of the logarithmic functions that
are part of the math module so basic log
function would be written like this math
DOT log in in between this I would pass
the number that I want the log for by
default if I just pass one number it
will it will calculate the log of 8 to
the base of e as we know e is the
Euler's number so let's see what it does
in this case gives me some value what if
I wanted to specify a particular base
well I would pass this second argument
in this case I want to find the log of a
to the base 2 this should be the value 3
as you can see over here there are two
specific functions that are also
provided in this math module that is log
2 uh what this will do is again it will
again I have to just pass one argument
and this will automatically find the
value of the log of 8 to the base 2 as
you can see here similarly there is a
math DOT log 10 function if I give if I
did this I will find the value of
something here to the base 10 as you can
see so this was a logarithmic functions
then you have the finally you have the
square root function so how would we use
the math the square root function is Max
dot sqrt again we passed what we want
over here if we want the square root of
say 49 this should give me the value 7
as you can see finally maybe move on to
the final set of functions that we can
do using this math module uh they are
trigonometric functions and they are
hyperbolic functions so let's start off
with some of the trigonometric functions
as we know
um we can do sine we can do cosine and
tan uh some of the basic functions
um the way we would do it is math DOT
sign in between this what we this is to
calculate the sign of a particular angle
and this angle must be passed in radians
and this is very important to note we do
not pass it in degrees but in radians so
if I say past sine of 3.14 as we know
3.14 is an approximation of the value by
sine Pi is supposed to be in fact it's
supposed to be zero so let's see we get
something close 0 again since this is an
approximation it won't give us the exact
value similarly we can use math dot cos
to find the value of a particular angle
if you want to find yeah if you want to
find the value of the sorry the cost of
a particular angle we can use the tan
function in case we wanted to find the
tan similarly we have the next set for
arc sine and the arc cosines of the
certain of angles so to use to find the
arc sine for example we would use a DOT
sign I mean sorry a sign for R cosine we
would use this and for r10 we would use
this the next set would be hyperbolic
functions again hyperbolic functions are
basically the sine and the cosine and
the time calculated not circles but on
hyperbolas again the details don't have
to be you don't have to know the details
you just should you should know that if
you wanted to say for example find out
the hyperbolic sign of n and a of an
angle we would use math dot sine H and
we would pass what we wanted between
this similarly if we wanted to find the
cosine it would be cos H tan it would be
tan H and if we wanted to find the
inverse of the hyperbolic inverse we
what we would do is what we would do is
use a so we would use a tan H if you
wanted to find the hyperbolic inverse uh
of sine we would use a sine H and
similarly for cos it would be cos a COS
H in this video we will learn about
conditional statements and we will learn
about how do we create these control
structures where we have these
conditional statements we will learn
about the keywords if we use in Python
to create a conditional statement block
the if keyword the alif keyword and the
else keyword we will also learn about
indentation and its importance in Python
so let's get started so the basic uh
syntax if you will for a if statement in
Python consists of the keyword if
followed by an expression as you can see
from this pictorial if there's an if
statement there is a expression uh there
is this a block of code which if you can
actually see is slightly indented to the
rest of the code uh and then we have the
rest of the rest of our code after that
so what we're looking at is this so this
is our if statement block
um now let's let's break this down so
what is this expression that we're
speaking of uh an expression in this
context is a Boolean expression which
evaluates to a true or false statement
so when we are speaking about the if
statement we have an expression and if
this expression evaluates to true then
we execute everything below the if
statement otherwise we skip that portion
as you can see if the statement is true
we execute this statement or these
statement blocks uh otherwise if it's
false we move on to the next the next
statement block or the beginning of a
new statement uh so let's look at an
example to further understand this let's
take this if statement over here as you
can see in this if statement I have this
expression 50 greater than 30. so what
python is going to do now is it's going
to check whether 50 is greater than 30
and it's going to check in a Boolean
context if this is true then we can move
on to the next portion which is this but
if it is false then we will skip this so
let's see what this uh what happens over
here so since we know that 50 is indeed
greater than 30 this is a true
expression we move on to this block of
code which is saying that print 50 is
indeed a larger number than 30. so let's
see if this actually gets printed so as
you can see we get this uh the result
which is this is a true statement and we
get our print statement getting executed
what if we give a false expression over
here so let's look at what happens if I
give a false expression now I'm checking
if 50 is lesser than 30 which is a false
statement so if it's a false statement
we do not move on to this portion of our
if statement block and we we directly in
fact we directly skip so if I have to
execute this you will see nothing gets
executed and in fact my print statement
is just not executed because we never
entered this because our expression over
here was indeed false so yeah this is
how a basic if statement block looks
like in Python and this is how the uh
how we move on to how we check for the
true the truth truthfulness or the
falseness of a particular expression in
the if statement so moving on
um let's move on to the topic of
indentation in in Python so as you can
see this uh this if statement is an
example of a control structure so
without moving without defining uh what
a control control structure is in detail
control structures consists of these
conditionals or Loops or iterations if
you will uh so all of these control
structures involve heavy indentation so
so what does an indentation mean well
what if I gave you an example say I gave
you some variable called H and I wrote
20 over here now if I give you an if
statement saying if age is greater than
10 now uh it's very important to note
that when I'm defining an if statement I
need this colon otherwise this if
statement is not defined so this colon
is important anyways so now I'm checking
this expression if age is greater than
10. now what is this what happens if H
is greater than 10 now what if I want
python to do something only if age is
greater than 10 well how do I tell
python that there is a piece of code or
a section of code that I want executed
only if this condition is met well this
is where indentation comes into play so
if I want say if I want this line this
person is an adult okay and this is some
random line where I'm assuming age is
pertaining to this adult all right or
this person so if I have this variable
age where I write this number 20 which
denotes the age of some person and I'm
doing a check if age is greater than 10
actually let's be specific here well the
adult age for most people is 18 in most
countries so let's see if age is greater
than 18. now if I'm doing this check uh
I want to print this statement only if
this person is a person's age is above
20 above 18 so how do I tell python that
I only want this statement to be uh
executed only during this if this
condition is met whereas this is where
indentation comes into play and as you
can see exactly as you can see uh this
part this portion of the code is
slightly indented compared to the if
statement so when this condition is met
then only do we move on to this if this
condition is not met we move on to
whatever the next section of code will
be like whatever whatever code that we
have after this if statement so let's
see so this since this condition is
actually met as you can see this print
statement is actually executed so this
is the importance of indentation now we
will see uh in as we move as we learn
more about if statements and else
statements and alif statements how
indentation plays a key role in defining
what we want as an output when a certain
condition is met all right so for now
it's very important to understand that
this is how indentation is used in
Python in other languages we might use
uh we probably don't use indentation in
fact popular language the C language
does not use indentation at all but some
languages and python in probably the
trademark language for indentation and
programming so you might say that so
different people have different opinions
on an indentation the general consensus
is that indentation helps make the code
look very presentable and very readable
and this actually is one of the facets
of Python Programming is the indentation
and the easy readability of it anyways
moving on so what if we have
um multiple conditions in our code or if
in our if statement block that we want
to see so let's create this list or
let's actually just copy this example
that I have written over here as you can
see what I am doing in this piece of
code is I have a list X where I have
this integer 50 I have two strings get
an Apple now I want to check a bunch of
things so I want to check if 60 is an X
and I also want to check if the string
cat is an X and I want a final sort of
like if none of these conditions are met
I want something to happen so how do we
do that well we start off our state our
if statement block with the standard if
keyword all right now if we have one
more condition that we want met then we
can use the L if which is kind of a
short form for else if so we use the L
if keyword so it so what this python
what python reads is it checks this
condition then it will check this
condition and then finally we have this
else keyword and else is a keyword used
in our blog to tell python that if none
of our earlier Expressions have been
true then do what is in the uh there
that is within the else keyword that is
indented within the else keyword so
again we don't pass an expression for
else because else is only we only Reach
This LL statement in case all of the
earlier conditions have not been met or
have come to be false and not true so
let's look at uh this particular code
example so we have a list of 50 cat and
apple and I'm my first expression that
I'm checking is uh is 60 in X so this is
how we check actually so if 60 and X
should be read as is 60 in the list X so
is this 16 elix list X well actually no
we don't have the object 60 so this part
is not executed we move on to the next
condition is the string cat in X well
actually it is the string cat is indeed
in X so we move on to this statement
block which is within the condition that
is met which is print cat is in list X
and you will see that none of the other
statement blocks will be executed
because we have met our condition over
here so if I execute this as you can see
that the print statement cat is in this
text is what is actually executed and we
do not execute this obviously because it
is false and we do not even check or we
do not even move on to the statement
because well we have a condition mat
over here so it's a one thing that is
important to note is that we can use as
many alif statements to check for as
many conditions that we we want to check
for but it's very important that we only
use and if we are using that we only use
one else statement and only at the end
of our block okay so moving on now I'm
going to show you a very neat example
about how python actually does its uh
these condition checkings so it's very
important to note that once a condition
is met none of the other conditions are
even checked for so we do not even
consider the next statements and we
directly leave this if statement block
so let's look at this example over here
now in this example that I have over
here is where I've stored the string cat
in X now I have three uh I have three
conditions that I'm checking I'm
checking is 50 greater than 60. I am
checking if the value of x is indeed cat
and I'm checking I'm some random
expression 1 divided by 0. this is not
even a check this is literally just
checking if 1 divided by 0 is true or
false and as we know we cannot divide
anything by zero so let's see what
happens when I execute this statement
now typically if I wrote 1 divided by 0
python would throw me an error because 1
cannot be divided by zero that is an
error error statement so let's see what
happens when I do this actually as you
can see I have a statement being printed
but I have no error even though I gave
it wrong I gave an error statement in 1
divided by 0 well now you might ask why
is that so well it's simply because I
have actually never reached this
condition I have not even python is not
bothered looking at this because if you
actually see there is a condition
previous to this uh over here which is
met and which is true so we move on to
this block we execute this block and we
forget about the rest of the code so we
don't actually get to this error
statement which is an interesting thing
and which is an example that I have
shown uh to show you that once a
condition is met in an if statement
block we do not look at any of the
further conditions that are being
checked okay so finally
um I have one one small topic that I
would like to share with you is the
conditional expressions or the pythons
ternary operator now this is slightly
different to the if statement that we
have talked about up until now uh in the
sense that it is not a control structure
so what this actually is is more of an
operator that defines some expert
question so let's see what I'm trying to
say over here so as you can see over
here highlighted is the Syntax for what
I'm trying to talk about this ternary
operator so let's look at this example
and let's see what I'm trying to do over
here so I have this variable age all
right and this age is 26. now X now just
just read this statement X is equal to
adult if age is greater than 18 else
child now I could have done an elaborate
control structure with an if statement
then an indentation within that if
statement and then
um I could have written else and then
another indentation and I would have
written another statement over there but
instead of that I have used this
operator to assign a particular value to
the variable X and this uh what value
I'm assigning to X depends on if this
condition is true or false so as you can
see the condition says is age 18 uh
greater than 18. so if this is true then
I assign this particular string if it is
false then I go to the the else
statement and I assign this so since age
26 is greater than 18 I should assign
the string adult to X and as you can see
if I execute this and check what is an X
you can see adult is indeed in X so this
is a very neat a very needable readable
and a very um it's a it's probably a
more it's it's a better looking way uh
to perform simple else uh Sim simple if
and else statements where you don't want
to create a whole um if stay if if else
statement control structure block so
yeah this was the ternary operator
finally we let's uh we we make a short
note on the pass statement uh in Python
so the path statement or the pass
keyword is a a place where it is is a
placeholder of sorts so what if I had an
if statement and I'm writing a piece of
code but I don't know what to do with
this if statement so if if a statement
is correct if a statement is true
um but I don't know what to do if this
statement was true how do I tell python
well let's just keep it a hold for now
and I might put something into this
block later in the future well I would
use the pass statement so if I had this
say this some condition again so I'm
checking age is greater than 18 but I
don't know what to do with this I would
just simply use this past statement and
this basically does nothing uh it it's a
way to it's it's like a way to create a
placeholder where maybe in the future I
might have I might write some sort of a
say a print statement or some sort of a
different function or something else
within this indentation so but in the
meantime like currently I don't have
anything to place over here so I just
leave it with a pass statement so this
is a way where you can use a pass
statement in if and as statement or if
an else control structures in this video
we will be I will introduce you to the
concept of iterations in Python and we
will be speaking in specific about the
indefinite iteration advice and
otherwise known as the while loop so
let's look at what an iteration means an
iteration is uh executing the same block
of code over and over potentially many
times a programming structure that
implements an iteration is called a loop
now in programming we have two types of
iterations definite and indefinite
iterations and in this example we will
be speaking about indefinite iterations
in definite iterations in Python is the
while loop where we use the while
keyword to Define an indefinite
iteration so let's look at the basic
syntax as you can see this is the basic
syntax where we have the while keyword
followed by an expression and again the
colon and below that is something
indented again we encounter indentations
the psych NFL statements a set of
statements where what happens here is
following the while keyword we have this
expression where this expression is
evaluated in a Boolean context again we
check if this expression evaluates true
or false and if it is true we execute
all the statements or the statement
block that is indented below this file
statement this is another example of
control structure much like FNL state in
blocks where we use a lot of indentation
so let's look at a basic example now of
while loop so let's copy this example
and let's see what this does so I have a
variable n where I am assigning it a
value 0. this is called an initializing
process and it's very important to note
that most while Loops consist of an
expression which contains a variable a
control variable uh which is usually
initialized prior to starting the loop
and then this control variable is
typically very modified somewhere within
the main Loop body so in this case my
control variable is n and I am
initializing it by assigning it the
value 0. so let's move into the loop now
so the loop has this while keyword as
you can see followed by a an expression
n lesser than or equal to 5. now what
this is is an expression which is going
to check if it's true or false is n
lesser than or equal to 5 and as long as
this expression is true we will continue
when you're doing whatever is indented
below this y statement and what is below
this y statement is a print statement
first of all which says value of n is
and it basically prints a value of n in
that particular iteration and as you can
see this uh compound assignment where we
add the value of n by 1 and we assign it
back to n so what this is uh let's see
what this does actually let's execute
this and see what this does uh important
to note the value of n again is
initialized at zero so this while while
loop will keep going on until the value
of n remains lesser than or equal to 5.
so as you can see I have the execution
of this uh particular block of code or
this while loop where I get the multiple
different iterations of this print
statement that you can see here the
first iteration it says value of n is 0
then it's the value of n is 1. what I'm
doing is I am writing I am assigned I am
writing uh the value of n multiple times
uh and each time the value of n is
written over here based on what
iteration it is so what is happening
actually is uh that initially the value
of n is 0 and I print the statement
value of n is 0. now I add uh the value
of what is In N by 1 so now what is the
value of n so again we do this check so
after this first iteration we come back
or like once this whole uh code block of
code is executed we again come back to
this expression and we again check if
the statement is true so now that the
value of n is actually 1 if this
statement is still true so again we
execute this and that you can see over
here value of n is 1. now again we add
the value of n by 1 and again we go back
here once this uh this block is executed
and we check if this statement is true
again and as you can see the value of n
when it's 2 is still uh making sure that
this expression is true and this keeps
happening until the value of n is
greater than 5. so once the value of n
becomes 6 this condition is no longer
met and finally we do not execute the
statement because this expression
evaluates to false and we do not do this
anymore and we finally leave our while
loop so let's check what the value of n
is just to confirm this as you can see
the value of n is indeed 6 and that is
why we have left this while loop over
here so this is an example of a basic
while loop where we check for this uh an
expression if it evaluates to true we
evaluate everything within it once this
is done we go back and we evaluate this
expression again if it is again true we
again go back into whatever is indented
within it and we keep doing this until
the expression gives us false and
interestingly we don't uh we don't
necessarily have to Define these control
variables always we can actually use uh
iterables and we will learn about
iterables actually in a future video but
we can use it rubles and an example of
an iterable is the list so let's look at
this list and let's look at this whole
block all right so I created this list a
which contains five objects one two
three four and five all integer objects
and I have another variable double X
where I store the integer one now I'm
this while statement now it might look
confusing now it says it says while a
now what is a well a is not uh your
typical expression where you're making
sure if some condition is being met or
not but this the way you read this is
while a exists so in the context of a
list as long as a which is a list
contains objects within it a is true if
it does not have any objects within it a
is false so while a basically what it
means is while a has objects within it
and if it does have objects within it or
as long as it does we continue executing
whatever is indented within this y
statement and this y statement is a
print statement again we uh do like we
we have this value X where we
um we're doing this this we're printing
this is iteration number and we pass X
so the first iteration obviously pass X
is equal to 1 and then we add X by 1 and
then the second iteration should pass
this is iteration number two and then so
on and finally we have another statement
within this block called the a called
the pop statement where we're popping
the elements of a now as if you would
have seen the list the video on lists
the pop statement removes the rightmost
value uh from a list so if I do a DOT
pop initially it will remove 5 from this
list and I will have the rest of them
again if I do pop it will remove 4 from
this list and then you will have the
rest of these so let's actually see
we'll actually check what's left in this
list each time we do this pop statement
so I'll also print the list a each
during each iteration and let's see what
happens over here as you can see what is
happening out here is while a or while a
has elements we are going to continue
doing this y statement whatever is
within it so in the first iteration
obviously we have all of it and it is
iteration number one and as you can see
the list contains everything then I pop
it then iteration number two it again
has elements but it has lost its most
rightmost element and this keeps on
happening until the list finally has no
elements left and once the element or
invents a list has no elements left we
this expression while a evaluates to
false and we do not execute this anymore
and we leave the while low and again
let's check what is in a a should have
no elements as you can see it's an empty
list when a check written a it's an
empty list and that is why while a
return near false and we do not print
any further so this is an example of
using a virus statement using lists and
of course the next topic would be
discussing nested while loops and this
is a broad topic what I mean by this is
that when when I'm saying nested while
Loops I'm actually talking about nested
control structures so we can have while
Loops within while Loops not only that
we can have FNS statements within while
Loops we can have while Loops within if
and else statements and we can have FNL
statements within FNL statements so if
you think of all of these loops and we
will even speak our for Loops in the in
the in in a in another video for Loops
again in a type of control structure so
all of these are control structures
while Loops are control structures for
Loops or control structures if and as
statements are control structures all
these are control structures and nesting
can happen within them and it does not
matter uh which is the like the parent
of the nest and then the child or the
nest we can have a while loop within an
ifnl statement you can have for Loops
within a while loop all of this is valid
in Python and uh it's one of the one of
the great features of python that is
very flexible in this way so let's look
at an example where I have a while loop
within another while loop so I am
copying this piece of code where I have
this list one two three four five and
another list first and second now my
first while loop I print I print what is
pop from a so I take a then I pop the
zeroth index so basically from the left
hand side and I print what is that all
right and then I have another while loop
where I have this list B and I'm doing
the same thing but this while loop is
within the first while loop and let's
see what happens out here so as you can
see my first uh my first iteration of
this parent while loop causes me to pop
what is the first element which is one
then I do these while loops and this is
completely executed and only then do I
go back to this first one and then I
come back and do all of this again then
I go back to this one and then I come
back into all of this again and that's
why you can see this repetition so I
have this first iteration and then I do
uh the second while loop then I have the
second iteration and then I do the
second while loop and I keep doing this
and this is an example of a nested while
loop okay so our next Topic in this sec
in this video would be break in continue
statements now break in continue
statements are ways to abruptly end
iterations uh in in a particular Loop
now you can use break in continue
statements not only in while loop where
you can use it and also in for Loops so
let's look at how we use it in while
loops and let's look at what we mean by
breaking contain the statements first of
all well the break statement terminates
the loop entirely so once the break
statement is found the the complete
while loop that we are using is
completely terminated and the continue
statement on the other hand terminates
only the current Loop iteration and it
goes back to the beginning or the
expression and it checks whether the
expression or the or the controlling
expression is again reevaluated and it
is checked whether the loop will execute
again or terminate this pictorial that
you can see here actually emphasizes or
it shows the difference between break
and continue so I have this while loop
and I have an expression all right I
have a bunch of statements and I have a
break command over here and I have a
continue command over here so if I
encounter the break command it will not
execute any of this in fact it will not
execute this wire statement at all and
it will move on to the next piece of
code that we have but a continuous
statement if a continuous statement is
income about it in a while loop will not
completely break away but it will not uh
it will not execute the the rest of the
statements in that iteration only these
two but it will go back here it will
check this expression again and again we
will do this all over again so this is
this small uh difference between the
break and continue statements but both
are used to abruptly end an iteration in
a loop so let's look at an example of
how we use the break statement so I will
use this example where I have again I
have initialized some controlling
variable n to 0 my first Loop will check
whether n is less than equal to 5 if
this is true then I will print this
statement then I will what I'm doing
over here is I am incrementing it by one
now in my previous my earlier example
using a similar uh using the similar
example I had no like this this part was
not there so what you got was I was
printing the value of n so it was
printing as like value of n is 1 I mean
0 and then one and then two and then
three four 4 and 5 but over here I've
included a small I've nested an if
statement and within that I put a break
statement and this if statement is
checking if if n is equal to equal to 2
so once n is 2 I move on to this and I
do the break statement so let's see what
happens now as you can see once so when
I have executed this I don't get the
whole value of n is 0 and then 1 and
then two three four five I I stop at one
and that is because once n is equal to 2
I actually do not execute this while
loop again I do not go back and execute
print value of n is 2 now in fact I
break from this whole while loop and my
while loop terminal is right then and
there and that's why you only get these
two iterations value of n is 0 and then
value of n is one okay so now I'm going
to show you a neat example of what
happens or what is the difference
between a break and a continuous
statement okay so let's uh go back to
our initial example where we're printing
this value of n is 0 1 2 3 4 and so on
but I have added one more statement
where I print hello at each iteration so
let's see see what happens when I do
this as you can see it will print hello
after each of whatever I was doing
already now let's introduce our break
statement first of all so when I do
break well let's go back to this if
statement if his if we check this
condition then we break let's see what
happens now as you can see something
interesting has happened where we have
this first iteration completely being
executed but the second iteration kind
of stops where there's no hello and that
is because we have broken from this
while loop before the second iterations
hello was printed let's see the
difference between a break and continue
now so now I have this continuous
statement and instead of a break let's
see what happens here as you can see it
seems familiar to our first example
where we did not have any break or
continue but there is a small difference
that I want you to catch and that is
very important about this continue uh
statement so as you can see the first
iteration has value of n is 0 and then
hello and value of n is 1 but there is
no hello and this is because this is
because once this condition is actually
met we do not move on to this statement
but we go back to this expression and we
will evaluate this expression and then
once we evaluate this expression again
and it's found to be correct we do
everything the same again when we print
hello but except for that one step where
this if statement was met and we did
continue and this following statement
was not executed and that happens only
for one iteration and that is when n is
equal to equal to 2 and as you can see
that is what happens over here in one of
the iterations we may say hello and that
is the difference of the continue
statement between uh there is a
difference of the continuous statement
with the break statement this video will
be an extension into that topic where we
will be looking at three examples where
we are using while Loops along with
other stuff like say if and else
statements so our first example will be
where we calculate the factorial of a
number in this example as you can see
here we are first going to ask the user
to enter a particular number for us now
this number is supposed to be an integer
once we have this integer we store it to
a variable called number now we have
this you can say this variable called
fac which does one and you we will see
how we are using it later now we know
that the factorial of 0 is 1 that's how
it's just defined so we have an if
statement checking whether our entered
number is 0 and if it is 0 we say that
the result is 1 or the factorial is one
however if we enter a number that is
greater than 0 we must calculate the
factor oil for this number and that is
what we are going to do in this else
statement block over here now in this
else statement block we have a while
loop in this while loop the condition is
checking while number is greater than or
equal to 1. so as long as this condition
is true everything within that while
loop will be executed so as long as
number is greater than equal to 1 we are
going to execute these two lines now
what do these two lines do let us see so
the first line takes the variable fac
where we had the number one stored and
we are going to store FEC times number
into it number being the number that we
have inputted so in case for example we
start we entered 8 then what this will
do this line will do is 1 into 8 and it
will store that back into fac now once
that is done we move on to the next line
where we are decrementing the number
variable by one so if we have stored 8
or we have entered 8 into our input it
will become 7. now as we know 7 is still
greater than or equal to 1 so this
condition is still being met and then we
do this process again where we are going
to multiply fac this time fac stores the
value 8 and we multiply it times the new
number which is 7 now so we do 8 into 7
and then again we decrement this uh also
once we do 8 into 7 we store it back
into fac and we keep doing this where we
keep multiplying 8 times 7 and then we
decrement the number variable uh by one
and then we check this condition again
so what ends up happening is we are
going to keep doing 8 into 7 into 6 into
5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1 and once
we are at 1 again when we do this
document operation the number variable
we store the value 0 and then this
condition will no longer be met so
number will be 0 and this condition will
be false and we can move out of this
while low then finally we store the
result into a variable called result
which stores the result of 8 into 7 into
to 6 into 5 into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1
this is of course if we did enter 8 when
we were asked to give an input so let's
see this
um in real time once we execute this so
I'm executing this the first thing it
asks me is to enter a number so let's
say I enter my number 8 as I was
speaking about eight all right now that
I have entered 8 as you can see the
result that it gives me is factorial of
8 is 4 0 3 2 0 which is correct and you
can check this for yourself where it
will show you
um 8 times 7 or 8 factorial is basically
this this number okay so now in our next
example we will be looking at how we can
generate Fibonacci numbers for this
example we will be using bunch of if and
else if statements along with a while
loop so let's look at this piece of code
where we are actually doing this so as
you can see the first part of the code
is basically an input statement asking
us how many Fibonacci numbers we would
like to generate and then the user it
would be asked to give an input which is
stored as an INT into a variable count
now in this if a statement the first if
statement checks whether what we have
entered is 0 in which case we just store
an empty array in the variable called
FIB next if our entered integer is 1 we
just store the value 1 in this array
called FIB if our entered number is 2 we
store 1 and 1 in the array FIB all of
these are different sets of Fibonacci
sequences this obviously an empty an
empty array shows that well there is no
numbers to be generated in this sequence
if we have one we just print the first
number of the Fibonacci sequence which
is one itself if it is 2 we print the
first two numbers which is one and one
now the actual calculations happen when
we say we want a Fibonacci sequence for
more than two numbers now in that case
we move on to this block in this
statement block we initialize the FIB
variable with the first two Fibonacci
numbers one and one and we store in this
very in this array now we are going to
do a while loop within this and in this
while loop we're going to keep executing
this statement block as long as this
condition is met or this condition is
true and what this condition is is it's
checking this variable I which we have
initialized as 1 over here and we're
going to check whether that is lesser
than count -1 count being the number
that we have been asked to input if the
statement is true and as long as the
statement is true we will be executing
this statement block which is basically
us appending this expression into the
array FIB now what this expression is is
basically it's going to keep adding so
each subsequent numbers and we are going
to store each subsequent numbers back
into the array Fib so in this case if
you see the fourth the first step will
do is it will take the value at the
first portion of the array fib and it
will add it to the value at the 0th
position of the array fib and both of
these values since they are 1 and 1 when
we add them we get 2 and we append that
to Fib so now our FIB will look like 1
comma 1 comma two then we increment this
by 1 and what we do is we do the same
process again so in the next step what
will be what we would do is we would do
2 plus 1 so we would get three now this
would keep going on until this condition
is met or basically until uh the numbers
that we actually want to generate in our
sequence so let's like let's let's uh
execute this and let's see an example of
what happens so it asks me how many
Fibonacci numbers I would like to
generate and I will say I want the first
let's say six Fibonacci numbers so I
execute this as you can see this gives
me the first six numbers in the sequence
which is 1 and 1 and then 2 which is
basically one plus one and then three
which is one plus two and then 5 which
is 2 plus 3 8 which is three plus five
so if we wanted more numbers we would
just enter over here like say if we
wanted the first 10 numbers it would
give us the first 10 numbers in the
sequence as you can see here now in our
next example what we are going to do is
we are going to write a program which
takes two digits that represent the
dimensions of an array for example if we
want a three by three array we will
enter three comma 3 and we are going to
generate a two dimensional array in
which each of the elements of the array
are basically the row times the column
position of that particular element and
what I mean by this is say we have a
position I comma J on the array the
value of the element at that position
would be I times J so for example if I'm
looking at something at the third row
and the fifth column or say the third
row and the third column for example the
value of the element would be 3 times 3
and if I'm looking at something at the
second row and the fourth column I am
going to do two times four so let's uh
let's see how we can do this using Code
so if you look to the right over here I
have a piece of code where I'm going to
uh in where it asks me to input two
numbers two integers to represent the
dimensions of my uh example my sample
array now once we have done this we are
going to store these uh these dimensions
in the inputs in in a variable called
input string so obviously when we enter
say 5 comma 5 that will be stored as an
INT in this particular string or this
variable what we want is we want five
say we entered five comma five we want
five as a separate integer and the other
five as another separate integer and
that is what we do in this particular
statement where we're going to split up
our input string based on the comma
separator and we're going to store the
first part of that string into the zero
width position of Dimensions which is an
array and the next dimension in the
first position in this particular array
now we are going to store the number of
rows as row number and that is the
zeroth position of this array and we're
going to store the code number of
columns as the first position of
Dimensions or whatever we've mentioned
in the input so now we we have this our
results array called multi list which is
basically what what our final error is
going to look like and we are going to
store into multi-list and in this
example we will be using for Loops to do
this or to create this particular array
so as you can see here our first uh we
have initialized our multi list saying
that um we're going to have only zeros
in our sample array so initial leave
once we have initialized this array all
multi lists will contain is a say for
example we have inputted a five by five
array it will have basically a 5x5 array
with all elements as zero and that's
what this line does once we have done
this we are going to move on to the for
Loop portion where we are actually going
to create our array that we want so as
you can see we are our first for Loop is
going to say four row in range row
number so obviously a range will
generate a an iterator which can be
iterated over and since it says range
row number and say our the number of
rows that we entered were five what it's
going to do is it's going to create an
iterator containing the value 0 1 2 3
and 4. so for row and range it will
basically basically row will take the
value 0 1 2 3 and 4. and a similar thing
is going to happen in this nested for
Loop which is within this where we're
going to again uh create a an iterator
using this range function and for the
column number once we have this we're
going to do the simple process of
multiplying the uh the value of the
element based on its position so if it's
at the position 3 comma 4 we're going to
store the value 3 times 4 into that
particular position of the array and
we're going to do this for every
position which is what happens in these
two for Loops we are going to first go
by each row and then within that we're
going to check each column and we're
going to perform these calculations and
finally we print our result so let's
look at an example now I'm going to say
I want a 3 by let's say a 2 by 4 Matrix
so let's see what the results will be
when I give this as uh so what I'm
saying is I want two rows and four
columns now as you can see here it might
not be very clear to you right now but
what you can see here is this is the
first row and this is the second row and
each row contains four columns so these
are the this is the my final array that
I get so what you can see here is this
is the zeroth position and the uh or you
can say this is the first row First
Column first row second column and uh
since python is zero based so this is
actually the zeroth row and this is the
first row so as you can see uh this this
value basically is zero times one this
value is zero times two zero times three
zero times four and over here it is one
time zero one times one one times two
one times three so similarly if I did
for example a five by five Matrix what
you will get is five rows now five rows
and five columns and for example like
this particular value is uh one two
three or zero one two three so zero one
two three and the First Column so this
is three times one
um if I took this value this is like the
fourth row for example fourth row times
the um zero one two three third column
so this would be four times three which
is twelve so and each value of this has
been generated in the similar process so
this is an example of how we can use for
Loops
um for a particular exercise that I have
shown you right now in this video we
will be covering the topic of definite
iterations using for Loops in Python so
starting off we know that there are two
types of iterations in programming a
definite and indefinite we have already
covered indefinite iterations in the
form of while Loops definite iterations
on the other hand are done using the
keyword for and the basic syntax or the
standard Syntax for a basic for Loop in
Python is as you can see over here we
have this four keyword we have some
variable we have the in keyword and we
have this iterable and we of course
Define this control structure with the
colon and then indented we have this
statement block so once this for Loop
has started we execute all of these
statements within the statement block as
part of the for Loop iteration so yeah
let's uh now let's to understand like
how for loops work uh exactly let's look
at the concept or meaning behind what we
call iterables and iterators so so think
of it in a stepwise manner all right so
we in Python we have different objects
that can be used as iterables and an
iterable is basically some object that
uh it's it's a collection of other
objects so you know think of your lists
uh think of dictionaries and sets so all
of these are essentially collections of
objects so once we have these collection
of objects we can create an iterator out
of it uh how do we do that is we use the
iter function so for example if I pass
this list a if I pass this list a
through the iter function and I store it
in some variable either underscore a and
I see what is item underscore a it is
actually a list iterator at some random
memory location which we don't really
care about similarly if I gave a tuple
and I did the same thing I will create a
tuple iterator and in the left if you
can see over here I've done the exact
same functions with sets and
dictionaries as well so I'm creating
iterators out of these
eternal levels so as to speak uh now
what is an iterator well an iterator is
an object that yields values
successively so if my list contained
five values or five objects an iterator
of this list will yield these values uh
one after the other and that is kind of
how or that is the basis for which we do
we create Loops let's see what we
exactly mean using this uh using another
function that we call the next function
so the next function keeps moving from
object to object within an iterator so
since I've created this list iterator
let's just do it once again so as you
can see I've created this list iterator
underscore a now with this item
underscore a what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use this next function what
next function does is starting from the
leftmost object within this iterator I
will keep yielding or keep producing the
values so let's let's just see what
happens when I do next iterate when I do
next for this particular variable it
gives me this object first now let's see
what happens when I do it again
now it gives me the object second what
if I did it again it gives me third now
if I kept doing this it will keep giving
me the different objects that were
initially stored in a that is first and
then second third fourth and fifth one
after the other so let's actually
perform that now I get fourth now I get
fifth now a natural question is now that
I've exhausted all of these values what
will happen if I perform the next
function again well let's see what
happens I get a an error or and this
error is the stop iteration function
error which basically is telling me look
you have exhausted all of the objects
that were initially present in this list
a and you cannot you cannot keep doing
the next next function anymore you
cannot keep going further so yeah so
this is what the next function does when
it comes to the concept of iterators all
right so now we've learned two things
what is an iterator and what is the how
do we create an iterator out of
different collections of objects like a
list or a tuple and we've also learned
how to use the next function now let's
uh move or let's come back to our for
Loop that we started off this video with
so our for loop again let's consider our
for Loop over here
as you can see some for loop with the
objects again one two three four and
five all right this is a list now I'm
going to do for X in a print X and let's
try to see what happens when we do this
okay as you can see when I have executed
this it gives me one two three four and
five so I have first of all let's look
at this for loop I in this for loop I
Define a new variable X and then I say
for X in a print X and what's happening
well in each iteration I am printing
whatever the value of x is at present so
and the first iteration it is the first
object one in the second iteration it is
the second object two then three four
five and then finally uh on its own like
uh this for Loop knows that okay now
once I have exhausted all of the objects
within my iterator I can stop doing this
for Loop and I can move on with the rest
of the code all right so think of it
like a three-step process uh a for Loop
in Python the first step is it calls an
iter function to obtain an iterator for
whatever we pass over here this iterable
second step it calls the next function
repeatedly in each iteration all right
to keep getting the next item from the
iterator so it gets one then it calls
next then it gets two then it calls next
and it gets three and then four and then
five and so on and then finally the
third step is determination step is when
after we do the final next where we get
this error as you can see the stop
iteration error or exception finally
this tells the for Loop function or the
for Loop that okay we have reached the
end of our definite iteration or the end
of our definite for Loop and this is
where we must terminate our Loop and
then continue with the rest of the code
all right so this is how a for Loop
Works in Python now it's very important
to note that whatever we have discussed
when it came to while Loops such as
nesting of while loops and nesting of
other control structures is also
applicable in the case of for Loops so
if I had a for loop with in another for
Loop that is perfectly fine if I had a
while within a for Loop that is
perfectly fine so all of these are valid
statement blocks that we can do and
again for Loop is another control
structure and so we must follow the
concept of indentation when it comes to
writing our statement blocks within a
for Loop okay so now I'm going to speak
about in specific I'm going to speak
about the this something called the
range function that is uh quite you
could say it's used definitely it's used
in other areas of programming but it's
widely used in Python uh I mean I mean
the for Loop in Python uh what I mean by
this is that um Range this range
function is very important for the for
Loop and we will see why okay so let's
look at one of the examples of using the
range function so what does the range
function do is if I give range 5 let's
see what it does it gives me range 0 to
5. what this basically tells me is that
this will create an iterator that
contains uh integers from 0 to 5 so it
will contain the object 0 1 2 3 4 and 5
and we can use this as an iterator so
let's let's look at this uh I have Range
Five let's store this in X okay now
let's do a type just to see what happens
when we do Type X it should give me the
type of range as you can see and this is
a type of an iterator in Python now
let's see what happens when I do for I
in X print I okay let's see what happens
as you can see it prints the number 0 1
2 3 4. an important caveat when it comes
to the range function is when we say
range 5 it creates an iterator from 0 to
5 but it contains the objects 0 1 2 3
and 4 only it does not contain the
object 5 itself okay this is something
that is very important to so once again
I created I use this range function to
create an iterator from iterator 5
objects from 0 to 4 0 1 2 3 and 4. I use
that in my for Loop and that's what that
is what you are seeing here now let's
use this range function in the context
of something else for example let's see
so I had my earlier list a right look at
my list a here
so you can see list a contains these one
two three four five five objects okay
let's see what length of a is length of
a is five okay uh let's use the range
function on top of the length of this
list a and this is uh like I can't show
you an example right now without any
context but this uh this form of using a
for Loop is used is widely used in
Python Programming you will use it so
much in data science you will use so
much in machine learning and AI I cannot
tell you uh this is so this is a very
important like sort of for Loop
expression so you have four let's say I
in range Len a let's see what's going on
here first I create first I do length of
a that gives me 5 then into range of 5
that creates an iterator between 0 and 4
right when you do Range Five it gives
you an iterator of zero one two three
and four as we saw earlier and this is
what we're doing over here we have
created an iterator out of the length of
a list now when I do print I it should
give me again one two three four zero
one two three four of course so as you
can see here it will give me zero one
two three four and this is a very neat
way of using the range function on top
of the length of a particular collection
of objects in this case we're using the
list a this is something that you will
use a lot so I I would recommend that
you get used to this form of creating a
for loop as well using the range
function also of course
um there are uh the you can use break
and continue statements as you have in
the case of while Loops uh exactly this
it works exactly the same in the case of
for Loops wherein the break statement
will abruptly stop the for Loop
completely and we will move on to the
next piece of code whereas the continue
statement will break that particular
iteration and then we will resume with
the next iteration so yeah that was
break in continue statements in for
Loops finally I would like to show you
something about uh how to use
dictionaries as an iterator or or as an
iterable when it comes to for Loops so
let's create our dictionary let's go we
have a dictionary already here in fact
create this dictionary again we'll store
it in a okay so I created this
dictionary a all right so I have
dictionary a uh what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pass it through the iter
function as you can see and now I'm
going to just for the sake of showing
you it will show I'll show you that it
is actually an iterator of type of a
specific key iterator type all right so
now let's uh let's do something on this
so as you can see in the dictionary I
have the key first that has a value one
I have the key second that has a value
two I have the key third that has a
value three and then fourth for four
fifth for five now a good question would
be when I do iteration or when I do a
for loop on top of this a well what is
it going to pick up is it going to pick
up first uh is it going to pick up the
keys like these or is it going to pick
up the values or is it going to go one
by one key and then value and then key
in the subsequent value uh let's see
what actually happens let's do 4 I in
iter underscore a print I let's see what
what is The iterations Happening upon
using this so as you can see we're using
the keys so by default when we do this
when we perform when we create an
iterator out of a dictionary we use only
the keys as our uh iterator elements or
at iterator values but of course like if
you wanted to use values all you would
have to do is pass a DOT values over
here and if you remember from a
dictionary video this uh a DOT values
gives us a list of or it it gives us the
essentially a list of the values in our
dictionary so when we pass this to the
iterator uh iter function and we create
an iterator out of it let's see what
happens over here now let's see what is
ETA underscore a you can actually see
it's now the dict value iterator at a
particular memory location in so it's
not the dict key as we saw earlier it's
a direct value iterator so now that we
have this dictionary value iterator now
let's print what are our iterator
elements and as you can see now we are
printing values and not the keys so this
is how to this this is basically two
different ways of iterating through a
dictionary one through keys and one
through values in this video we will be
doing a small exercise on if statements
now in the previous video you might have
already seen some of the basic concepts
surrounding if statements however in
this video just to drive home the point
or the purpose of an if statement we
will be doing a small exercise so let's
first revise some of the concepts of an
if statement so basic if statement can
be something like this we have a small
condition where we are checking if a
variable X is greater than 5 or not and
if it is greater than x we print this
statement over here so if this condition
is met we print this statement as we
move to the statement log now our
variable X has the value 5. now since X
is not greater than 5 what this will do
is it will check the statement and since
this will be false we skip the statement
block and move on to this statement so
as you can see here similarly we can do
something where we are checking multiple
statements we use the L if statement in
such a case so now in this block we are
checking in one of the one of the
conditions we're checking is if x is
equal to 5 or if x is greater than 5 and
then finally if both of these conditions
are not met we say else and we print
whatever or we do whatever is in this
particular statement block which is a
simple print statement so as you can see
X is indeed good is equal to 5 so this
is the block that will get executed as
you can see here now another example our
nestative statements so nested FL
statements are if else statements within
if else statements so let's look at an
example as you can see here we have a
string stored in a variable called
orange quality and the string is fresh
now we have an integer or a float in
this case 4.0 stored in Orange price now
our first statement is checking whether
orange quality the variable orange
quality is it equal to the string fresh
now within that if the statement or if
this condition is met we do another
check where we're checking what is the
price is it lesser than 5 if it is V2
this block else we execute this block
finally if our initial uh statement our
initial condition is not met we move on
to this else block now when I execute
this what should happen is I will enter
this block because this is true and
finally I will enter this block because
this condition is also true so I should
have this printed I will buy five dozens
as you can see here now let's move on to
our main exercise for this video so this
was all just the revision now we're
gonna use some or all of these Concepts
in a sample project or a sample exercise
to for your further practice so in this
exercise what we are going to do is
we're going to request the user to enter
a number between 1 and 20 and our our
code is going to check whether this
number entered is an even number or an
odd number so as you can see there are
two sets of checks that we're going to
do in this code the first check is going
to be whether the number that is entered
is between 1 and 20 or not and if it is
not we have to say it's an invalid
number but if it is entered between 1
and 20 we have to move on to the further
checks which is whether it is an even or
an odd number so let's see how we do
that so in this piece of code what we
start with is a print statement saying
please enter a number between 1 and 20
and then we add an input command this
input command will open a box where we
can enter whatever number that we want
to enter now we use this int keyword to
make sure that whatever we have entered
into the input box is stored as a int
data type in the enter num variable once
we do that our first if statement is
going to check whether the entered
number is greater than or equal to 1 or
less than equal to 20. sorry and less
than equal to 20. so both of these
conditions have to be met if this
condition is true then we have a valid
input and this statement is printed that
we have entered a valid number and then
we move on to the rest of the statement
block within this if statement which is
another set of if and else if statements
if our number is not between 120 we move
to this block and this block prints that
we have entered in invalid number now
once we have say entered a valid number
we move on to this block this if if else
if alif statement block now what this
block is checking is whether the entered
number is an even number or not now as
we know an even number is divisible by 2
only the remainder 0 when divided by 2.
so this is what this check is doing if
this check is true that means our number
is even and we get printed that our
number is even the other other check or
the other uh if statement is checking
whether it's an odd number and that
means when we divide by 2 we should get
the remainder 1 as you can see here and
we get printed your number is odd so
let's execute this and see what happens
when we enter a number now it's asking
me to enter a number let's say I enter
17.
now that I have entered 17 as you can
see it's a valid number that I have
entered and the code is telling me that
my number is indeed odd let's look at
some other what if I entered something
else here let's say if I enter 16 now
since it's an even number as you can see
16 is also a valid number as it's
between 1 and 20 and my number is even
and the code checks for that let's see
if I what happens when I enter an
invalid number let's say 25 now when I
enter 25 as you can see it says I have
entered invalid number and in this case
what has happened is this condition
itself is not met and I have moved on to
this statement block so to give you a
breakdown as to how our code has
executed this let me show you an example
for the number say 9 when I enter nine
the first check that happens of course
is this check whether it's a valid
number or not and since it is between 1
and 20 we move on to this block and in
this block it's checking whether our
numbers divisible by 2 or not and since
it is not it will remain it will leave a
remainder 1 and we execute this block it
says our print our number is Odd as you
can see here in this video we are going
to learn about the topic called file
handling now file handling is basically
needed because so most of the times when
we are handling large and different
types of data in python or in general we
cannot store everything into a variable
and we will have to use files now there
are two types of files that we are going
to deal with they are binary and text
files so binary files are some of the
files that we most of the files that we
commonly encounter like document files
image Files video files Etc now all
binary files are encoded in a particular
format and they cannot be read by a
normal text editor and we would be
needing certain specific softwares for
specific files text files on the other
hand do not have any specific encoding
and they can be opened in the normal
text editor itself and they are like XML
CSS HTML files and so on now there are
four main operations that we can do 2 on
Pi in Python on files they are open read
write and close
um there are certain other operations as
well though like rename delete so some
of the most basic operation that we can
do is obviously creating and opening a
file and the syntax is as you can see
here where we store where we use the
open command and we give a file name and
we give a mode and we store that in a
particular variable now a mode is uh
basically telling python how to handle
this opening so we can have a read-only
mode which is done by this letter r a
write-only mode which is done by letter
W and for there are a bunch of other
modes such as read or write mode which
is done by R plus and we're going to see
them as we encounter them now the it is
important to note that what I just
mentioned is for text files if we are
going to do for binary files we are
going to do this file handling then we
would be using the letter B in front of
whatever we were using in the case of
text files so if we were doing a
read-only mode for opening a binary file
um we would be using RV and if we were
doing read and write mode a read or
write only mode for a binary file we
would be using RB plus so basically just
adding the b in the case of binary files
let's look at a basic example when we
want to open a particular file we are
going to open like in this example I'm
going to open some file called
firehandling.txt in a read and write
mode read or write mode and I'm going to
store it in fo so this is as simple as
it gets similarly if I wanted to do it
for the binary file since I'm using a
binary file I will use the letter B as
well in the mode and that's how you do
it here now let's look at different ways
in which we can read from a file and
there are three commands that we can use
we can use the read command followed by
optional number of characters you can
use the read line command followed by an
option number of characters and the read
lines command so this optional number of
characters denoted by n over here
um and basically telling us how many
characters we want to print so let's
look at a simple example of where I'm
going to print something called so I'm
going to take this and I'm going to do a
print on top of this so I have done
first I've opened it and I've stored it
in my file and then I'm going to do a uh
a method or a function called read and
I'm going to say like in this example
just read the whole thing so as you can
see my file that I have opened has all
of these lines this is like the whole
file basically but now what if I wanted
to open only the first five characters
of this file which is basically this
well in that case let's open this once
again now let's do the same read command
except we will give the character number
which is five as you can see it's only
printed five now let's do a print read
command and try to read the whole thing
again and you will notice something very
interesting now when I do the read
command you can see it's kind of picked
up from where we left off you know from
our previous command and that is the
nature of how python handles files so if
I wanted to again take the cursor back
in such an example I will have to open
this again and then I use this read
command once again to get back to where
I started from as you can see here now
another command that we can use is the
read line command so let's uh once again
open this over here and now we're going
to use the read line command and over
here so what readline command is going
to do is going to each time we use this
command it's going to go one by one and
read each particular line from this file
so in first case it will take artificial
intelligence then data science big data
and so on so as you can see if I execute
this it first takes artificial
intelligence now if I did this command
again
it will say data science next time if I
do it it should say big data as you can
see here okay so this is the read line
command now within the redline command
also we can enter uh characters and that
will tell us basically
um that we want these number of
characters from the next line so if I
want the first six characters of the
next line I will say six I've run to six
here and it will give me the first six
characters of this particular line which
is the next line that is to come as you
can see here now another way in which we
can print whatever is there in our file
line by line is by using a for Loop so
again I'm going to open this file I'm
going to store it here now I'm going to
use a for Loop saying that well for a
line in my file and what this does is
basically at each each iteration it's
going to take each line and store it in
this variable that we enter over here
which is called line itself and we're
going to print that at the end of the
loop what we'll have is all of the lines
have been printed one by one and another
thing that we can do right now is um
save we want to read a a particular line
see I wanted you to read the fifth line
of my file I can use this technique
where um I just say okay I'm going to
store 5 in this variable called line
number and I have this another variable
called current line which I'm going to
initialize with one and I'm gonna any
I'm gonna what I'm going to do is I'm
going to do the same Loop where I'm
going to say four line in my line but
I'm gonna add a condition saying that
only if current line when it's equal to
line number am I going to print the line
and then I'm going to break out of this
whole thing and at the end of each Loop
I'm going to say current line is going
to be incremented by 1 until basically
these two variables are equal so when I
do this I get my result which is uh
machine learning which is the fifth line
of um my which is the fifth line of or
whatever file I had now we're gonna move
on to the topic of image file handling
so we we saw how we handled and we we
saw certain operations around text files
and text files are obviously something
that we're going to use a lot but we are
also going to be using files such as
images a lot and let's look at certain
examples and certain use cases around
image file handling so my first step is
going to be importing a bunch of modules
and packages now the details of these
modules and these packages are not
important as of right now because they
will be covered in a future video but
just keep a note of some of these
packages such as um let's say numpy and
image the image package so once I've
done this let's move on to my example so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
store certain file locations in two
variables so it's basically two strings
I've attached the uh this prefix R to
say that this is a read-only uh sort of
a prefix so the next topic that we're
going to be handling is image file
handling now we have already seen many
examples pertaining to text files so
text files are obviously something that
we're going to be using a lot but image
file handling is something very
important as well and we're going to see
certain operations that we can do around
image file handling so starting off I'm
going to import a bunch of packages and
modules uh what these packages exactly
are and what these modules exactly are
are right now not of that important of
not are not that important to you right
now but it's something that will be
covered in a future or in future videos
uh it's important to just keep note of
what these are such as numpy and image
so once I've done that what I'm going to
store is I'm going to store two
particular file locations into variables
location one and location two and I've
prefixed them with r just to say that
these are raw strings so once I've done
that I'm going to use the image from the
image package I'm going to say open and
I'm going to say open from this
particular location in this particular
location and I'm going to store these
image images in im1 and im2 over here
very similar to a normal text file file
opening now once we have done this we
can access certain properties of this
image using say format which tells us
the format of the file it attributes the
it identifies the source of an image and
if the image will not write from a file
it is set to none we can also see the
size of the file using the size
attribute and we can see the mode which
basically defines the number and names
of the bands in the image and also
contains a pixel type and depth certain
common modes are like L for luminescence
RGB for true color images and CMYK for
pre-press images so let's look at them
so when I access this you can see my
first file is of jpeg of this size and
an RGB format image and my second image
is another jpeg slightly bigger image
and again RGB now we can also of course
display these images and to do that we
can use the PLT again PLT is the is
supposed to stand for matplotlib DOT Pi
plot it's a particular for a particular
package that again you don't need to
know the details of right now but this
is how we would do this so I'm going to
use a bunch of commands and methods such
as figure and subplot and then I am sure
so once I have done this as you can see
both of my images with this being im1
this being im2 have been produced on the
screen as you can see I can also use
display this display function followed
by the name of the file and this will
simply display my image as you can see
here now I can obviously save a
particular image using the save function
which is as simple as just doing this so
I'm going to save the image as I am
underscore save.jpg over here now if I
wanted to crop an image I can do that as
well so I initially I stored the
dimensions that I want cropped in the
form of a tuple as you can see here and
I'm going to pass that Tuple to the crop
function and I'm going to apply that on
top of im1 and I'm going to store that
to region once I've done that as you can
see so basically what I've done is I've
cropped this image based on whatever
I've passed here and I've stored it into
region and now if I wanted to see what
was um actually in that crop I can just
do the IM show function and I'm going to
pass the particular cropped image which
is denoted by region as you can see here
and you can see my cropped image is
basically a certain a left portion of
this whole image has been cropped out
and I have produced it over here now I
can also use the copy function using
it's a simple basically copy basically
you use the copy function and it copies
an image onto another variable that you
have assigned and when I use the IM show
function I am going to show you the
copied image which is basically the same
now we can do the transpose operation as
well so let's see some of the let's see
what we have done here so in this
transpose opposite operation so in this
basically I've done a bunch of
operations such as rotating by 90
degrees rotating by 180 rotating by 7
270 and finally once I've done with all
of these multiple operations I am going
to show you the final output which is
basically a certain transposed image
like this which is basically the result
of whatever I have done before this so
this is it for this video on file
handling uh I have shown you two
slightly more comprehensive examples on
text files and even certain examples on
image files however we can use file
handling in different libraries
pertaining to file handling for audio
files and even for like stuff like PDF
files and this is like this is just only
the beginning and I'm sure you will
encounter a lot of different use cases
different examples as you continue
learning
um Python Programming this video is
going to be the first of a part of a
series on object oriented programming so
to start off with let's try to
understand and get an introduction into
what is object oriented programming well
as the name suggests object oriented
programming is about creating objects an
object is a group of interrelated
variables and functions variables can be
referred to as the properties of the
object whereas the functions can be
referred to as the behavior of an object
so if we were to treat say for example a
car as an object its properties would be
its color its model its price and its
brand whereas Its Behavior or functions
for that matter would be like
accelerating gear change braking
similarly if I give you an example of a
dog as an object we could consider the
properties of the dog as its weight or
its name its breed its color whereas its
functions could be say barking playing
eating walking Etc objects provide a
better and a clear structure for a
program now let's move on to what is a
class and an instance now a class is
like a blueprint or a template of
certain functions and entities whereas
an instance is a particular realization
of a class classes are used to create
user-defined data structures and Define
certain functions called Methods within
the class whereas instances are
realizations of these classes and when
we are speaking of classes and instances
classes don't contain any real data they
are just merely templates instances on
the other hand contain real data to
think of an example of the difference
between a class and an instance think of
a class like a empty form or a
questionnaire now an empty form of a
questionnaire does not have any
information but it does have a template
to it it tells you to fill in certain
information and based on who is filling
in the information that information or
the data on a particular form will be
different so an instance is like a
filled out form with its own a unique
set of information that is one way of
treating or understanding what is a
class and in instance now for our first
example on classes I will be taking you
through a class where I've defined based
on the circle object so this class is
going to define basically information
about your general circles such as this
radius and its area so let's go through
it now obviously to define a class we
need a keyword well in the case of
classes we use the class keyword
followed by a name for that class so in
this case my name is circle now after
the colon every every information that
is part of the class has to be obviously
indented as is typical for python now
you can see over here A bunch of Dev
keywords followed by something that you
might not be familiar with and I will
try to get you through this so if you
see here you have a def keyword followed
by init and this init is prefixed by a
double underscore and it's suffix by
double underscore and you can see the
same thing for Str and repr well this
double underscore is called it under and
any method these are of course methods
this is a method this is a method this
is a method this is a method now any
method that is prefixed and suffixed by
double underscores are called Dunder
methods these Dunder methods are or can
be thought of like predefined or
built-in methods for any class that you
define so these we have like three
Dunder methods over here and we have one
user defined method that we will get to
so this first method that you see here
is the init method or the initialization
method and this is invoked or called
whenever we create an instance of this
class Circle and what we do here is
basically we pass when we create this
instant Circle we are what what happens
is that we are we get an option to pass
an a value for a what what is this uh
keyword or variable radius so if I pass
so you will see me later on creating an
instance where I will be passing a value
and that value is basically stored as
the radius and by default the radius
that will be passed whenever we we
create an instance for this class is one
the Str method is basically used to
return a descriptive string for the the
instance of class our API is not
something that you have to bother with
right now and now get area is something
that you should follow because if you
see here I have not used any double
underscores so this is a user user
defined method user defined methods are
some methods that we Define and these
are like tasks that we Define on our own
so in my user defined method called get
area I will be returning the area of
this circle based on the radius that I
passed to it now if you notice here
before every in every method I have this
self keyword before any other attribute
so like this has self this has self even
the get area herself now what this means
self is like an optional keyword that is
used to improve readability of a program
first of all and it's also the function
of the self keyword is basically really
telling python that well any of the
methods that we are invoking in this
class or the instance of this class has
to refer to attributes and variables
within that instance of that class so if
I'm going to use get area function I am
going to get values and attribute values
and variable values based on only the
current instance of that particular
class self is obviously optional we
don't really need it but basically the
first attribute of any method is is
basically the is basically what the
method is is the instance that the
method is invoked upon so if I say self
I am telling this particular function
that okay all the value that you're
going to get for performing whatever
task you want is going to be found in
that particular instance where you have
been invoked itself now don't worry if
all this is very confusing if this might
be in the beginning but just try to
understand that this is some something
that we do for good practice and you
understand when when to yourself or when
not to yourself as you learn about
objective oriented programming so if you
see here my get a job function is
supposed to return the value radius
times radius F dot radius is basically
telling um whatever value I've passed
for radius for that particular instance
you can read this as radius times radius
times pi as well so obviously this is pi
R square which is the area of a
particular circle now let me show you an
example where I am going to perform some
of these functions so if you see this
first line I have created an instance of
the class Circle where I've passed 2.1
for the radius of the circle so now the
value of the variable radius in this
particular instance is going to be
stored as 2.1 and this particular
instance is going to be stored in the
variable C1 now the print C1 function
invokes the Str self-defined or
predefined function now if you remember
Str was it's basically used to return a
particular string that describes like
what the class will do and this is
something that we Define on our own in
our example Str will return the string
saying this is a circle with radius of
and then it will return the radius that
we passed so in this case it should say
this is the circle of radius 2.1 as you
can see over here so if I execute this
you can notice this line This is a
circle with radius 2.1 and this is
invoked by the print function the print
basically invokes the dunder Str
function which does all of this now in
the next line we say print C1 dot get
area so this is going to print the value
of the or what what gets returned when
we invoke the method get area for this
particular instance C1 so obviously in
this particular instance our radius is
2.1 so the get area function should do
pi times 2.1 square and the value is as
you can see here is some 13.85 so that
is the area that we got now if we want
to print a particular radius um we just
say print C1 dot radius so this will
print the value of what is what is
stored in radius for the particular
instance C1 now you might notice me
using a DOT whenever it comes to
defining a certain function or a keyword
well any time that we want to invoke or
use a method of a particular class we
have to use the dot keyword so we use
the instance name C1 dot followed by
whatever method that we want to use so
if we want to use the get area function
we say C1 dot get area if you want to
find out what is there in the radius uh
key radius variable of a particular
instance we say C1 dot radius now before
we move on let's talk about some of the
naming conventions class names are
initial capitalized so if our class name
is for example
um like for example if it's camel case
well each word that is part of this
class has its first letter capitalized
variables and Method names add in lower
class so if my class was called Circle
we say class class circle with C being
in capital now moving on let's talk
about how we initialize or Define
instance variables now instance
variables are declared within the init
method if you remember from the earlier
example of circle init is a Dunder
method it's followed and it's preceded
by double underscore as you can see here
now if you see in this particular case I
have again used the self keyword and as
I mentioned earlier the self keyword is
the first parameter of all member
methods
um and it this basically binds that
particular method to the particular
instance itself during invocation so
every time a new Circle object is
created the dot init function sets the
initial state of the object by assigning
the values of the object's properties so
if the init function basically
initializes each and every new instance
of um whatever of our class so we can
give in it any number of parameters but
the first parameter must always be a
variable called self now when a new
class instance is created the insta
instances automatically passed to the
self parameter in init so that new
attributes can be defined on the object
inside the init method the self.radius
basically means that we want the value
of radius based on the current instance
itself so as you can see radius defines
an instance variable radius and we're
going to use the particular instance and
its value of 4 radius in our variable
radius now instance uh the inner I mean
the init function is not a Constructor
but it is an initializer to create
instance variables the init function
also will never return a value and it is
optional and can be omitted if there are
no instance variables now let's move on
to class variables so now as we
mentioned earlier all the attributes
that are created inside the init
function are instance specific
attributes and the instance attributes
are obviously specific to a particular
instance of the class for example all
dog objects now if we have a class
called dog then all dog objects have a
name and age but the values for the name
and age will vary depending on which dog
we are talking talking about or
basically which instance of the dog are
we talking about now class attributes
are attributes that have the same value
for all class instances and we define a
class attribute by assigning a value
value to a variable outside of the init
function so if you look at this example
over here we have created another class
called Circle and we have this
initializer again where we have class
specific variable called radius which
whose value will change depending on
whatever we pass for that particular
instance however if you look before the
initial the init init function or the
initializer function if you see here we
have another variable called shape
object which stores the string Circle
and this variable is going to be the
same and constant for every instance of
the class Circle and unlike the variable
radius we will not have different values
depending on a particular instance okay
now let's talk talk about instantiating
an object and let's see what happens
when we create two different instances
of the same class so as you can see here
I've created an instance C1 for class
Circle and I'm going to check its ID
well if you see the ID is something like
this now if I create it in other
instance over here called C2 and if I
check its ID well it's something
different now so if you see each
instance basically has a different
memory location in our memory and each
instance is this is how each instance is
different each time we create it and
they are created in different memory
locations finally before we conclude
this topic on the introduction into oop
let's talk about class methods instance
methods and static methods now class
methods are usually declared are
actually declared with the at class
method operator or decorator as you can
see here it accepts a class as its first
argument so in this case I am going to
say I'm going to define a class called
my class I'm gonna use this at class
method decorator say that whatever
follows here is going to be a class
method and I've defined a class method
called hello that takes in a that uses
against self and a name attribute so
what this does is it prints
um whatever I have passed to it in the
form of hello from self.name now what
this this is going to do is basically
it's going to give out a string saying
hello from name of us is called the
string name my class with a comma and
then whatever we passed initially which
was Rakesh next is then instance methods
and these are the most common types of
methods these are invoked by an instance
object so we have to create an instance
to actually use an instance method and
it takes the instance or the keyword
itself as its first argument so if I say
class dot class if I define a class my
class in this example and I'm going to
Define another function called hello as
you can see I have not used any
decorator like at class method so this
is going to be an instance method and
it's going to be invoked by the
particular instance so in this case it's
going to print hello from and it's going
to basically say the name of the class
again so I create my instance called my
instance one and it's an instance of
this class and then I'm gonna invoke the
instance method by using this dot dot
operator and the instance name and the
result will be basically this string
over here as you can see now finally we
have another type of method called the
static method which is declared using
the add static method decorator so a
static method does not know its class
and it's just attached to the class for
convenience it does not depend on the
state of the object and could be from a
separate function of a module a static
method can be invoked via a class object
or an instance object so if you look at
this example over here I have defined a
static method I've defined hello and it
basically says print hello world so it's
going to basically just print this so if
you can see here I created my instance
and I'm going to say dot hello it should
basically pre-print print hello world
that's all in this video we will
continue know that discussion on oop
with inheritance inheritance is used to
describe the relationship between two
classes wherein one class takes the
methods and properties from another
class in this relationship we have
something called the base class or the
parent class from which we will derive
all our sum of the properties and
methods and the class which actually
derives these properties and methods is
known as the derived class so you can
think of the derived class as a
specialized version of a base class to
explain what inheritance is in a basic
way I will show you an example where I'm
creating a cylinder class which is going
to be a subclass of the circle class
that you might have encountered in the
earlier video on op so what we're going
to do is create a cylinder class that is
a subclassive circle where we're going
to get the attributes radius and get
area from Circle class and we're going
to add the attributes height and get
volume to the cylinder so right off the
start you can see we have our class
Circle that you might have seen in the
earlier video so this class Circle has
the familiar initialization where we are
supposed to enter a value for a radius
that gets stored in self dot radius now
we also have a description string which
basically is a Dunder method that
returns a string when we invoke the
print command on a particular instance
and we have the get area method as well
now if we move on to the cylinder class
you can see that I'm defining this class
with the class keyword with the cylinder
name but you can see that I have added a
parenthesis and within it I have
mentioned the name of the superclass
that I want the cylinder class to be a
subclass of so this is how we actually
Define a subclass in the most basic way
you enter the name that you want and you
enter the name of the super class that
you want the subclass to be if a
subclass of in parentheses right after
the name now next if you move on to the
dunder initialization
um the initialization is very familiar
familiar except now we have another
attribute for height which has a default
default value of 1 just like the radius
so this basically means that we have an
option of entering two different
attributes for our cylinder instances
now if you see here there's a line which
says super dot in it now this is like
um this is a command which we use to
invoke the super classes initializer so
anytime we create an instance for
cylinder we also want an initialization
for the circle method as well as a part
of our cylinder instance next you can
see that much like how we store itself I
mean the radius attribute in self.radius
we're also storing the height attribute
in self dot height now even this
cylinder class has an Str method to
return a particular string if we use
this print function and finally we get
on to a more a new method that we have
defined only for the cylinder class
called get volume now if you see the get
volume it returns as basically the
volume of the cylinder that is being
described in the particular instance for
which we enter the height and the radius
so if you can see here what we've
basically added extra is an a height
attribute and another method called get
volume and the other parts of the circle
super class such as radius and get area
are also going to be a part of cylinder
even though you do not explicitly see
them anywhere here and we will see how
in uh in the form of an example that's
coming up so let me just execute these
classes now that that's done I'm going
to create an instance for cylinder I'm
going to store it in cy1 and I'm going
to pass 1.1 for the radius and 2.2 for
the height and once that is done let's
just print to invoke the HDR method and
as you can see the Str method basically
tells us the information that is a
cylinder with radius 1.1 and height 2.2
so now let's print what is the value we
get when we use the get area method now
it's important to note get area was not
explicitly defined in the cylinder
subclass but it's a method that is a
part of the circle super class and we
can see that we can actually access
methods that are of the superclass
simply by accessing any other method so
if you use the dot get area you can see
that we get a value for the area of the
cylinder so this basic this area is
basically the area of the circle face of
the cylinder uh the top or the Bottom
now let's use now let's invoke uh the
subclass specific method which is the
get volume method in a similar manner as
you can see just by doing invoking this
method we get the volume as well now if
we want to see what is the radius and
the height we can just do a simple print
statement followed by cy1 dot radius C1
dot height and it gives us both of these
values as you can see here now over here
what I'm going to do is create another
instance of cylinder but I'm not going
to pass anything for radius or height so
basically it's going to take the default
values for radiation height which was 1
and 1 respectively so once I print
um this is this statement is basically
going to print the SDR method or
whatever we stored in the Str which is
basically the description of the object
followed by what is its radius and
height this method will give us the area
and this method will give us the volume
so once I execute this as you can see
here this is what we get and this is
what we expect as well so now in this
example what I'm going to show you is uh
now I'm going to go back and I am going
to create another instance for circle
now this is the superclass of course and
I'm gonna give it and since the
superclass has only one option uh one
attribute that we can enter which is for
the radius so I pass 3.3 and I'm going
to print what what happens when I just
print uh this instance it's going to
basically give us whatever was a part of
the HDR method after that I'm going to
print is instance this is basically a
check on whether C1 is an instance of
this class Circle and X I'm going to
check if C1 is an instance of its
subclass cylinder now when I execute
this you can see that well this is what
we uh this is the Str method that gets
printed but if you see here um you can
see that it says C1 is indeed a an
instance of circle when it says true
over here but when we look at the next
line is C1 an instance of cylinder it
says false and this is obviously because
um a superclass object is never an
instance of a subclass object whereas
whereas vice versa it would be true now
in the next part of this video what
we're going to do is look at the
different types of inheritances in
Python so there are basically five types
of inheritance in Python there is the
single inheritance there's multiple
inheritance multi-level inheritance
hierarchical hierarchical and Hybrid
inheritance so we will go one by one and
see each of these examples starting off
we have the single inheritance this is
simply where we have one Base Class and
one derived class from That Base Class
so this is a simple single inheritance
and in this example you can see I have a
class called country where I have a
method that I have defined called show
country which is basically going to say
print this is India it's basically going
to print this every time we invoke this
show country method then we have a class
called state which derives from the
super classical country where we have a
method called show state which is going
to say print this is state every time so
you can see I created an instance of the
class State and I'm through that
instance I can access the super class
and the subclass methods over here next
we have the multi-level uh sorry
multiple inheritance and this is when a
derived class contains more than one
Base Class so let's look at an example
to understand this so if you can see
here I have a class called student with
the two methods defined called method
one and Method two in method one we can
pass two attributes Sno or I think is
this this is supposed to be like an ID I
guess like SN number and we have S name
so this is basically two attributes we
can pass that are probably descriptors
for a student and in the next method you
have basically two print statements
which Says student number and then they
will print the student number and it
will also print the student name next we
have a class called marks this is also
so um so these these two classes are
basically what our super classes are
going to be and we're going to derive a
third class from these two so this
second class is a class called Marx and
we have two uh methods again one method
is called set marks which has
um the option of putting in two
attributes M1 and M2 both are
representative of the two marks and we
store them in self dot Mark 1 self.mr2
the second method is put merch which is
going to print the marks namely mark one
and then it's going to tell us how much
marks are there in the first subject for
example and another print statement
doing the same thing for the second
subject of Mark two finally we have a
third class called a result which
derives from two classes marks and
student as you can see here in my
parenthesis I've passed in marks and
student both are super classes and our
class result is going to derive from
both of them this is an example of
multiple inheritance and within this
class result I have two methods specific
to this derived class called calc
wherein I'm going to basically calculate
the two the total marks of
the the total marks which is basically
the addition of Mark 1 plus Mark II and
I'm then I'm going to have another
method called put total which is going
to print me what is the total so if you
can see here I have created an instance
of this derived class called a result I
am storing it in R then I'm going to
access method one which is obviously a
method from the first superclass called
student and I'm going to store okay so
this is name is I guess lucky and he has
60 marks uh secondly then I'm going to
do our set marks which is the method
from the second Super class which is
going to set the marks uh respectively
so you have lucky student and his ID is
60 and he has got 50 and 60 marks
respectively in say the first two
subjects and finally I'm going to access
the derived class method called calc so
this is going to do the sum finally I'm
going to also do our method two which is
I'm going to print our student number
and his student name next we're going to
have put much which is going to tell us
the what are the individual marks for
Mark 1 and Mark 2 and then finally we're
going to print the total marks with the
put total so once I execute this you can
see here it says student number 60
student name lucky Marks One is 50 as I
had written here marks 260 as I passed
here and then total is 110 which is
basically 50 plus 60. now the next type
of inheritance is called multi-level
inheritance now multi-level inheritance
can be assumed as where you take a super
class let's call it a and you derive a
Class B from that class A now what if we
derived a Class C from B and we kept
doing this so until say at class E now
each of these steps is in its own an
inheritance but this whole relationship
can be described as a multi-level
inheritance so let's take an example
again so after this this time I've
defined a class called student where I
have defined two methods called set stud
and put stud or you can call it set
student and put student in my first
method I have two options of adding two
attributes again this is the story
number this is the student name in my
second method I am going to print what
is the student number and what is the
student name finally uh so sorry next we
have another class called marks which
derives from the first class called
student this has two methods called set
marks where I'm going to again get the
option of adding two integers for M1 and
M2 which is going to represent Mark 1
and Mark 2 and finally I have put marks
the method which is going to print Mark
1 and Mark 2.
um finally I have another class called
result and this if you see this derives
from marks now if you see this
relationship you'll notice result
derives from marks whereas marks itself
derives from student and this is an
example of multi-level hierarchy and
even as a part of this third class we
have its own methods called calc and put
total calc will calculate the total as
we had seen earlier and prayer total
will basically print the total and we're
going to do a a similar operation we're
going to create an instance of this
third class result and store it in R
then we're going to do basically we're
going to set the student details uh his
uh student number and his name we're
going to give him his marks 50 and 60.
we're going to calculate what are the
total we're going to say okay now put
the details of what is the student's
number and name we're going to also
store enter I mean display his marks my
Quantum Mark 2 and finally we're going
to display the total marks so let's
execute this and if you see it's
basically the similar operation that we
did earlier but the only difference is
in the earlier example our uh our third
class result was derived from Marx and
student together so this was an example
of multiple inheritance whereas in this
example the result class derives from
marks and marks itself derives from
students so this is an example of
multi-level inheritance finally we have
um sorry not finally penultimately we
have as our fourth example of
inheritance called hierarchical
inheritance apart in my Ms presentation
it's hierarchical inheritance so in this
case a base class basically will contain
more than one derived class so let's see
a look at an example of what we mean
here so I have a class called one where
I have defined a method called display
where what I'm going to do is I'm going
to store set.x is equal to 1000 and self
dot Y is equal to 2000 then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to print a
statement saying this is the method in
class 1 and I'm going to say after that
I'm going to print another statement
saying value of x is a self.x which is
going to be 1000 uh then I'm going to
have another print statement saying
value of y is self.y which is going to
be 2000. finally uh I mean next I have
another class called 2 this this is
going to derive from class 1 as you can
see here and in this class 2 I have
defined another method called add and in
this method add what I'm going to do is
I'm going to first print a statement
saying this is the method in class 2 and
then I'm going to actually print the
result of X Plus Y which is 1000 plus
two thousand finally I have another
class called three and this is also
deriving from one so if you notice we
have one parent class called one and
from this one uh parent class we're
going to derive two different subclasses
called two and three so this is an
example of hierarchical inheritance now
in this uh class three what I've done is
I've defined a multiplication method
what I'm going to do is print first of
all I'm going to print this when I
invoke this method that this is the
method in class three finally I'm going
to say uh I'm going to print the result
of x times Y which is 1000 times 2000 so
if you see I am going to create an
instance of 2 and I am going to create
an instance of three and I'm going to
store them in T1 and T2 now since uh T2
I mean T1 is an instance of 2 so I can
access its methods add and I can access
this methods display so I'm going to use
d1.display and even into T2 I mean since
it's a class uh it's an instance of
class 3 and this also derives from class
1 I can also access its method display
but now I cannot access add but I can
access multiply so if you see here I
access add through T1 instance since add
is a part of Class 2 whereas multiply is
a uh is a method in class three so I
access it in its respective instance
which is D2 so if you see here now once
I execute this what you will get is
basically
um the results so first of all it will
basically display the method from class
1 which is the display method it will
display the values of X and Y and since
I've done this twice from two different
instances it will basically show a
repetition over here finally I've done
the addition and since this is a method
in class 2 it is going to say as much
that is the method in class 2 and then
it's going to say X Plus Y is 3000 and
now multiply is a method in the third
class so it's going to say this is a
method in class 3 and it's going to tell
me what is the multiplication result
finally we have what is called Hybrid
inheritance and this is a combination of
multiple plus multi-level inheritance
that you saw earlier so let's again
understand this through this example so
we have a class called student where we
have have a method called set student
again two attributes we can pass here
for student number and student name next
we have a another method part of the
class student called put student so this
will print us the student number and
student name next we have a class called
marks and this marks inherits from
student so we have a method in class
marks called set marks where we can pass
two attributes for Mach 1 and Mark 2
respectively and as we have seen earlier
we also have a put marks which will
display the marks for Marks One and
marks two we have a class called
practical this practical is basically a
another Super class if you see here
since this does not derive from anything
it is super class on its own and what it
does is it it has two methods get
practical and we can pass an attribute
for P1 here and we store that in self.p1
and then we have an attribute for uh put
practical which will print us the
Practical marks whatever we passed for
this attribute in P1 finally if you see
we have a class called result now in
this result we have we are going to
derive from marks and practical but if
you notice here marks itself is a
subclass of student so this is an
example of multi-level inheritance
whereas since result derived from marks
and practical both it is also an example
of multiple inheritance so if you see
notice here this is an example of
multiple and multiple level inheritance
which is basically what we call Hybrid
inheritance and as we had seen earlier
this result class will have a calc
method to do a total of the marks in
this case Mach 1 plus Mark 2 plus the
Practical Mark P1 and we have a put
total method which is basically going to
print us the total so now we are going
to create an instance of this result and
through this instance of result we're
going to first invoke the parent class
method called set student which is the
the second level parent basically the
student the student class set student
method so we're going to set student
here we're going to say 60 is a student
ID and name is Ash then we have set
marks which is again the the second
level parent which is a student class
where we set the marks finally we access
this get practical now if you notice get
practical is part of the Practical uh
super class so in this we store the
third subject or the the Practical marks
100 then we calculate the total and we
put uh first the student details then we
put the individual marks then we put the
Practical marks and finally we enter
what is the total so let's execute this
and if you notice you will see here
student number 60 student name and now
the basically whatever details we wanted
um is shown over here in this video we
will continue our discussion on object
oriented programming with the topic of
polymorphism now the term polymorphism
in oop refers the ability of an object
to adapt the code to the type of data it
is processing polymorphism is one of the
key concepts of python and it is also a
built-in feature of python an example to
get us started on polymorphism would be
how we use the plus operator we use the
plus operator not only for arithmetic
additions but we also use the plus
operator for stuff like string
concatenations or joining two lists
together this example where we're able
to use the plus operator for different
different operations is an example of
polymorphism to show you what I mean I
have basically done a simple addition
operation here where I'm adding two
variables number one and number two when
I do it on integers it basically adds
one plus two now when I use it on two
strings str1 and str2 which contains
Python and programming to separate uh
strings and when I use the plus operator
on these you can see what it does here
it forms one string containing both of
these individual strings so this is
basically the plus operator showing
polymorphism and is one of the simplest
occurrences and yet most common
occurrences of polymorphism in Python
another example of polymorphism would be
through the lens function the lens
function in Python is some something
that we use a lot and over multiple data
types depending on the data type that we
use the length function for we get a
different value or a different sort of
information from the length function now
if you see here from this diagram when
we use the length function on a string
it gives us the length of the string
when we use the length function on a
list it gives us the number of items
whereas if we use the length function on
a dictionary it gives us the number of
keys so this is well another example of
how we have polymorphism in a function
now what we are going to do is look at
the different techniques through which
we can enable polymorphisms in our code
our first example that we are going to
look at is through method overloading
now method overloading in its
traditional sense where we can have a
method with the same name more than one
method with the same name in the same
class is not exactly possible in Python
so if we have multiple methods with the
same name in a class in Python which may
differ in in types and number of
argument events are not allowed and not
supported in Python in fact if we did
something like this where we created a
method with a different uh with
different say types and number and
arguments but having the same name in
the same class then what python will do
is it will only recognize the the last
defined method and it will not recognize
any of the earlier methods with the same
name but we can simulate polymorphism
through method over overloading by using
default arguments in a method now for
example what I'm going to show you here
is an example where I have a method
called sum Now by default it has three
attributes that you can pass through
this method a does not have a default
value B does not have a default value
but if you notice C has a default value
of 0. so this is a simple example where
I'm going to show you that the sum
method is going to be used in two
different cases in one case we are going
to Simply add two digits I mean two
numbers and in another case we are going
to use the sum method to add three
different numbers so we have this class
overload demo within it a method sum and
I have three attributes A and B are uh I
have are supposed to be given by the
user since they don't have a since they
do not have any default values whereas C
has a default value of 0. so if you see
here in my first case I have I first of
all created in an instance called over
uh an instance called OD for the class
overload demo and I have what I'm going
to do is I'm going to store the value of
the sum of 7 and 8 in the variable sum
now if you see here I have not passed a
third argument so what this method is
going to do is it's going to take the
value of C as 0 by default so it's
basically going to do 7 plus 8 and it's
going to give us the sum for 7 plus 8
and in the next instance I'm going to
give three ad arguments seven eight and
nine so now c will be replaced by 9
instead of 0 and then I'm going to get
the sum of 7 8 and 9. so in this this is
a not a very used and are not a very
commonly used thing but it's basically a
method just to show you that we can
actually simulate method overloading in
Python by using default arguments so
I've basically shown you how the same
how the same method sum has been used to
do the addition of two digits and then
in in another instance is doing the
addition of three digits it might look
very similar but you'll basically notice
that by having this third attribute C I
have a default value of 0 I have induced
some form of polymorphism through method
overloading now the next way that we can
induce polymorphism is through
inheritance which is called method
overriding as well now method overriding
gives us the ability to change the way
or the change the implementation of a
method in a child class which is defined
already in one of its super classes now
if there is a method in a super class
the method having the same name and same
number of arguments in a child class uh
then the child class method is going to
override the method in the parent class
so what we do is when a method is called
with the parent class object the method
of the parent class will be executed
whereas if we call the method using the
child class object the method of the
chart class will be executed executed
and it will override the method in the
parent class so the appropriate
overridden method is called uh is called
based on the object type which is an
example of polymorphism so let's look at
an example to understand this so we have
a class called person and we have
defined what we're going to define the
initializer is two attributes which we
have to pass called name and age and
we're going to store them in cell plot
name and self.h now we have a user
defined method called display data where
we are going to print if this display
data has been called through the parent
called person
um if it's going to be called through
the parent class object then we're going
to print in parent class display method
and when we're going to print the name
and age that we have entered now we have
another class called employee which is
is going to be a derived class on person
so it's going to
um so it's also going to have an
initializer and this Constructor will
basically what what this initializer
will have is it will have an uh
Constructor for the superclass where
we're going to do this uh the same
initialization that we do in the super
class but we're also going to store
another attribute called ID in self dot
employee ID and if you see here we also
have another method called display data
which is the same name method from
person but now if you see in display
data I have every I have all the same
almost the same information I'm going to
print the name I'm going to print the
age but if you see the first statement
I'm going to say if I'm going to call
this method from the employee object
then I'm going to say in child class
display data method instead of in parent
class display data method to say that
basically I'm invoking this method from
the child class object and I'm also
going to print on top of the whatever
I'm printing before I'm also going to
print the employee ID so if you see here
I have created an object called person
which is an object of the class person
with the information of name John and
age 40. and then I'm going to display
this now next I'm going to create an
object called amp which is the child
class employee object which is going to
now have the same information of John
for the name and age 40 but now is going
to have an employee ID then I'm going to
store this uh in amp and I'm going to
display the data for this child class
object and we will see the difference in
how the display data is differing from
the earlier earlier case so when I
execute this you see the in the first
case it says in parent class display
data method so this display data has
been called through the parent class
object and I'm only going to show the
information of name and age whereas when
I invoke this method from the employee
class object it's going to say it's
going to specifically say that it's a in
child class display method and then I'm
going to say the name is and also the
employee ID over here so this is the
difference between how displayed data
has been used in its parent and its
child class and this is basically the
example of method overriding now our
next example of polymorphism is going to
be through operator overloading and
operator overloading is the ability to
overload the operator to provide extra
functionality in additional to its real
or core operation and operator
overloading is also an example of
polymorphism as the same operator can
perform different actions the earlier
example of where we use the plus
operator for different operations is an
example of operator overloading
polymorphism now when um when when this
operator overloading required well
anytime you want an operator to perform
a different function for you in your
custom objects you would basically do
operator overloading now an example of
this would be what I'm going to show you
below so if you see this class called
point it has an initializer where I'm
going to store two attributes X and Y in
sub.x and Y and incept.x InStep dot y
now I'm going to create one object
called P1 where I'm going to create
point uh one and two so you can think of
this object as basically like a
coordinate x coordinate one y coordinate
two this is one point and another Point
called uh x coordinate three x one and
four I'm gonna call that P2 now I want
to print P1 plus P2 all right now if I
try to execute this you will notice an
error it says unsupported operand types
for plus point and point this basically
means that plus does not know what to do
when it's given an object of this type
it has no idea what to do whereas what
we wanted to do is add the the the x
coordinate from this point and the x
coordinate from this point so we wanted
to do one plus three and we also wanted
to do this y coordinate plus this y
coordinate or 2 plus 4 and then we want
to print basically like something like 4
comma 6 or the addition of the two
points uh or the the vector addition of
these two points so this is what we want
this plus operator to do but the python
does not have any inbuilt feature for
the plus operator and we are going to
have to basically do some Opera greater
overloading to create a polymorphism on
this so let's see how we can do that so
to do that first of all we have to
understand that all operators in Python
have internally defined methods to
provide functionality for these
operators the operator or the special
method to provide functionality for the
plus operator in Python is the add
method and whenever the plus operator is
used we are basically internal link
internally invoking the add method so
these these sort of internal methods
that provide functionality for The
Operators are part of a big a bigger
class of methods known as magic methods
and these magic methods are
automatically invoked whenever it's
corresponding operators are used so we
want to change the or the operation for
the plus operator in this example we are
going to have to use the the add method
in this case and since it's a magic
method magic methods are also are
basically what we saw earlier in the in
the form of Dunder methods so magic
methods are going to be invoked using a
double under score a prefixed and suffix
to it so similarly to how we defined an
init of an init method or an HDR method
we are going to also invoke the add
method using the same double underscore
before and after its name so now let's
see how we're going to do this so if you
see this class I have now my class point
and I have the same initializer when I'm
going to store X and Y now I am going to
Define on uh these this add magic method
I am going to override the the normal
functionality of plus and I'm going to
give it a very specific function where
I'm going to say
um for two two different objects you're
going to add its uh the first part the
first part or its so called x coordinate
with the other x coordinate and it the y
coordinate with the other y coordinate
and you need to return return this to me
in the form of a similar object so now
when I pass 1 and 2 and 3 and 4 it
should return me 4 and 6 as you can see
here I have basically done what I wanted
to do by operator overloading I have
changed or I have over loaded this add
this plus operator using this add magic
method and I have created a new
functionality for this add function for
these two points one and two three and
four now I'm able to add one comma 2 3
comma 4 in the way I want it to so now
that you saw how we did our operator
overloading I'm just going to show you a
list of similar magic methods for
different operators that we are familiar
with so the plus operator already we've
seen has the add method then we have the
minus operator with the sub method and
similarly we have for all of these
operations such as multiplication
division we have its respective magic
methods these magic methods are again
prefixed with two underscores and suffix
with two underscores and they are
basically they are also called uh done
does in Python so this is how we would
do operator overloading in Python for
whatever operator we want similarly we
can do this for like comparison
operators and for unary operators as
well so look at this example now where
I'm going to overload the multiplication
or the as tricks operator so I have
again defined a point I mean a class
called point I'm going to Define an
initializer but I'm going to store some
attribute X in cell dot X now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to overload the
multiplication operator when I'm going
to basically allow the uh this Asterix
operator to multiply two objects uh from
like for example 12 and 5. usually I can
just do a normal 12 times 5 but in this
case my object is slightly different my
12 is being passed through an object of
a class called point and 5 as well in
another uh instance of the same class
now when I want to multiply these class
instances like the the multiplication
operator does not perceive these class
instances to be integer so by default it
would not be able to multiply what we
want to multiply but when we Define or
we overload the multiplication operator
within our class it's now able to
understand what to do um using the
attributes of these classes in its
respective class instances so it's able
to say okay so I want this attribute
from this particular instance V1 12 and
I'm going to multiply it with the
attribute 5 from instance P2 whenever I
say P1 times P2 or P to P1 as takes P2
so when I executed it will give me 12
times 5. similarly I can also do this
for the greater than operator over here
so I have a class called person where
I'm going to Define an initializer where
I'm going to pass name and salary and
store them in sub.name server.s salary
the GT method is basically the greater
than method magic method and it's going
to uh we're going to use this to
overload the greater than operator and
now again using this greater than
operator I am able to basically say
object 1 greater than object 2 and I'm
basically able to check through this and
if object 1 is greater than object 2 it
will basically tell us if it is true or
false or basically whatever like we want
to know so but this is the the print
statement will check for object1.name
and it will say earns more than
objective.name if in case object that
one is indeed greater than objective so
when I execute this you can see here my
first information says John has is
earning 4500 some units Natasha is
earning 6000 of some units so it will
say uh John earns more than Natasha well
it's false because object one is not
greater than object two so uh since 4500
is not actually greater than 6000 and
this is the check that I'm doing by
overloading the GT operator over here
where I'm so where I'm returning the
Boolean value of uh what is greater
self. salary or other dot salary self
being the first object in any comparison
so in the if I'm basically any
comparison if I'm doing say if I'm doing
5 greater than 5 greater than 6 so what
the GT will do is this will be the self
object and this will be the other object
so this is what I'm doing over here I'm
checking self dot salary with other dot
salary in in the form of these objects
and it's basically the same same way
that we we are able to do five plus five
through these class instance objects
that you saw earlier or 12 times 5 that
you saw earlier so this is all examples
of operator overloading in Python in
this video we will be taking a brief
introduction into what is a function so
a function in Python is a group of
related statements that performs a
specific task or tasks now functions
help break our program into smaller and
modular pieces of code and it's very
good and very convenient to use
functions to make our code organized and
manageable especially as our overall
program grows larger it also helps us to
avoid repetition and makes the code
reusable so let's look at the basic way
of defining a function so this is a
basic function that I am calling Fun
underscore name all right now the rest
of the function or whatever the task is
going to be performed by this function
will be my written over here within
indent of course as a standard when it
comes to python so I'm going to Define
this one something in triple uh double
quotes so don't worry about what this is
right now this is a Docs string don't
worry about what this means and I'll
explain it to you just in a short bit
all right now now the rest of the
statement the rest of it uh will
obviously be what this function will do
let's include a simple print statement
all right let's uh done here and let's
call this so of course now once you've
defined the state function to call the
function you just have to use its name
like this this is how you call a
function so as you can see when I call
this function it should print the
statement hello now let's go let's uh
look at some of the uh like what
happened over here so we've used the
keyword def to define a function we give
it a unique name which makes it which
with which we uniquely identify this
function
um and also once we've done this we
um we can give it we can give this
function a particular header uh it's
called a doc string so what this doc
string is basically something that we
include in triple quotes over here just
after the dev keyword and this is like a
brief we can use this to give a brief
and give brief information into what our
function is doing so we can say this is
this function performs addition this
performs
um subtraction or whatever like some
basic information as to what our
function does so we can use a doc string
for that um of course this is an
optional thing this does not have to be
we don't have to include this as well
all right but for the sake of this let's
just keep it here after that of course
rest of the function uh will contain
whatever tasks we want to do with it and
that will be indented
um finally we can also include a return
keyword and what the return keyword does
is at any point you find the return
keyword in a function you immediately
leave the function you go back to where
this function was called okay so now
let's see
um now there's also one more important
component of defining a function and
that's parameter now if you've noticed
over here within these parentheses I did
not include anything this is like an
empty parenthesis opening and closing
what is if I said a if I included some A
and B over here so what this means is
whenever I call this function I need to
pass two parameters A and B these can be
like strings or numbers or whatever
um but now it becomes almost mandatory
that I pass these two things for my
function to uh to work so let's define a
function where I'm going to add a and b
so instead of this print statement let's
do this I create a variable C and in
that I'm storing a plus b all right and
then I return C so you can use a return
and you can you you can return certain
like variables along with the return
statement so I'm saying not only return
from this function but also given output
or return an output called C which is
the addition of A and B now how do we
use this well now instead of just
calling the function like this I'm going
to add para I'm going to include
parameters so I'm saying Pass 2 and 3 to
function name where 2 will take the
place of a and 3 will take the place of
B all right what will happen happen now
is addition will take place and we will
get return the result so let's see what
happens now as you can see two plus
three and I already got the data the
addition of two plus three and it
returned me five so yeah this was like a
basic uh usage of a function and
parameters so of course uh we can if you
want to know like what a what the doc
string of a particular function does or
says uh you can use this uh particular
you can use this like statement so let's
say for so uh it's very important to
like just keep a note in your uh while
you're going through this or while
you're learning that uh whenever we use
some sort of a function which has double
uh underscore right this is like a
built-in a built-in command provided by
python
um within the python Library itself so
these are like built-in commands to
check certain details so I want to check
what is the doc string and this is how I
do it so let's do print let's print what
is the doc string over here this is a
doc string so this is a basic basically
what I wrote over here I can change this
to this like this does addition for
example all right now this will say this
does addition when I execute this line
so this is the way to check what is a
doc string anyways so now that you have
seen a basic uh basic function two basic
functions that I defined for you and how
we use them what a parameter is let's
look at another concept that we call
scope and lifetime of variables so scope
of variable is the portion of the
program where the variable is recognized
all right now a parameter and a variable
that are defined inside a function are
not visible from outside the function
this is a very key thing so if we Define
something within the function we can
only use it within this function and we
cannot like we cannot use it once the
function has already been executed so as
to speak
um these variables and these parameters
uh have what we call as local scope
since they are only recognized Within in
a particular function now the lifetime
of a variable is the period throughout
which the variable exists in the memory
itself and it's very important to note
that lifetime of variables that are
defined inside a function
um are as long as the function executes
once we return from a function uh
whatever we have defined within it are
destroyed so when we use a function it
will not remember the values of a
variable from a previous iteration of a
function call so let's uh try to
understand this example or this concept
using certain examples so out here I
have defined a function where I am going
to create a variable my underscore VAR
my variable and I am going to store the
value 10 in this and then I'm going to
print so whenever I call this function I
will always create this variable I will
store 10 and I will print the value of
this all right now what I'm going to do
is I'm not only going to create this my
are inside this function I'm also going
to create a variable outside so you see
there now you might be confused as to
okay how is the behavior going to be
because outside the function I have
created my bar with a value 20 but
inside the function I will always Define
my virus 10 okay now I'm going to print
so my first what I'm going to first do
is I'm going to execute this function
that I created initially where I store
the value of 10 in my bar and then I'm
going to pray and print the value of my
wire that was present outside the
function let's see what happens you can
see two different things happening so
when I execute this function it prints
the value inside the function as 10 but
when I print the next line which says
um okay now get the value of my wire it
actually prints a value of 20 and this
is a very key concept because What's
Happening Here is when I initially call
my function within this function it
creates a variable called my wire and it
prints the value as 10. and the moment
my function has been executed it
destroys this variable and and the
variable which contained the value 10 is
of course now destroyed and all we have
is the my wire that contains 20 from the
outside and when we print that we get
the suspective value as 20. so you can
also think of it like this the my wire
that is present inside this function is
different to the my word that we create
outside so the scope of the my bar
within this function is local only to
this function and once the function is
executed that variable is destroyed all
right now let's look at a another case
or the other side of this case where um
say we're dealing with variables that
have a global scope how do we deal with
them so let's create a variable called
my where all right and I say I stored
100 in this all right now if I Define a
function I've stored my where let's say
I Define a function define underscore
say again same name where what I'm going
to do in this is I am going to print the
value of whatever is there in my where
Okay so let's do print and
value of variable is value stored in
variable is okay let's uh my where so
let's see what happens when we do this
let's call this function on underscore
name see what happens here so as you can
see the value I stored a value 100 in Y
where and I've called it inside the
function and this is because since I've
defined it outside I can use it inside
as well now what if I try to change the
value of this variable inside the
function though so let's see
if I did this and now if I try to print
let's see do is this Allowed no it's not
allowed in fact I get an error it says
local variable my wire reference before
assignment
um and without going too much into
detail what it's saying is that the
variable inside over here is still local
to this function and I have not defined
this my where as a global variable so I
cannot make changes to it within this
function right now and uh to change that
I can use the global keyword what if I
did Global over here so if I did Global
and now if I said okay Global myware and
I declare this variable as a global
variable now if I do this now if I do
the same incrementation now let's see
what happens when I'm trying to do this
you see I get the value 101 it's exactly
what I wanted and that is because I've
defined my variable to be a global
variable within this function so I can
in fact make changes to it within this
function so this is how we use the
global keyword and Global variable uh
also just to make a quick note there are
three types of functions uh the three
types of categories in which we can
divide functions first one being
built-in functions these are the ones
that are built into the standard library
of python the other is user defined
functions that is the ones which we
Define ourselves and the third type is
called Anonymous functions they're also
known as Lambda functions and this is
something that we're going to cover in a
separate video now let's talk about the
arguments that we pass in Python so
there are four types of arguments that
python user defined functions can take
first one being default the other one is
required then there is keyword and then
there is variable number of arguments so
the default argument is when say
um if I defined a function where
underscore sorry fun or Discord name and
I'm saying a comma B right but what if
the user has not like save I I want a
default value of a and b each time when
I use this function so in the case where
if say I don't pass a value for A and B
like this will always be used so I can
just say a is equal to 2 by default and
B is equal to 3 by default and then
within this function I will say C is
equal to a plus b and then return C so I
do this and if I say fun underscore name
and in case I don't pass any arguments
here let's see what happens by default I
get the answer 5 because by default a is
2 and B is 3 but this is not fixed and I
can always change this by passing my own
values here 5 and 6 and in this case I
should get 11 as you can see here now
the next type is required arguments and
when we are defining a required argument
we just simply do not use the equal to
sign for the parameters over here and
this basically it makes it so that now
anytime we call this function we have to
pass something over here so now if I try
to pass like this I won't get a oops
Yeah I won't get a default value then
that's because
um that's because well there is no
default value and it needs an AM B so I
have to pass it at 3 and say 4. now it
should give me 7 as you can see the next
type of argument that we'll be talking
about are the variable number of
arguments so let's look at an example
here so what I'm doing in this
particular example is I'm defining a
function called my sum where I'm passing
some parameter called my integers and
I'm doing something out here and what
this does is
um it will take the values of a
particular like collection of objects
and that's called my integers and each
value I'm going to keep adding it to
each other and I'm going to result a
particular sum I'm just going to resolve
the sum of whatever is there so in this
case what happens is I'm creating a list
one two and three which contains one two
and three and then I'm going to print
the summation of whatever is there so it
should give me 6. now the problem in
this case is that each time when I'm
going to perform this function I have to
create a separate list where I'm going
to store these objects but what if I
didn't know I do not know like what
exactly I'm going to pass here what if I
don't know if it's going to be a list of
objects or like what is it going to be
exactly well in that case I can use a
variable variable key variable number of
arguments so it's it's like a variable
keyword argument so what we use here is
um a specific way of passing um keywords
and we do it like this so I say Define
my under underscore name and I use an
Asterix now I give it any name this can
be args this can be integers it doesn't
really matter what this is but it's just
this is the key the asterisks here and
this tells us that whatever we pass here
is now if we're supposed to create an
iterable out of this and then we can
perform whatever tasks we want so let's
just uh since I've already created one
here let's see how I'm going to use it
in this case so as you can see I'm doing
uh I'm creating a particular variable
argument function over here and I'm
doing the same task I'm just going to
keep performing at uh I'm going to add
whatever I pass over here but now when
I'm calling this function I don't need
to create a separate list as I did over
here I'm just passing all the numbers
that I want to in the form of like it's
pretty much like a tuple so I'm just
passing these numbers here and what this
function is going to do is it's going to
create an iterable out of this and then
we're going to iterate over it as you
can see that's happening over here and I
can keep uh I don't need I I can just
keep like uh so since I've done it for
one two three and seven the summation
should be 13 in this case I can add
another number here just explicitly just
like this and you can see the value will
change and that's because this is a
variable uh this is a variable argument
uh method of creating a function now the
fourth type of function arguments is the
variable keyword uh argument so let's
look at what is the keyword argument now
so I have defined a function here called
the concatenate function and let's see
what I'm going to do with this so in
this I have passed a keyword argument
I've said that okay this is going to be
a keyword argument function and what I'm
going to do in this is I'm going to
create a blank string and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to add or I'm going
to concatenate certain strings that I'm
going to pass to this function so I in
this example I have passed Python and is
and Google and an exclamation mark all
separate strings and what I'm going to
do in this function is I'm going to join
them together
um and I'm going to create one whole
string out of it let's see what's the
result python is cool so this is so of
course like uh if I had to add some
something else like python is a cool and
say I just wanted to say hello and say
one more string I can add I can add it
just like this I don't have to like
Define a fixed number of arguments I can
pass and any number of arguments I want
and this works exactly the same as
variable in the only differences instead
of positional arguments we're using
keyword arguments over here hello by
like this it doesn't really make sense
but it's to show you as you can see so
this is how we use keyword arguments in
this video we will be learning about X
exceptions exceptions are errors that
are raised during the execution of a
program when an error occurs python
generates this exception that can be
handled which avoids our program from
caching python has many built-in
exceptions however we can create many uh
user-defined errors or exceptions as
well to catch whatever errors we're
looking for in our program so when an
error occurs python interpreter raises
an exception and stops the current
process and it passes it to a calling
process until the exception is handled
and if this is not handled the program
will crash some of the built-in
exceptions are like I O error in the
case when a file cannot be opened or
import error python cannot find the
particular module being imported and
there are so many similar uh so many
exceptions that are built in Python for
the appropriate cases now before we move
on and see how we raise these exceptions
let's look at the difference between an
exception and a syntax error so for that
I will be using an example where I will
be dividing something by the number zero
of course this is not possible so let's
see how python handles this particular
problem well it Trace is something that
it raises what we call a zero division
error and this is an exception that is
built in in Python whenever we try to
divide something by zero now let's look
at the difference between this exception
and a syntax error so this is the same
statement except I'm going to add this
extra bracket which does not make sense
syntactically in this now if I try to
execute this as you can see we get a
different type of error known as the
syntax error when it says the unmatched
closing bracket so this is what a syntax
error looks like like an extra bracket
or a comma that basically makes the line
unreadable to The Interpreter in the
first place so the The Interpreter
doesn't even get to the point where it
needs to figure out uh that there is
something being divided by zero it
doesn't even get to that point because
it finds this extra bracket and it
cannot execute this line at all so that
is like the difference between an uh an
exception and a syntax error all right
now for our first case of how we raise
or how we handle exceptions let's look
at the keyword arrays so for this
example what I will be doing is I'm
going to take this variable X all right
and I'm going to store a value 10 and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
check for a condition if x is greater
than 5 then I'm going to raise this
exception using the raise keyword like
this and in case this condition is met
if x is actually greater than 5 I want
this particular message to play out in
my uh exception so let's see what
happens when I execute this as you can
see the exception is raised because X is
indeed greater than 5 its value is 10
and the mirror message says so that X
should not exceed 5 the value of x was
10. so this is an example of how we can
raise an exception and as you can see
when a condition was met the program
comes to a halt and an exception was
raised now let's look at another type of
handling exception where we use the
assert statement so when we use base
command we waited until an error
occurred and our program crashed Midway
right what if we want to check if a
condition is met and if this condition
is met then then the program can
continue but if the condition turns out
to be false then we want a particular
error namely the assertion error
exception to be thrown to us so we can
use the assert command in such a case so
in our example we will be checking
whether the system that we are working
on is actually Linux or Windows 32. so
let's see first of all let's import a
library called sys this is the it's a
library which where we can access system
information one of the modules and that
is one of the functions and that is the
platform it basically tells us what
system are we working on so we're
working on a win32 system okay so um
let's now let's use the assert keyword
all right now we're going to check if
Linux is what we are working on and in
case it is not then we want an error
message and this will be the error the
error will obviously be an assertion
error because we are using the assert
keyword
so this is how we use the assert
statement and if we execute this as you
can see we get the assertion error
because systart platform contains win32
and not Linux and so we got this
assertion error so if we change this to
check for Windows system we won't have
any error when we execute this as you
can see so this is uh the example where
we use the assert statement another way
of handling exceptions is by using the
try and accept block so this is probably
one of the most common ways of handling
exceptions in Python where we use a try
keyword and an accept keyword now within
the try keyword as you can see here we
have a chunk of code which we're going
to check and if everything is fine in
the try keyword then this is perfect so
we don't need to move on to what we call
the accept part of the try and accept
block but if say there was an error in
the try block then we move on to the
accept block where we're going to run
the part of the code in the case we find
an error in the try block so first we
check the channel part of the code that
is under the try block and if if there
is an error we move on to the accept
block and we run that part of the code
over there and where we and in the
accept block where we that is where we
handle our whatever error that might get
thrown our way in the try block okay
let's look at an example at how to use
this technique so I have a basic
function out here all right it's uh
defining a function called Linux
interaction what this is uh basically
doing is that when I call this function
I want to do an assert check I'm going
to check if Linux is the system I'm
working on and if it is not then I want
this error to be thrown okay and so yeah
let's see what happens in the case and
if if the search statement is actually
passed then we will move on to this
statement so you could look at it like
this if whenever I mean when I call this
function it will first check for this
assert statement in case something wrong
happens and we get an assert error then
we do not move on to this line so we
only get this printed but if this assert
statement passes then we move on to this
line and we get print doing something
okay so let's see I'm going to call this
function out here let's see what happens
here as you can see I get an assertion
error because obviously this is a
Windows system and not a Linux system
and I get this message okay now let's
see what happens when we use it in a try
and accept block all right so now I have
a try block over here in which I am
going to try the same this function
Linux underscore interaction if in case
I find an error I immediately jump from
the try block into the accept block now
you see the slight difference in how we
handle this like what happens as you can
see when we use the function explicitly
we directly went to what we called an
assertion error but when we use a try
and accept block we will not use the
assertion error because we are leaving
the try block immediately and we are
going to go into the accept block where
the only thing we're doing is printing
the statement as you can see we are not
on Linux found some error okay now what
if we wanted to catch the error within
uh this function itself which was the
assertion error and we can do that
explicitly like this so now what I'm
doing is I'm going to try all right and
it's going to catch an error in this
right so now in the accept block I'm
going to say the assertion error that we
found in this function in the try block
we're going to use that in our accept
block so as you can see we're going to
print that assertion error it will
basically print this statement function
can only run on Linux systems as you can
see here function can only run on net
systems function can only run on Linux
systems and the next part of the thing
was the Linux interaction function was
not executed okay so this is a a very
this is like this is a key there's a key
something very important happening here
when we use this assert statement the
whole program is actually getting
executed right but when we're using the
try and accept block we are immediately
jumping on like the moment we catch an
error we are immediately jumping onto
the accept statement and uh however and
all the handling of the exception is
done in the accept block and not in the
try block anymore so where to uh think
of it like this that the try block is
only to check if a particular piece of
code is like does it have any errors or
not and in case it does then every like
all the handling that we do is uh in the
accept block of this particular
statement now let's look at another
example in this example I'm going to try
opening a particular file now this file
does not exist so I will be I will get a
file not found error and this is a
built-in exception and I'm going to
catch that and I'm going to print that
error over here in the accept block all
right so as you can see file not found
and whatever like error I have I printed
over here all right so this is another
like this is a file not found error that
we are going to with that we we caught
in our try block and we're handling it
in the accept block now let's use let's
combine both of the examples where we
use this Linux interaction and we also
try to open a particular file and we try
to do both things in the try block and
since both of these contain errors let's
see what happens when we try to what
happens when we have like multiple
errors in a tribal block so as you can
see in my try block I'm not only doing
this Linux interaction I'm also trying
to open a particular file that does not
exist obviously so now you might think
will I get two exceptions well let's see
what happens when we try to uh execute
this so it's important to note that in
our accept we have one except for uh
catching a file not found error and we
also have an except for finding um uh
the assertion error that that is part of
this Linux interaction function so so
since both of these are errorous
statements or they will throw exceptions
so now the question is will we get both
of these except blocks or will we get
both of these exceptions where we can
only one of them where we get the first
one so let's see what happens so as you
can see my error statement is is very
much like the assertion error that I had
that we had done as part of this Linux
underscore interaction function function
can only run on Linux system the Linux
function was not execute it as you can
see that that is the one that has been
caught and for some reason the file not
found error has not been caught and this
is because this is a very important
feature of the try block the moment we
find the first error in our try block we
immediately leave and we do not execute
any of the further statements and we
jump into the exceptions and we handle
it using the accept blocks so the moment
an error is found in this function we do
not execute this part of the statement
and we directly jumped into the
respective exception that was the
assertion error exception so this is a
key takeaway so some of the some of the
other key takeaways when it comes to
exceptions is a try Clause is executed
up until the point where the first
exception is encountered and in the
accept clause or the exception Handler
we determine how the program responds to
this exception we can have multiple
exceptions and we can differentiate how
the program responds to each of these
and it's also very important to not use
accept clause on its own it's very
important not to use a bare accept
Clause now finally before we we conclude
this topic of exceptions let's look at
the else and the finally Clause so the
else Clause is used when we want to
execute a particular piece of code in
the case where we have no exceptions or
no errors found so let's look at this
just like we had the Linux interaction
function I'm going to define a win under
underscore interaction and this is going
to check whether our system is Windows
or not in case it is not then we get
this error message all right and in case
it is a Windows it is a Windows system
we print this in the case of when we
call this function so let's again use
our try and accept statement only in
this case we will be using an extra else
Clause so we first try this function in
case there's an error we catch it as an
assertion error and we print that error
but if there is no exception then we
move on to the else statement and we
print this so as you can see our we have
actually moved on to the else statement
and we print this line executing the
else clause and that is because we have
found no exceptions over here so again
is key to remember that the else Clause
is used whenever you want to execute a
particular statement in the case where
we do not find any exceptions in the try
block the finally Clause is used when we
want to execute something regardless of
whether we have an error or an exception
or not so no matter if an exception
happens I mean is raised or if it's not
raised we want this finally block to
always get executed and let's look at
how it's let's look at an example of it
being used so I have this block where
I'm doing a lot of things the first
thing that I'm doing is I'm going to
check for this Linux interaction
function which is going to check of
course whether it's a linear system or
not this is I'm doing the try block now
if I catch an error that I want to be I
want to handle it by simply printing the
error over here and in the event that
there is no error then I will move on to
the else statement and I will try this
particular block of my statement which
is again that when I'm trying to read a
particular file that does not exist and
it's very uh it's very important that
you note that within the else block I
have another try and accept block and
this is perfectly legal and it's
perfectly valid in our program we can do
this so think of it like this I'm first
trying this if I have an error then I do
this and I don't execute this but if I
don't have an error then I execute this
whole statement which contains its own
try and accept block all right but
regardless of whether I get an error
here or not I will always execute this
portion of my statement or under the
finally Clause so let's execute this as
you can see of course the error is
raised in this try try block so we move
on to the exception and that is what is
printed over here and after the
exception is done we move on to the
finally we of course skip this else
block because the exception was actually
raised so after that is done we move on
to the finally block where we print this
particular statement well that was it
for an introduction into exceptions in
Python I hope you learned something from
this and um of course this is just the
beginning exceptions are something that
you will be that you would probably
encounter a lot especially when you're
beginning and it's something that you
will learn to extensively work with and
that will also help you improve in your
programming in this video we will be
covering the topic of iterators now an
iterator in Python is an object that
contains a countable number of values or
it's a larger object it contains a
countable number of sub-objects an
iterator is an object that can be
iterated upon and what that means is we
can Traverse from each value and we can
manipulate or perform certain functions
or operations and tasks using each of
the sub objects or values within this
larger collection called iterator now
um when we're looking at it technically
an iterator is an object which
implements the iterator protocol in
Python which consists of the methods
iter and the method next so to begin
with let's look at a simple iterator
we're going to see the example of a list
where we're going to Traverse through
the objects of a list using the for Loop
so we have objects one two three before
and I'm going to print each of these
values one by one as you can see here
similarly we can also do the same thing
for another iterable known as the string
where we can go character by character
again using the for loop as you can see
here another example of an iterable in
Python is the dictionary so let's say I
have a dictionary where I have two
values two key value pairs uh key X
which contains a value 1 and key Y which
corresponds to value 2. now when I'm
going to do a for Loop through this by
default I will be traversing through the
keys X and Y as you can see over here
and of course the other types of weight
troubles in Python are like sets and
tuples as well all right now let's look
at um what this iterating protocol is in
Python so first of all we take an
iterable it's an object that contains uh
it's a collection of objects it contains
sub-objects and when we use the eater
function it creates an iterator out of
it so we can one by one we can Traverse
through
um each of the objects and we can
manipulate each of the objects that is
contained in this and anytime we want to
move to the next object we use the next
function and when we are finally
completed all of the or we've
manipulated or traversed through each of
the sub objects we encounter the stop
iteration exception which tells us okay
there are no more objects to be
manipulated or uh iterated upon so an ex
as an example I will create a list where
I will store the values some simple
values in teachers one two three four
one three four five okay I'm going to
create an iterator out of this where I
will use iter function and I'm going to
say this is let's say this is called my
my editor okay and I'm going to use iter
function as I had mentioned and I'm
going to pass my list in this
now if you see what is miter it should
say it should be a list iterator at a
particular memory location now let's use
the next function to keep going through
whatever is there in this so of course
the first object should be one as you
can see now when I look at the next it
should be three then I should get four
and now I should get five as I use the
next uh successively now since I've
reached the last of my objects in this
collection now the next time I use this
next function I should get a stop stop
iteration exception that is raised as
you can see here so this is the basic
iteration protocol in Python now you
might have already gone through the for
Loop video and in that I have spoken in
quite a bit of detail as to how a for
Loop performs this um this iterator
protocol and how it creates an iterative
iterable object out of say a list or a
tuple and how we how it internally
performs the next function and it um
breaks out of the for Loop once it
encounters the stop iteration exception
so
um for Loops are like they're very very
similar to your standard iterator and
they use pretty much the same protocol
for its functioning now let's do a basic
comparison of what is a a basic
comparison between a generator and an
iterator in Python so in generator we
use a function we use like we Define it
using the def keyword and we Define it
under one function to create a generator
whereas in the case of iterators we use
two separate functions the iter function
and the next function the generator
makes use of the yield keyword whereas
the python iterator does not in
generators we save the states of the
local variables each time we use the
yield keyword and we pause the loop
temporarily whereas in iterators we do
not make use of any local variables all
we need is any triple like a list to
iterate upon we may use any number of
yield statements in generators and we do
not use yield statements in iterators
generators are not memory efficient
whereas iterators are very memory
efficient so this is like basic
comparison between generators and
iterators in this video we will be
covering the topic of modules in Python
now a module in Python to put it simply
is basically a python file that has
functions and classes written into it
and is saved with the dot py extension
to specify that it is indeed a python
file a Python program can use one or
more modules and modules can have one or
more functions they basically help us
organize our code and instead of having
one like one long python file we can
have several files for several modules
now my modular programming is the
process of breaking a large a large
event or task into smaller and more
manageable subtasks and we call these
subtasks basically modules now
individual modules can be grouped
together like building blocks to create
a larger application there are several
advantages to modulizing code in a large
application and we will be going through
them right now so first of all there is
Simplicity because instead of focusing
on a big big problem a big task we can
break down the problem into smaller
smaller portions or modules now
maintainability of code is much better
through module because they are designed
to create these sort of boundaries or
clear demarcations between different
problem domains there is usability
reusability in the sense that once we
create a module we can use it in
different parts of the code or even
different different applications itself
there is also scoping and what this
means is modules typically Define a
separate namespace and this helps us
avoid collisions between identifiers in
different areas of a program functions
modules and packages are basically all
constructs in Python that promote code
modulus modularization you might have
already come across a coordinate intro
into functions in this video we will be
going through modules in another video
we will also cover the topic of packages
to import a module we use the import
keyword and in this example what I'm
going to show you is a simple function
or a simple operation of importing the
OS module this is short for operating
system and as the name suggests we can
perform a system tasks uh through the
functions and methods that are part of
this OS module so simply executing the
statement will import this module onto
our program for us to use now if we
wanted to see all the functions that are
present in a module what we have to do
is use the dir function so if we print
the dir OS function it will print us
basically a directory of all the
functions that are present in the OS
module as you can see here that like the
all of these are basically uh names to
different functions that are part of the
OS module finally moving on another
function commonly used with modules is
the getcwd function and what this does
is it will give us the current working
uh directory that we are working upon
right now so if I execute this it will
tell me what is the directory that I am
currently working upon right now as you
can see seed notebook dir stem if you
wanted to see all the files in a
particular directory what we can do is
use the list dir function followed by
giving a path by default if we do not
enter a path inside the panel this is it
will basically give us all the files in
the current working directory which in
our case is temp so if I were to execute
this it gives basically gives me a list
of all the files that are presently uh
there in the directory that I am
currently working upon now a basic step
is
um creating a python module the simplest
way to create a python module is
basically creating a python script with
whatever functions and tasks that we
want and methods that we want inside uh
whatever module and saving it with a DOT
py extension
um so in in my example what I'm going to
do is I have already created a script in
notepad and I've stored it with a DOT py
extension that contains these four
functions add subtract product and
Division I have basically copied I
basically use this code and I've stored
it in a.py script and I'm going to be
using this as my uh as as a test module
for this particular example now how do
we import a module now once that I have
created a script in my example it will
be called mycalc.py uh and we've stated
stored it in our directory to import the
module all we have to do is use the
import statement so if I had to import
my calc all I have to do is say import
my underscore calc and now my calc has
been important um so we can use the
import statement or if we want to import
something particular from my calculator
we can do from my calc import uh now we
whatever like for example if we wanted
the ad uh the add function we can
basically just say only add or if we
wanted add and subtract we can say add
and subtract for example so this is
basically by using from we can say that
we want something from something but
only parts of it we don't want
everything we can also use from my calc
import and we can say asterisks to
basically say uh import everything that
exists in my calc right now so this is
another way of importing something from
a module now to access contents in a
module we have to use the dot operator
and I will show you how right now so
what I'm going to do is in my example
I'm going to import my calc as calc so
now what this since this is the original
folder or the original module but I'm
going to give it a shorthand name so
that I can easily use it in my code and
I don't have to type out my underscore
calc every time so now I'm going to
import this as calc so anytime I have to
refer to a particular method or function
inside the script or this module I will
just use this uh this placeholder this
variable name so now I have two
variables A and B and I'm storing 20 and
30 in them so my first func what I'm
going to do is basically four operations
I'm going to print the addition of A and
B then the subtraction multiplication
and the division of these two numbers
and each time to do this operation I am
going to use the add function that is
present in the my calc module so to do
that I have already imported my calc all
I'm going to do now is invoke these
functions using the dot operator that
we're already familiar with so I'm going
to say carrot.add and then I'm going to
pass these two arguments or these two
variables to say that I want to add
these two and similarly I'm going to do
it for subtraction
um multiplication and division as you
can see these are the results of my
tasks now if I had to do a directory uh
operation on the module calc it will
basically give me a bunch of inbuilt or
Dunder methods that are already a part
of any uh python script by default such
as built-ins so if I execute this just
to show you what happens when I use the
dir function it will basically give me
all the functions that are part of this
python script so these double
underscores that you see are basically
uh denoting magic methods or Dunder
methods and these are like inbuilt
methods as a part of the script and if
you see here add division prod and sub
these are the methods that we have
defined earlier on in our script
ourselves now to go slightly deeper or
more detail into what happens when we do
a module search
um let's let's actually look at what
happens so what happens is when for
example we execute the statement import
my calc as calc as we did over here so
the first the steps that actually take
place are the interpreter executes the
above statement and it searches for this
python script in a list of directories
assembled from these following sources
that you see here so it takes the
directory from which the input script
was run or the current directory if The
Interpreter is being run interactively
which is the case right now secondly it
will list all the directories contained
in the python path environment that you
set up uh that you can set up or you can
change later on as well and this format
for python path is OS dependent of
course but it should mimic the path
environment variable that we see in
Windows systems and then the other
source or the other directories is
basically an installation dependent list
of categories configured at the time
python is installed now the resulting
search paths that is accessible in the
python variable system.path and this is
basically obtained from a module named
sys so if I import it this is and I did
sys dot path now these are all the
directories that we are going to look
for when we want to search for any
particular module so if I am doing uh
import my kayak or import OS it's not
only going to look at the current
directory that I am working on it's also
going to look at all of these
directories that have been set up as you
could say directories or paths in the
system.path in this video we will be
covering the topic of packages now what
if we developed if a very large
application in Python that contains many
different modules and we have so many
different modules that have similar
names and functionalities and they're
all kept in like or dumped in the same
location that it becomes very difficult
to track these modules what if there was
a way to organize and access these in a
much simpler and more organized manner
well packages allow us to do just that
packages are a hierarchical structuring
of the module namespace using dot
notation and this is the same dot
notation that we use when we want to
access methods or functions that are
part of other classes or modules so
let's try to uh let's look at certain
examples to understand what we mean so I
have a directory called PKG this can be
basically treated as what we call a
package now in our package we have two
modules mod1.py and mod 2. py and what
we're going to store in mod 1 and mod
2.py are the follows so I'm going to
define a function called Foo and I'm
going to print uh this particular
statement mod1 and then I'm gonna
basically say Foo and then I'm going to
say in class 4 I'm going to have an
empty pass command similarly I'm going
to define a function called bar in mod 2
dot py where I'm going to print this
statement so basically mod1.py has a
simple function where I'm going to print
this statement and mod 2.py has a simple
function then I'm going to print this
statement
um I'm going to store them in mod 1 and
mod 2.py respectively and these two
modules I'm going to store in the
directory tkg in my local folder now
I've already done this so we can already
get to working with this now if I wanted
to access these particular modules from
the PKG folder I can simply use the
import command and use the dot notation
so I can say PKG dot mod1 so this will
invert in this will import the mod 1
module from PKG folder similarly I can
do the same thing for the mod 2 module
from the PKG folder in the same line so
now that it's been imported just simply
execute this and this Imports whatever
we needed now if we wanted to perform a
function that was a part of
mod1.py we can just extend the dot
notation and use the function as over
here as you can see it performs this
print command whatever it was supposed
to do similarly I can invoke the
function that was part of the mod 2
module by extending the dot notation to
it in the same way now another way that
I can invoke
um I can import a package is by directly
importing the package Itself by using
import pkz and not accessing any of the
specific modules within it now let's see
what happens when we do this so just for
this example what I'm going to do is I'm
going to restart the kernel so that the
PKG modules that were already imported
get cleaned away so we see what happens
when we execute this on its own now if
you see I haven't imported this now
let's see if I can access says my mod 1
and mod 2. now if you see here it's
throwing me an error and this is because
using simply using the import command on
a particular package only Imports
um you could say the package name space
but it does not actually import any of
the modules and files that were part of
this package so if I wanted mod 1 from
this package I would have to actually
say import pkg.mod1 directly and I
cannot simply say import PKG and python
will not import everything that is part
of a package on its own I have to
specify it myself
specifically now I'm going to create and
I'm gonna I mean I'm going to show you
another type of importing from a package
using the star operator so I have this
package PKG once again now I'm going to
store
um three I mean four different modules
within this package
mod11.py mod 222.py and I've already
done this you don't need to bother about
seeing me doing it right now because
I've already created these files and
what I've done is is within mod11.py I
have defined I've passed I've written
this statement and I've stored in the
python script similarly I've created
another Python scripts script called
mod22.py and I have basically written
this in the code and I've simply done
this for mod 333.py and I've done
another for mod 4.py now once I have
done this I've stored these Python
scripts into my uh into my package or
PKG package so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create I'm going to
execute this command if you see this
from pkg.mod 333 import start so once I
execute this now I'm going to say print
directory and print directory basically
will tell me all the functions that
exist in my current directory if you see
here there's this bias function that was
a part of mod 333 module now if I change
this and if I imported mod11 and if I
did the same thing you will see Foo has
now been added as a part of this
direction directory and these are all
functions that are part of these
different modules where I'm importing
from and that is what the star function
does what the star function will do is
it will basically tell python okay so
the statement is saying from pkz dot
mod11 so it's saying that um okay look
into this directory or this uh package
and find this module and in this module
import everything that exists inside it
up until this point so this is another
another way of basically importing uh
files or functions from a particular
package and a particular specific module
within that package so yeah this was a
very brief video on packages in Python
uh the conclusion being that packages
are basically a an organized way of
storing many different modules that we
might have created in a very large
application and these modules can be
accessed using the familiar.net notation
that we have used in other examples such
as methods when we were working with
classes and objects in this video we
will be taking an introduction into the
concept of generators so python provides
a generator which is like like a
function where we can create our own
iterator in a generator function we use
the yield statement instead of the
return statement that we use for
standard functions
so let's look at a simple Generator
First of all so out here I have defined
a generator called my generator where
I'm doing like the three uh like three
functions or three tasks that I'm doing
first one is when I'm printing the first
item and I'm yielding a value 10 then
I'm printing second item yielding 20
then I'm printing last item using 30. so
let's see how do we use this
now since we know my generator is the
function it uses the yield keyword every
time we use the next keyword we will
keep getting what is next in this
function so let's store the generator in
my gen
so now we have stored the iterator in
this function variable called gen or gen
now let's see when we do next
and we use gen
what happens so the first task is
performed or the first iteration is
performed where we get this the first
year command is done all right let's see
what happens when we do next again
next gen
now
as you can see we get second item and we
get 20. let's do it for the next so
let's do it once more since there is one
more task there's one more iterable
inside
you can see this now a valid question is
what will happen if we do next gen again
since there is nothing after this
but let's see what happens
we should get an error as you can see
stop iteration error this is another uh
built-in exception
um that happens when we have like
reached the last object of an iterable
so we get a stop iteration error
so now a key difference between a
generator and a function is that when we
execute a function the moment we hit the
return statement in a function or any
execute a function like whatever
variables are stored inside are lost and
they are destroyed unless they were
defined as Global and the function is
completely done executing and we leave
the function completely whereas when it
comes to a generator when we hit the
yield function we don't actually
completely leave this function so the
first time the yield is found we get 10
but the generator remembers its position
inside this function so the next time we
use the next we actually move on to the
next iterable and then we move on to the
next hit Triple so you can think of a
generator as it sort of has memory if
that makes sense it's a way to like
create iterables in Python okay
iterators in Python so to understand a
what the difference between the yield
command and the return commanders let's
take the same function all right
and let's put it return over here
after this particular the second yield
okay let's do the same thing we say gen
is equal to my generator
and
let's start uh yeah let's start
doing next gen and seeing what's there
so the first here will be standard first
item 10 the next one is again is going
to say second item and then 20 but now
if you notice there was a return I put
over here
so technically when I did the second
next it's not only yielded 20 but it's
also executed this return function or
this return statement so let's see what
happens if I do next again
as you see I have gotten the stop
iteration seemingly earlier than I did
before and that's because I have used
the return function and while in return
statement and what that's done is that
um if we've completely left this
function so as to speak and there is
nothing next so as to speak so we get
these top iteration and that's uh the
difference between yield and return
now in the next example I'm going to
show you how we use a generator function
in place of the for Loop or for a for
Loop so let's take this whatever over
here and I have defined a function
called get sequence up to X and what
this will do is basically it will keep
printing the printing numbers up until
whatever we have entered in place of X
over here so if I said say sequence is
equal to
that's uh
copy this all right and say I want um I
want sequentially I want every number up
until 10 well not including 10 of course
because python starts with 0 right
so let's do this and um
now let's see so the first number will
yield 0
and now if I
did this again
it should give me one
two and I can keep going
until I will stop at the value 9. as you
can see here
so 8 9
now I should get the stop iteration
error because that we have reached the
end of our iteration so this is a way of
using generator functions for for loops
so another neat example where we're
going to use a generator is
um in the case of Fibonacci numbers so
let's use it let's see how we can
generate a Fibonacci series using
um generator so I've defined a Fibonacci
function called Fibonacci where I'm
passing Max so max is basically the max
value that I want
um yeah like up until where I want the
sequence right so this is basically the
code which will uh give return me the
subsequent values of my Fibonacci
Sequence so let's pass this to fib
and see I want all the Fibonacci numbers
until 10.
so once I will pass 10 over here
let's see what happens when we do next
fib
well it should start with zero then when
we
do this again we get 1 then we do 0 plus
1 it should be one next number should be
one plus one which is 2 then we should
have two plus one three and then three
plus two five then three plus five
should be eight now eight plus five is
thirteen and since 13 is greater than
what we pass for our max value here now
when we try this we should get the stop
iteration error as you can see
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of list comprehension
now this comprehension is it's a neat
way of creating a new list based on
values that are already there in an
existing list so you can think of it
like creating a new list using a much
shorter and cleaner syntax compared to
what you might traditionally be thinking
so let's go through some examples and
through those examples we will see how
list comprehension makes creating these
new this much simpler and much easier
for us
so in our first example we will be
creating a new list which will contain
fruits that contain the letter a in
their name so we already have a list of
fruits over here as you can see it has
Apple it has banana Cherry kiwi and
mango now we want to create a new list
which has only the fruits that have the
letter A inside them so Apple would be
one of them banana would be one of them
and mango will be one of them so
traditionally
if you look at this piece of code
this would do what we want to do but
this contains a few extra lines but yeah
it does it does do what we want to do
now what if there was a way of doing the
same thing by just writing one simple
line of code and that exists as you can
see here
so I take the same
list now this is where you need to
follow so now my new list is equal to so
I'm creating a list over here as you can
see now within this list you have this
line this is what we call a list
comprehension so as you can see it says
each fruit for each fruit in fruits if
now it's checking for the letter or the
character a inside each fruit and what
this each fruit is that we're checking
each object in this list one by one so
first in the first iteration each fruit
will contain the string Apple then in
the next iteration it will contain
banana and in each each iteration we're
going to check if it contains the
character a and if it does then we store
that each fruit in the new list as you
can see here so if I execute this line
you see my my result is the same I have
my whatever I want it and this was a
much cleaner way of writing uh or
creating this new list let's look at
some other examples now
so my next example what I'm going to do
is I am going to iterate through a
string so I have a string it can be
anything in this case I am using a
string called human
all right so I have a string called
human right now I want to store each
character of this string into a list
that we call H underscore letters so if
I use the for Loop this is how we would
do it if I execute this as you can see
the list contains H and then u m a and
then n now what if I wanted to do the
same thing but uh by using list
comprehension so what I would do is
let's create
a list over here H underscore letters
and
um so as we know let's come so list
comprehension will uh it's it's a it's
you just basically need one line in this
case it'll just be like this
now this is my string
now let's see when I check what's in h
letters
let's see what is the output so as you
can see I have the output as uh what I
needed so this is a much cleaner way
let's go through some more examples now
now we can do more list comprehensions
um we can even use so we've already seen
uh one case where we checked for the
character a we've seen a case where we
uh went through where we we did a sort
of a loop through a string we can also
use this comprehensions in conditionals
so let's uh look at an example where we
use the uh this comprehension with an if
statement
so what if I wanted to store say the
first
10 even numbers so this would so this is
an example that I'll be using
so in my list I want to store the first
10 even numbers so this would be a way
to do it
so I have in range 20 so what this is
going to do is X is going to take the
value of 1 2 3 4 and so on until 98 that
actually take it from 0 1 2 3 4 until
19. so when we do range 20 we're
creating an iterate in iterable where uh
we're going to look through our iterate
through the value of 0 to 19. so if I if
I do this and this what this statement
does is basically uh it checks if it's
divisible by two
so if this is equal to equal to 0 that
means we have an even number and if this
condition is met if this condition is
met that means we store uh the X into
our number list so let's see what
happens when we execute this
should contain uh 0 2 4 6 until 18. so
this is the first 10 even numbers as you
can see so this is an eighth wave using
if statement we can also use an if else
statement
so what if I I'm checking um each okay
so I'm going to create another list and
in this list I'm going to basically see
if um
each of my num numbers either even or
odd the first let's say 10 natural
numbers
so let's write this statement down
so I want it to be even
in case
the I that I'm checking I being every
number between so like say the first 10
natural numbers as I said
let's check if um if it is divisible by
because if it is by 2 of course it's
going to be even right else
we say that it is odd
and then we checked for I in say the
first let's say the first 20.
okay
so now when we do this and we check hope
he check what's in the list so as you
can see the list contains like even or
even or it's basically saying the number
uh zero is even then the number one is
odd then number two is even and so on
and so forth so this is a an example
where we used the list comprehension
with if else statements so another neat
thing that we can do with the list
comprehensions is that we can use it
along with functions so let's look at
this function in this example we have a
function called double X where we Define
this double X this double function to
take an input to take an argument X and
what we return is the square of the
argument so let's use this in uh in our
left list comprehension so what we do
over here is that we are we're checking
what we're doing is for every X
um bit in range 10. so we're taking the
value of 0 1 2 3 until 9 and we're
passing it to this function double X and
we're going to get the square of them
and we're going to store that in a in a
list as you can see here let's call this
list X so just call this list uh let's
call it y so now let's see what's in y
and we check uh it should be 0 1 4 9 and
so on so wait this let's check again
does this Square now this is actually
two times so let's make it square
as you can see
so you can see zero one four nine for
the first uh 10 numbers 10 natural
numbers now what I've shown you is
obviously list comprehension but we can
also do set and dictionary
comprehensions in fact set
comprehensions work exactly the same way
as list comprehensions like the only
difference is the set comprehensions
will make sure that there are no
duplicates inside the set so you can't
have like duplicate items which you can
in the case of list comprehensions so
let's uh let's like let's take a look at
an example so here in this example what
we're doing is we're going to check so
we have this string that we're storing
in the variable text and the string is
something like live finds a way so
whatever this is now what we're going to
do is we're going to in iterate through
this string character by character and
we're going to check if uh there are
we're going to check for vowels
essentially so uh are going to see if
the character a e i o or U is present in
the string and if it is we will pass it
into our set now if you if you look you
will find there are multiple eyes right
and there are multiple A's as well so if
we did this through a list comprehension
each time that we find found find a
vowel it would be added to our list but
since this is a set and sets do not
allow duplicates so you will only have
one copy or one particular object for
each of the vowels so uh of course now
uh set comprehension is defined using
curly braces so let's keep that in mind
so now if I check what's in this I will
see a e i and U even though there are
multiple A's or multiple E's or I's and
U's since this is a set we don't have
duplicate copies of any copies of any of
these uh so this was just a small
example for uh showing you set
comprehensions similarly we can do the
same thing uh this this comprehension uh
for dictionaries and if we call it
dictionary comprehensions the only thing
that we have to worry about when it
comes to dictionary comprehensions is
that we have to define a key when it
comes to this so let's let's look at an
example
in this what we're doing is again
dictionary comprehensions are also
defined using curly braces just like
sets except in this case we will Define
a key and that separates it from a set
comprehension so in this case what we're
doing is that I'm checking I'm going
through the a list of numbers from 0 to
9 right so what the range 10 function
does and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a key which is going to
be like 0 1 2 3 and the value of each
key would be H squared as you can see
here I'm doing I times I or just to
make a little more clearer as you can
see I'm doing I squared over here for
every value from 0 to 9. so what I
should get is like a dictionary where
the first key is 0 and the value of that
key should be 0 as well because 0 square
is zero then for one it will be one and
then for 2 4 and then 3 9 4 16. so let's
see what happens as you can see here
this is the the result that I wanted
so just to summarize let's go through
some key points uh to remember when it
comes to list comprehensions
um so it's obviously An Elegant way uh
to Define and create list based on
existing lists uh it's more Compact and
faster than normal functions and Loops
but we should also keep in mind that we
shouldn't write like very complicated uh
list comprehensions because the idea of
a list comprehension is to be user
friendly and also it's important to note
that every list comprehension can be
written in the form of a loop but uh
every Loop cannot be written in the form
of a list comprehension and that is a
probably a very key point to remember
in this video we will be learning about
the concept of regular Expressions now a
regular expression is simply a sequence
of characters that defines a search
pattern for example if you see this
example here you can see a symbol called
the carrot followed by P and then five
periods then an n and a dollar sign and
what this regex pattern does is it's
searching for a seven letter string that
starts with B ends with n and has five
characters in between
let's look at this example now this is a
regex pattern that is looking for a five
character string that starts with a ends
with s and has three characters in
between now if we had to match this with
this string with these strings as an uh
as uh i o test strings the first one
would not match because it's a three
letter string and we're looking for a
five character string the second one
would match because it's a five
character string that ends with an s
starts with an A and has three
characters in between this will not
match because whatever pattern would do
is it would find the first s and it
would find that the string itself starts
with an A and it would say okay there
are only two characters between this
first s and this a and you would assume
that this is actually just a four
character string to actually Identify
two consecutive s's we would have to do
something special and what we would have
to do is what we will see later on so
again this is the same example since
this is case insensitive capital a uh is
perfectly fine when we're searching for
this and it will also match this is
um this is obviously two words and it's
not a five character string so this will
not be a match
now the regex pattern or the regular
expression module in Python can be
imported using this statement import Rd
now once we've done this we can actually
use the our regular expression tools and
methods to do a pattern recognition
character recognitions and to identify
different sequence of characters in our
strings let's try to understand a bit
more in depth about regular Expressions
now so what you're seeing here is one
variable call pattern which stores
something that looks like a regex and
another variable that stores our test
string called abis now what we're going
to do is we're going to use the match
method of this module re and we're going
to check whether this pattern
um or whatever we are trying to search
using this reg X is in fact does it
match with our test string and what
we're trying to look for is if you see
here very similar to what I just showed
you a 5 character string that starts
with a and ends with s
so if you see our test string it induced
is a match and when we use this uh this
command we should get a perfect match
so we should be basically it should say
that search is successful if I execute
this and this is what it does
now if I change the test string to this
now you will see that now this is no
longer what we're looking for a five
character string with a and starting
with a and ending with s and you will
see that the search will be unsuccessful
as you can see here now let's try to
understand what exactly do we mean by uh
when we use these different cert these
special symbols like for example this
carrot or this dollar symbol
um these are by the way known as meta
characters and now we're going to look
into all the uh or most of the different
meta characters that are used in regex
so to put it simply meta characters are
simply characters that are interpreted
in a special way by the regex search
engine now here's a list of meta
characters
let's go through them one by one
now the square brackets square brackets
simply specifies the set of characters
that we wish to match so we want to
match some combination of a b and c it
can be one a two a is Three B's four C's
we are not looking at a specific pattern
we just want to know if a b and c exists
in any form in our string so if we used
it on a the string a simply we would
find one match because the letter a is
found here AC would match twice because
we have a and C present here in this
string Hey Jude we will have no matches
because a b and c none of them are found
here and in this weird string we will
have actually one two three
four and five matches so we would have
five matches for this uh this bigger
string because we have five instances of
a b or c
now let's use re dot match to do to
actually search for this and to uh see
if we have our particular whatever
patterns that we're looking for now in
this input string this is just some
example string
um I'm going to test this I'm going to
match whether my pattern that um a any
of a b and c is it actually found in
this so let's see what happens when I
use re dot match for this
so the the format uh the syntax is
simply the regex pattern and then comma
whatever test string that we have
so
let's see what object gets created when
we try to do this as you can see it's
none even though you might be wondering
like I can see an a over here I can see
a c over here re dot match actually
gives us the result none
now
if I try to do it on this test string
which is slightly different instead of
the film Titanic was at least in 1998
what I'm saying here is all film Titanic
was released in 1998. now let's see if
the r match uh works or not
as you can see it actually does give a
return When I execute this it returns as
an object called re.match object with a
span 0 1. the span zero one is basically
telling us that we have found a match
between the zeroth and the first
character which is basically this
character a which is what it has found
and it's saying that the match is indeed
the character a uh from amongst these
options
so what this is basically telling us and
what this means actually is that the re
dot match method will only find matches
if they occur at the start of the string
being searched once there is a space in
in our bigger string it will not search
for whatever comes after it so
what happened in the first instance was
it was actually only searching for
matches in this particular word in my
largest string and since it found no
match it basically gave us the result
none which was not the case in the
second example because it found a match
immediately in the first letter A
now if we want to actually check the
whole thing what we would be using is
the re dot search as you can see here
the re dot search method will actually
check the whole string and it will
return us the first instance where it
finds a match now let's see this is a
test string now and we're searching
again for a AR uh we're searching for a
b and c any any of these in our test
string but we're going to use re.search
and not match so now if you see it
returns us when I execute this it
returns us a match object again but this
time it's saying the span of 9 and 10.
now the spine panel 9 and 10 actually
exists over here this is the ninth
character and a itself is the 10th
character over here so what this
basically is telling us that the 10th
character is where we found a match
which was the letter A which was the
first instance of either A or B or C in
this whole string and this is basically
how re.search works it will not only
search the beginning of the string but
it will search the whole string and
return us the first instance of what
wherever we find now what if we wanted
to find out all the instances wherever a
b and c were found and not just the
first instance well in that case we
would be using the method find all over
here so when we use find all it will
actually return us each and every case
where it found a b or c and you might
not it won't tell you the exact position
but it will tell you like
um so if I execute this you can see it
gives us a a list with AAC a and a and
what this basically means is it was
looking for the characters A or B or C
and it found a first and hence this for
the first item in the list then it found
a c and then it found two is
successfully so this is exact this is
actually how find all works where it
will actually find all of the instances
of our regex pattern now that you've
seen how the square brackets work and
how the re dot search and re dot uh
match and re dot find all methods work
now we're going to go through all the
other meta characters that we saw above
so the period so now period matches any
single character except the new line new
line is basically slash n or a break now
if you look at this picture what it's
going to do is
um a this expression basically saying
that uh do we have
um two characters like sets of two
characters in our string so this is a
single character string and obviously a
single character string is not a double
character string and this expression
this double dot is basically asking us
do we have two characters present in our
string so if I had to match it with this
a it will obviously be a no match
because a is one character if we checked
it with AC it is a match because A and C
are two characters a c and d will also
give us only one match because it will
find AAC and then it will leave d as a
single character but when we check a c d
and e or this string in particular it
will find two matches because it will
consider a and C as one of the matches
and d and e as one of the matches So
Below is basically what we're doing
basically the same thing we're just
using Rd dot search for each of these
different examples so if I if you see
when I use find all on acde and when I'm
searching for a two character match you
will see that it will return me a c and
d e as you can see here and similarly
for something like this it will return
me again uh whatever like two character
patterns it finds successively
so the next symbol the next meta
character is the carrot symbol that
you've seen earlier then the correct
symbol is basically used to check if a
string starts with a certain character
so if you look at these two this picture
if you have two two expressions that
we're going to check over here one is
the one is checking if a is the
beginning of a string and the other one
will check if a
is the beginning of the string but is it
followed by b or not
so when we check this what you can see
is the first string will be a match
because it's the only the character a
and it will match here as well because
this string starts with a but it will
not match here because this string
starts with B now if I look at this
particular expression you can see that
um this is going to search for if the
string starts with a and is followed by
a b so it will match in this case
because a does start with a and is
followed by a b but it will not match in
this case even though it starts with an
A because it's not followed by a b so
out here is basically us using the ID
dot search to basically find these
patterns
the next symbol that we will come across
is the dollar symbol so the dollar
symbol that you can see here is used to
check if a string ends with a certain
character and we've already seen how
this is used in one of the uh one of the
earlier examples so this is going to
check basically if so this expression
will check if the string ends with a so
this uh this string is basically the
character a so it will match this also
ends with a so it will match and this
particular string does not end with a so
it will not match and we are going to do
that using the re dot search over here
so as you can see it finds a match in
the first character itself here in this
case it finds a match in the last
character but in cab there is no match
so it returns I say none another example
is of the meta characters is star so
this is the symbol for star and uh this
is what the star basically is used is
for checking if there are zero or more
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it so now if you see here what this
will check for is is there any form of M
and A
that occurs before n and it's very
important to note that the N has to
follow the a in this case so let's look
at these examples and what will happen
so if I checked it with M and N this is
actually a match because n is followed
by zero occurrences of M and A which is
if it might seem a little weird but it
is technically the truth because uh the
the star symbol checks for not doesn't
check for the Existence it just checks
for with n occurs it must occur after an
A or the a should not be there itself in
this particular string so as you can see
here the N occurs after an m and it's
fine because there is no a now you will
see when it will not work so M A and N
is obviously fine m a uh M Triple A N is
also fine because n follows an A and
there's an M here
this however main will not match now why
even though we have M and A and we have
an N you see the N is immediately
followed by an i is n follows an I
immediately or the N is preceded by an I
immediately and this is a no match
because our the strict condition in the
search is that n must uh proceed an a if
the a exists
again in women it will match because n
follows an a over here we're just going
to use the re dot search for these
examples that we saw over here in terms
of code using the Rd dot search as you
can see here finally we have the next
meta character which is the plus symbol
yes so the plus symbol matches one or
more occurrences of the pattern left to
it now this is very similar to what we
saw earlier in terms of the star except
now in the plus the key difference is
we're looking for one or more
occurrences instead of zero or more
occurrences that we were looking for in
the case of star
so when we say one or more occurrences
now we need what is there to the left of
the plus sign a zero uh no occurrence of
it will not be allowed or will not cause
a match so let's see now what we're
going to do here we're going to use the
same expression except we're going to
replace the star with the plus sign so
now what we're going to say is okay we
need M and A at least one occurrence
followed by an N the all of these
conditions have to be met so again if we
took the first example M and N this time
it will be a no match because there is
no occurrence of an a over here for
preceding the N so it's a no match M A
and N is a match because well this is
per this is perfectly fine M Triple A
and N is also perfectly fine but if you
look at m a i and N much like earlier
the N is uh preceded by an i and not an
A so there is no match and again woman
is perfectly fine and we basically
execute the same thing through the
search function in this piece of code
the next meta character is the question
mark the question mark symbol matches 0
or 1 occurrences other the pattern to
the left of it so let's see what this
does so now we saw the star the star
which was zero or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it we saw the
plus which is one or more occurrences of
the pattern to the left of it now we
will see the question mark which is 0 or
1 only 0 or only one and not zero or
more of one or more which was the
previous cases only zero and one or one
occurrences of the pattern to the left
of it again we're going to see the same
expression except we're going to replace
the meta character with the question
mark So now let's see what what happens
when we match so if you see here M and N
is a match because there is zero
occurrence of a and one occurrence of M
preceding n so this is fine this is also
fine because there is one occurrence of
A and M and then it's followed by an n
this will not be fine because now we
have three occurrences of a
which is followed by an N we're only
looking for 0 or 1. this again main will
be a no match for the same reasons that
we have already gone through and women
will be a match again for the same
reasons and we read through the same
things using the search function in this
piece of code the next meta character is
the braces character now the braces
character is interesting because what
we're going to do is we're going to see
if there are so uh this is the typical
Syntax for abrasives is an uh brace
followed by some integer n comma integer
M and then close braces so what this
means is we're looking for at least n
and at most M repetitions of the pattern
left of the braces let's see through an
example if you see this expression we're
looking for at least two and at most
three occurrences of this the character
a in our test strings so let's see what
happens in the first case we have no
matches in this case because this part
of the string contains only one a and
even this part of the string only
contains one a we're looking for at
least two and at most three this part
will contain one match the second the
second example because the second part
of the string actually contains two is
for one two
and in the third example you can see
both the strings actually contain
matches so we get two matches because as
you can see here there's two A's here
followed by Three A's here now when we
look at this particular string let's
look at what happens now so what we're
going to find is that this thing is
perfectly fine so we have two
occurrences of a but now we have four
occurrences of a but what the search
engine is going to recognize is these
first three is and it's going to see
okay so there are three occurrences of a
and I already have a match it's not
going to consider this fourth a in the
search it will just look at the first
three and say okay there are uh Three
A's and my my match is fine so again
there are two matches in this case again
if you're going to use the search
function initially and you can see each
in each of the cases there is a match
except for the first case which is this
case now let's see the find all option
and see what happens when we do the same
thing using find all
so when we use find all it basically
gives us each of the instances where the
match has occurred in each of these
lists
now let's try to use a slightly more
complicated example where we combine
different let's say different meta
characters and we create a a more
sophisticated expression that we want to
search in our test strings so if you
look at this expression what we're
looking for is 0-9 now a dash symbol is
valid in Python using regex because what
this basically tells it is that it's
looking for either 0 1 2 3 4 so on until
line basically any of the digits if
you're looking for any of the digits
from 0 to 9 and we are going to check if
at least 2 and at most four occurrences
of digits if they are there or not in
our particular code so let's see what
are the matches that happens when we use
it on test strings so if you use it on
this string you can see it will find one
match this basically this particular
part of the string where it says one two
three so this is uh three occurrences of
Digit so it's fine now when we look at
this whole string 12 and whatever this
is you will see this will not find a
match here this obviously will not
because these are characters but if you
look at over this part it will find
matches in the in terms of the first
four and then seven and three the next
two one and two again there are no
matches because there's only single
occurrences of digits we're looking for
at least two and at most four so if I
use a find all
you will see like what all it will
return so for the first test string what
is going to return me is it's going to
return me one two and three as you can
see here but now if you look at this
test string it's going to return me 12
it's going to return Me 3 4 5 and 6.
it's going to return Me 3 4 1 and 2 but
not seven because we're looking for at
least two and then it's going to return
me four five six and seven followed by
eight and eight as you can see in this
list over here now if we use curly
braces with only one digit it's
basically telling the search engine that
we want exactly so many repetitions of
the preceding uh whatever expression
that we have
so when we do this example for uh for
example we're basically saying that we
want uh X
followed by a dash and the dash has to
occur at least three times in our
particular expression and then it should
be followed by an X again which will not
match in this case because there are
only two dashes and it will match in
this case because there are exactly
three dashes and it will again not not
match in this case because there are
four dashes
as you can see here none followed by an
object Maps followed by none
next we move on to the alternation
um the alternation meta character and as
the word suggests alternation is
basically looking for some alternate
form of A and B so a should be followed
by a b and basically this pattern has to
keep going on so in the first string
over here this pattern will not match in
the second string over here we will have
a match because we at least find an a
even though there is no B but this is
still considered Mass because we did
find an a at least over here we'll have
three matches because we have a followed
by a b followed by an a again
so uh if we did a regular expression for
this we would basically find these many
matches for each of these examples
the next meta character is the group now
a parenthesis is basically used to group
sub patterns so let's look at an example
to understand what we mean now if you
look at this complicated expression what
this means is that I want some form of x
and z the x and z have to occur together
but before that what I want is some form
of a following B following C some sort
of alternation between a b and c so this
part as you can see here is kept in a
parenthesis because I want this whole
condition to basically occur before I
find an x and z so let's look at what
happens here in the first case we don't
have a match because uh there this
basically this parenthesis condition is
not being met we x and z is preceded by
a space or basically the A and B is
preceded is followed by a space so there
is this space that didn't occur we would
actually find a match as you can see in
the next example here you can see A and
B occur basically this uh initial
condition is met followed by x and z so
that is be a one match so it's fine for
us now if you look at this slightly more
a trickier one what you can see is we
have two matches in this case first in a
followed by x and z and then we have C A
and B now this is perfectly fine because
we we are looking for a b followed by an
x and z we're looking for either of
these things we're looking for some form
of alternation of these things followed
by an x and z and we can get that over
here we get B followed by an x and z so
we will get two matches in this case now
let's go through the concept of grouping
constructs now that we've seen many meta
characters you've seen how parenthesis
Works let's look at grouping constructs
so grouping constructs break up a regex
in Python into sub expressions or groups
and this serves two purposes one is the
grouping part which basically says that
a group represents a single syntactic
entity and any additional meta
characters apply to the entire group as
a unit and then there is a capturing
part which basically tells us that some
grouping constructs also capture the
portion of the search string that
matches the sub expression in the group
you can retrieve captured matches later
through several different mechanisms so
let's look at basically what we mean by
this example over here so if you see
this this expression has a plus sign so
we're looking for uh as you know a plus
looks for one or more occurrence so this
will basically check for one or more
occurrence of the character R only
because there's no parenthesis as in
this example so this plus is next to an
r and it's going to check for basically
whether one or more occurrence of R
happens uh preceding b and a but if we
actually put B A and R in a parenthesis
followed by plus it will actually check
for the entire string bar and it will
check one or more occurrences of bar
together so if you look at these two
examples when we use this uh on these
examples you can see that these are fine
like these matches are fine but if I
used this parenthesis then these would
be the acceptable matches and like b a
triple R would not be a match if I use
parenthesis as you can see here
so this is how grouping constructs work
and how parent thesis work so let's look
at some other examples so what this will
do is Foo has to be optionally followed
by bar and bar must exist over together
and um this is because we have a
question mark here this question mark
symbol tells us that it should be zero
or one occurrences
similarly this particular completed
expression is checking for one or more
occurrences or whatever we saw earlier
basically this whole thing is followed
by a plus so we're looking for this
whole sequence for one or more
occurrences of it c o w is simply just c
o w we're looking for this pattern and
this is going to check for 0 or 1
occurrence of cow because of the
existence of the question mark preceded
by the parenthesis
in this video we're going to continue
our discussion on regular Expressions
now that you know the basics of regular
Expressions let's continue our
discussion with special sequences now in
an earlier video on strings you might
have encountered what is an escape
sequence and how we use the backslash
character to generate these Escape
sequences and an escape sequence is
basically if you remember
something that we use to either
gives a certain special meaning to
characters that are otherwise ordinary
or it is used to remove the special
meaning that are inherently present in
certain characters that we call Meta
characters so let's look at what special
sequences are in relation to regular
expressions
so the first one we're going to look at
is the backslash capital A which is used
to match if specified characters are at
the present are present at the start of
a string so out here if you can see we
are checking if the word d is present in
these two strings so we would get a
match in the first case over here
because this starts with the word the
but in the second case we won't get a
match and this is how we're going to
check it for the same thing using the
find all function
so if you see in the first case it gives
us it returns us an object because we do
find the in the beginning of the string
in the second case we get us empties
list because this string does not start
with the word t
now the next one that we'll look at is
backslash B small B now this is used to
match if specified characters at the
beginning or at the end of a word so
when you use backslash small B and then
you follow it up with whatever you're
looking for it will look for the that
particular those particular characters
or that pattern if it exists in the
beginning of a word in a string so if
you look at the first example it starts
with f double O and in the second
example you see this portion of the
string or this word is actually also
starting with f double O so it will also
match however in this string which is
very similar to the second one we don't
have a space between a and F and it's
basically one word so this does not
start with f double O but it actually
starts with afo and it won't match as
you can see here now similarly if we
wanted to check if something exists in
the back of a string at the end of a
string we type what we want to search
for first and then we follow it with a
backslash small B and then if you see
here it will match in this first case it
will match in the second case because
this part of the string ends with f
double O but it will not match in this
case because well we remove the space so
now this whole thing becomes a uh the
string that we're looking for and it
does not end with FW anymore this is
basically us just checking in through
the find all function now the next SK
the next special sequence that we will
be looking at is the slash capital B
which is basically the opposite of what
we just saw this matches only if the
specified characters are not at the
beginning or the end of a word so if you
see here this is checking if F double O
is not at the beginning of these strings
so in this case there will be a no match
in this case also it'll be a no match
and this third case there will be a
match similarly if we wanted to see if
something does not end with a particular
string we would type that whatever
pattern we're looking for followed by a
backslash capital B and then we can use
the find all function to generate us
lists wherever we find such objects find
such matches in our particular test
strings like we have done over here so
the next one that we're going to look at
is the backslash small D and this
matches any decimal digit which is
equivalent to doing a square brackets
0-9
as you've seen you must have seen
earlier so if we did a square bracket
0-9 and we did a search or a find all or
a match it would look for any of the
digits between 0 and 9. so a similar
thing can be done using a special
sequence backslash small D so as you can
see there will be three matches in this
case because one two and three digits
exist whereas in this case for the word
python there will be no matches
so these are certain examples where we
are doing the same thing using the
backslash d now we have another one
which is the backslash capital D and
this is just basically the opposite it
matches for any non-decimal digits it's
also equivalent to typing a carrot
inside uh square brackets with 0-9 which
if you remember from the previous video
is basically asking us to check for
anything that is not the digit 0 to 9.
so this is basically we're going to
check these two strings if there is no
digits no non-decimal digits so if you
see here we will we will find three
matches a b and the uh double double
inverted commas and in the second string
we will find no matches because this is
fully just digits next we have backslash
small s now this matches where a string
contains any white space character so
this is equal to doing a check for all
of these so this is like backslash small
T is a check for tab space backslash
small N is a check for break line and
then backslash R backslash F backslash V
uh are their own uh checks for different
sorts of white space characters that you
can see by just looking it up honestly
but yeah so if you simply do a backslash
s it would actually be the equivalent of
searching for any of these uh whites
Place White space characters that we
generate
so if you see here when we do a
backslash s on this string you can see
that there is one space over here so it
will match it will give us one match
because there is one white space which
is just the normal space here and in the
second example there is no match because
there is no white space here
similarly slash capital S now as you
might have noticed is basically checking
for a string which does not matches in a
string wherever there is no white space
characters so it's basically the same as
doing carrot slash T slash n slash r
slash F slash V in a square brackets so
this is basically a simpler way of doing
uh the same thing using square brackets
and a carrot symbol so if you see this
expression backslash capital S now we're
looking at a space b so over here if you
see it will match for all the non-spaces
so it's going to match for a and b so
we're going to get two matches here
whereas an empty string does not contain
well it does not contain any non-white
space character since an empty string is
basically a white space character on its
own so this will be this will give us a
no match so the next special sequence
that we're going to look at is the
backslash small W uh this matches any
alphanumeric character which is the
equivalent of doing a to z in small and
then capital A to Z and 0 to 9 for and
also an underscore check in square
bracket tickets it's important to note
that the underscore is considered an
alpha memory character hence why we
included over here but yeah this is this
uh backslash W uh small W which
basically checks for uh any alphanumeric
character and matches it in a string so
if you see in this first case
um it will find three matches at one two
and also at the letter c these others
are not alphanumeric characters whereas
in this string none of these are
alphanumic characters we will get no
match again much like the other examples
there is a capital there's a backslash
capital W which will check for any
non-alphanumeric character and it's the
equivalent of doing whatever we did
before in uh in the square brackets just
with a preceded by a carrot sign so if
you see here we have the string where we
have a bunch of characters well yeah
only one of them this uh this percentage
symbol is a non-alphanumeric character
so we will get much one match over here
but in this case in this string python
we will get no matches because they are
all alphanumeric characters which is
doing the same thing here with a bunch
of different examples using the find all
function now the backslash capital Z
matches if the specified characters are
at the end of a string now don't confuse
this with the backslash small B because
the back is a small B checks for a
string and it checks each and every word
in the string individually and checks if
so if any of the words ends with a
particular thing or or starts with a
particular thing but it checks each word
individually but in this case the
backslash capital Z will check the
string only and not each word so if you
see the difference here in an um when
you use Capital backslash capital Z it
will match in this first example but it
won't match for the next two but if you
use the backslash small B over here it
would actually match and not only in the
first example here but it will also
match in the second example because it
would check this word individually and
it will find out that yeah there is a
match here as well so it would actually
match in the second example as well in
this video we will be covering the topic
of closures now before we understand
what a closure is we have to understand
what is a nested function and non-local
variables now a function which is inside
another function is known as a nested
function nested functions are able to
access variables of the enclosing scope
so if I Define this function called
outer function where I pass some
argument called text and I store that in
a variable called text again and if I
create a function within this collinear
function and I want to print whatever
this variable is in text when I execute
this it will be able to access this
variable because it's within the
enclosing scope so if I said outer
function here this gets stored in the
variable text and then the inner
function will print that variable which
is basically the string here
as you can see here
now inner function can easily be
accessed inside the outer function body
but not outside of its body so here
inner function is treated as a nested
function which uses text this this
variable text as the non-local variable
now a closure is a function object that
remembers values in enclosing Scopes
even if they are not present in memory
it is a record that stores a function
together with an environment it's a
mapping basically that Associates each
free variable of the function which are
basically variables that are used
locally but are defined in enclosing
scope with the value or reference to
which the name was bound when the
closure is created a closure which is uh
which unlike a plane function allows the
function to access those captured
variables till the closures copies of
their values or references even when the
function is invoked outside the scope so
let's look at an example to emphasize on
what uh what was just said so again I've
created amplify this function out of
function where I'm doing the same thing
now I've defined the same inner function
where I'm going to print the same thing
now it's very important that when I
return over here what I'm going to
return is inert function but it's not
going to be a function call this is
important to create our closure so we
return in our function but with without
um using the call as we do over here
and what this return will do is
basically to create the enclosure sorry
the closure where the inner function
will remember the values of the
variables stored in the enclosing scope
so now I'm going to store this outer
function in an object called my in a
variable called my function now when I
call this my function you can see there
there'll be two things that are
happening here so once I've defined this
and I've executed this
what happens out here is this function
has already executed and then I'm
storing it to this but because I've done
return inner function without
parenthesis I've created a closure
basically and this closure allows the
inner function to remember the values
that were stored in text at any point at
and at every Point even after the
execution of this fun time so when I
execute this again for the second time
over here it will remember the value
that was stored in the variable text
which is hey which was which was given
over here that's why you see when I
execute it for the second time over here
the first time being in this line when
I'm storing it in my function when I
execute in the second time again it
would give me the result of hey
as you can see the closures have to
invoke functions outside the scope the
function error function has a scope only
inside the outer function but with the
user closures we can extend its scope to
invoke a function outside the scope so
now let's look at this code so this code
don't worry about what's going on here
just know that what we are doing here is
we have two functions which we Define
called add X and Y which will return X
Plus Y and the subtract function which
will subtract X and Y so now we're going
to execute these once we are going to
execute the add over here and add logger
and we're going to execute the subtract
function and we're going to store it in
sublogger so technically we have already
executed these two functions but now
since I've created an X an enclosure
basically uh if you see here this is the
enclosure that I have created now what
happens is
when I access this function from outside
its initial scope which is basically
over here this was the initial Scope
when I access it outside you will see
that it it is it still has access to
these variables X and Y so if you see
here I I first of all I've allowed this
uh this the enclosing function to accept
uh arguments of any numbers so I can
pass X Y I can pass x y z also but if
you see here I only have a thing for X
and Y so
when I want to access any value of X and
Y even after the execution of this code
initially I have access to these
variables X and Y and that is because
I've created a closure out of that so if
you see if I do add logger 3 and 3 over
here I'm able to get the result 6. if I
do add logger 4 and 5 I'm able to get
the result 9 similarly for subtraction
logger 10 and 5 I will get 5 here and 20
and 10 I'll get 10 here and I can keep
doing this I can keep saying ad logger
in fact if I say 4 and 7 so if I
executed this and now I'm going to say
let's say for example add logger if I
set 4 and 7 here
so this still has access to my variables
X and Y because I've created the closure
and it should give me 11. similarly if I
did sub logger say 30 and 15 it should
give me 15 because 30 minus 15. so let's
say 30 minus 16 right so it should give
me 14 because again I have created the
closure and it has access to these
variables already in this video we will
be learning about the concept of Lambda
functions now a Lambda function in
Python is an anonymous function without
a name we usually use Lambda functions
whenever we want to create a a function
type object for for a short period of
time a Lambda function is defined using
the Lambda keyword like a normal
function is defined using the def
keyword we Define a Lambda function
using the Lambda keyword also the Lambda
function can take any number of
arguments but it can only accept one
expression as a part of it so think of a
Lambda function like a sort of a a
temporary function object that you
create whenever you want to perform a
particular task or object but you don't
want to give it a name or you don't want
to define a full full-blown function and
give it a name like that so over here
I'm going to give you an example of a
Lambda function let's say that this
Lambda function takes in let's call it X
and so you define the function let's
call it X let's call it a Lambda
function using this keyword now we want
say two parameters right
by saying say A and B or two arguments
in A and B so we're going to pass two
arguments A and B whenever we call use
this function and we're going to perform
some sort of an expression now let's
write down a simple arithmetic
expression for this once you've defined
your arguments
you just use the colon now over here we
have our expression so let's call it a
plus b so now we've created a Lambda
function called X where uh we will pass
two arguments and the result will be the
expression a plus B A Plus A and B being
the arguments we pass
so now let's print the result of
um let's say we pass one and three so
now we should get the result 4 right
because a plus b is equal to 4 so we
passed a as 1 B is 3 now let's execute
this as you can see the result is for
similarly you can pass any number of
arguments so we want to call some
function X
um let's say Lambda function and we say
um a
B and C the same and we want to do the
product of these three arguments
so now when we do when we check the
result let's say we're doing the product
of two four and six so this should be 48
and when you execute this you get 48 as
you can see here so these are two simple
examples of a Lambda function now I
could have done this
um in a different way where I could have
defined some function X and over here I
Define that it takes in three parameters
and then you can Define some say return
the function basically returns you a
product B product C but many a times you
don't need to define a full function
called X you don't you don't want to
assign some function with this name you
just want to create a temporary or a
short time Anonymous function with some
name just to perform a simple expression
and in that case we can use Lambda
functions that's an example by the way
you can use Lambda functions in multiple
places so let's move on now
now uh for the sake of this video what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
how the sorted function works and we're
going to learn how the Lambda function
uses this sorted function how they work
together so this will give you a clearer
understanding of how we use the Lambda
function in our code so to start off
sorted function returns a sorted list
from the items in an interval so you can
have a bunch of for example numbers and
the sorted function by default will give
you uh will return you the list of
numbers in an ascending order of course
you can also using a parameter called
reverse you can you can you can return a
list of numbers in the descending order
you can also do this for Strings uh I
mean characters so if you give it a
bunch of characters say a e f g in the
uh in the alphabet it will give you if
you use a sorted function it will give
you the characters it will return it in
an ascending or descending order
depending on the parameter you give so
basically this uh the sorted function
the syntax is you use the keyword sorted
then you pass the iterable which is
basically some some list or some Tuple
then you give it a key so this key
sometimes we don't need to give by
default if the iterable is does not
contain um multiple uh multiple items
per object for like if it's not a tuple
of multiple objects if it's not a list
of tuples for example you don't need to
give it a key if it's a simple list of
numbers you don't necessarily need to
give a key if you want to sort it but
yeah a key is basically the parameter
which we use to tell the sorted function
that we want to sort based on something
which is going to be the key in this
case finally the third parameter is
reverse which basically just tells us
that if we want to sort in the default
ascending order or if we say reverse
true then we will sort in the descending
order now let's look at some examples so
I have this list over here
and I'm going to print this list
so uh this list is obviously a bunch of
vowels
e-a-u-o-i and this is not in the
ascending order of the the alphabet
right like you we know it as a e i o u
if I print the sorted form of this list
it should give me a e i o u a list with
aeio in the ascending order
sorry yeah
so now as you can see
um it's given me this list as you can
see here similarly if um I gave it a
string a string as you know is an
iterable it's a collection of characters
so if I use a sorted function on this
interestingly it will give me a list of
these individual characters like p y t h
o and n but in the order that we want it
to be in which is the ascending order of
course so if I print this you can see it
returns me the list with each character
in the order that we wanted it to be in
now you might notice why does p come
before H that's because this is in
uppercase so what this does is first it
uh sorts all the uppercase characters uh
since there's only one so it just places
in the first uh object of this list and
then it sorts all the lowercase
characters that you see here so yeah
moving on now now what if we wanted to
say um sort this in descending order so
we have this list and now we want to
sort this in a descending order so in
that case we have to give the parameter
reverse and we have to assign the value
true so once we do this now when we
execute this you can see we have the
return as the same list but in the
opposite order so that's how the reverse
parameter works now let's uh try to
understand how we use the key function
or the key parameter in the sorted
function now of course if you if you
want to sort something based on some key
that we want to Define we use the key
parameter so let's take an example now
so in this example what we have done is
I've defined this function called take
second so what this does is it it simply
it takes the second element of a list of
tuples so what is this list of tuples
well this is random you can see this
random this is a list of tuples so this
is one Tuple this is the next Tuple and
what I'm going to do is in this example
I'm going to create a key out of every
second element in each Tuple so I'm
going to create a key out of 20 40 10
and 13 and based on these in an
ascending order I will sort this whole
list so my what my result should be is
that since the smallest of the uh every
second object in these tuples is 10 so
this will be my first object in the my
sorted list then it should be the one
with 13 because this is the next highest
number so then this will be the next
object similarly this will be the next
object then this will be the whole next
object so you see I'm using every second
element of the Tuple as my key and for
that to create a key basically
um I'm creating this function which will
basically return every
um it will iterate through all of these
and it will return uh each of the second
elements so um let's actually uh let's
actually do this now so what I have here
is
I am going to create a sorted list which
is going to use a sorted function on
this iterable which is a bunch which is
a list of tuples it's called random now
my key is going to be take second so
this sorted function is actually very
dynamic in the sense
um I don't I don't exactly have to
create a list directly each of these
objects present in the tuples I just
have to Define if I can even pass a
function in the parameter for key and it
will apply this function on the interval
that we pass over here which is random
namely and it will use this function to
generate Keys uh generate a key out of
each second element and based on that it
will do the sorted it will perform the
sorted function so now
if I check
what's my sorted list
you will see
that as I had mentioned now it's using
the second object so the second uh each
each second object of the Tuple as the
key so since 10 is the smallest this
whole object is the first object then 13
so we have this object here and then so
on and so forth so this is how we've
used a key to do the Sorting function a
key that we've defined on our on our own
now similarly we can use multiple Keys
as well so just to quickly go over
through this uh we have this
um some some list where a bunch of names
a bunch of tuples you can see right
tuples with three objects each within it
each first one is always always a string
denoting someone's name some students
name
um the second is the marks out of 100
and the third is their age so what we
have here is what we want to do is we
want to sort this uh these tuples uh in
the order of first marks and in case the
marks are clashing or they are the same
basically we will sort by the age so
what we want to do is we want to First
sort by these marks as you can see here
but in case the Clash for example like
say this 75 and 75 they're the same
marks in that case we want to sort it by
the age which is 12 and 20 which is
different so in this case we're going to
use two keys one the first key will be
given the highest priority and then if
there is a clash then we use the second
key so how do we do this now let's
define some function like uh how we
Define this take second function here
this will be our function that we will
pass to the key this function basically
what it does is it gives us uh who has
the highest marks now since we are
creating and uh since the key works in
an ascending order so um the smallest
object in a key is the first object that
gets returned right so what we're going
to do is we're going to return the error
which is basically the difference
between
um 100 which is the total marks and the
marks that student gets so this is how
we obtain a ascending order in our list
which is what we which which basically
is what we want because we want the
highest marks to be first so we do 100
minus item one item one is basically the
first object or whatever it triple we
pass in this case it would be the the
first objects of each Tuple which is the
marks secondly We performed age age is
the item two which is yeah each second
object of each Tuple now what we return
in this function is uh like this is
going to be our key now a list of errors
and there is a list of age error being
the marks error the difference between
100 and the marks you obtain so now what
it's going to do is it's going to take
the marks as the first key and the age
as the second key when we pass this to a
sorting function
so if you skip this you don't have to
look at this but if you look at this now
we have the sorted list which is going
to be the result of the sorted function
on top of what we pass which is the
participant list now we're going to use
the key we're going to use the key as
the sorter function so we're going to
use this order function as a key and
when we print if you see
we get let me just execute all of this
so if you see here in this section what
you can see is we have the highest marks
first then the second then the third but
if you see here there's a clash this guy
and this guy have the same Mark 75 so
now what we want to do is the guy who
has a younger age should be in the first
in the object so that is how this has
happened because we passed two keys
error and the age so when The Clash in
error key happened we went to the ah key
and then we did ascending order on that
and then finally the rest of the objects
that you can see here so now that we
have seen how the sorted function works
now let's look at how the Lambda
function Works using this sorted
function which was the main goal of this
video right so let's see
so now some of you might have figured
out where this Lambda function will be
used right so whenever we were using the
key in the sorted function we had to
define a function and then we would pass
that function as the key so as some of
you may have figured this out what we're
going to do using the Lambda function is
we're going to skip that process of
defining a function with a new name and
all that and we're going to pass a
Lambda function we're going to use a
Lambda function as the key so let's see
how we do it so initially what we've
done is we've created this list this
list is a list of dictionaries that you
can see so this first object is a
dictionary second object is a dictionary
each dictionary contains two keys the
name and the age and the values are
something like nandini the values for
age is like 20 20 and 19. so we have
three dictionaries in a list so what
we're going to do is we want to print
what we what we want to do with this we
want to print the these objects or these
dictionaries
in an ascending order of age so we want
obviously we want this to be first and
then this and this because 19 is smaller
than 20. so let's see how we do this
so if you go here
what we're going to do is we're going to
print the sorted the sorted function or
the uh the result of the sorted function
being applied on this list so this is
awaitable now if you see here in the key
the key parameter we don't we don't
predefine a function and pass it over
here instead we use the Lambda and this
Lambda function is defined in such a way
so we say Lambda it will take one
argument I and then it will return
basically the age index for some I and
this I is we we're going to presume an i
to be some sort of an iterable which has
an index called age and which is uh
which is the case in our case right we
have a bunch of dictionaries where there
is a key in each of these dictionaries
called age so we're going to use that
and now we are going to ask like what is
I well when we use the Lambda function
in the sorted function this I will
basically be each object that we get
when we iterate upon this list so we're
going to iterate first on this so it's
going to take this dictionary and is
going to search for the age then it's
going to take this it's going to search
for the age then it's going to take this
and it's going to search for the age and
each of the time it will pull out what
is the value for each of these age
keywords or these age indexes or age
keys and out of these objects so 20 20
and 19 or these values we're going to
create a key with which we're going to
sort each object in this whole list okay
so this is how the Lambda function will
work here so let's do this so as you can
see our sorted list now contains this
object first because a 19 is small stage
and then this and this now you might see
that there are two twenties so how do we
control which one comes first well by
default it will um that it will just uh
give us the result in the way we passed
it in the original list so since nandini
came before manjit in the result also
nandini will come before majeed but what
if he wanted to sort it even more what
if we want to sort it in such a way that
first we go by age and the second key
will tell us that if there is a clash in
ages we have to go alphabetically by the
name so in this case we will create a
second key and how we do that
well if you go to this step
over here what we're doing is we're
doing the same sorted function but now
the Lambda will again take one parameter
which is I which is going to be each
itro which which is going to be each
object in this iterable list and we're
going to take two keys so the first key
will be the ah key and the second key
will be the name so it will first sort
on age and then on name so now if you
see
um the result should be that manjit will
come before nandini even though the ages
are 20 because M comes before n in the
alphabet as you can see this is the
result
now if we wanted to do the same thing
but in a descending order all we have to
do is after this key parameter we have
to give another parameter called reverse
and we have to give it true
so if we did this now you see this this
uh or if we do it on this one
it'll be more clear
now if I execute this basically this
whole uh whatever result we get will be
backwards now
oh wait I did not enter it in the sorted
function
so this should come within the sorted
function over here
so now if we execute this you will see
nandini comes first manjit comes second
and then nickel comes third because
we've done the reverse I will use the
reverse keyword as true reverse
parameter is true in this video we will
be covering the topics of map filter and
reduce functions in Python now python
provides several functions that enable
functional approach to programming and
since functional programming is all
about Expressions some of these
expression oriented functions of python
are Lambda functions list comprehensions
map filter map filter and reduce now
we've already covered the topic of
Lambda and list comprehensions now let's
cover the topics of map filter and
reduce
so to start off let's look at the map
function the map function takes in two
attributes a function and a sequence a
function is basically some defined some
user defined function or any function a
sequence is basically an iterable object
like a list or a tuple for example or a
bunch of lists and tupacles as well so
let's look at an example so one of the
most common operations that we do with
something like a list is doing an
operation on each of the elements in the
list and then outputting a new list with
the the values as whatever we have
modified to the original items of the uh
list so we what if we did the square of
all of these items in this list and we
we want to create a list based on that
so we can basically iterate through it
and we can do a square function and then
append those values to a new list called
squared and when we do this for example
over here you can see when we print
squared
we should get the list of whatever
Square values we have for the original
list but this is uh slightly a bit
tedious and what if we had a method that
or a
what if we had a a technique wherein we
could um
basically pass a function that we have
that we want to do and a sequence on
which we want to apply this and we pass
it to a function and this function
basically takes care of
um applying whatever operations we want
to do on each element of a sequence so
as this is where the map function comes
in use so let's look at how we use the
map function over here so if you look at
this I have defined a square function so
the square function basically returns or
takes an argument X and Returns the
square of it and I have a map function
which takes the square function as one
of the arguments and the I the list or
an iterable as the second argument so
this map function creates a map object
if you see here so let's just do it one
by one so I'm creating my list and I'm
going to create my function called
Square and I'm going to
send this to the map function so I'm
sending this uh the first argument as
the function that I want to do and the
second argument as the list that I want
to apply it on now let's list out all
the items that are in this map object
so if you see it creates me a list with
basically the squared items and this is
exactly what we needed and another way
of doing the same thing would be just
going through a for Loop in each of the
map objects and printing each which
would give me the same results so if you
see here I found a very neat way of
passing a function at an iterable and
using the map function to apply each
operation that is part of the function
or applying the function on each item in
the iterable so as you've seen we
basically passed in a user defined
function and we applied it to each item
in the list then the map calls the
square function on each list item and
collects all the return values into a
new list and because map expects a
function to be passed in it also happens
to be one of the places where Lambda
functions are appearing a lot so let's
look at the an example where we do the
same operation using a Lambda function
so if you see here I have a Lambda
function where I am passing it as the
function argument and what this Lambda
function takes is some variable X or
some argument X it does its square and
it returns at X and this x is basically
going to come from each element that is
present in this list called items and
when we list down these you will see it
basically does the same thing for us it
creates this list with squared items now
we can also pass instead of passing an
interval itself we can actually pass a
sequence of functions and use the Lambda
function to perform a sequence of
functions on particular items so let's
look at a new example a slightly
different one so we're going to use a
numpy module for this don't worry we're
just using it to use the square root
function that is present in the numpy
power module we will be learning about a
Buy in a later section so we're going to
import this first and now I'm going to
Define three functions cos Square Cube
and square root so once I've defined
this basically they are returning the
square the cube root uh the cube and the
square root of some integer X and now
I'm going to create a list of these
functions that you've just seen and
we're going to use a for Loop and we're
going to iterate through a range from 0
to 4. and we're going to pass this
and we're going to say that we're going
to apply
some some function we want to apply some
function X and we want to return that
using the snapdraw function now what
values this x will take is based on
whatever functions we've stored in this
variable called Fu and CS or funks and
in funcs we have a bunch of functions
called Square Cube and square root that
we have defined earlier so what we're
going to do is we're going to apply each
of these functions to R and R will take
the value 0 to 4 and now let's see when
we print this what values we get so if
you see here we get a list of square
root squares cubes and square roots for
integer 0 1 2 3 and 4. so this is
another way of using the map function
and Lambda functions together to apply
multiple different operations to a bunch
of iterables
now for our next example what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
function that basically what it does is
it creates the uppercase of some string
that we pass to it right so that's what
we've done here in this function called
two uppercase so if let's first Define
this function now we have a print
function basically which is going to
print each object in a particular which
is going to prevent each element of a
particular object and it's going to at
the end of it and the end of printing
we're going to give a small space for
printing a new line basically so let's
create this also this print it editor
object now what we're going to do is
we're going to pass a string with the
letters a b and c to this function and
we're going to map and we're going to
apply the uppercase function to this
string now if you remember string is
also an iterable where it's a sequence
of one character strings so this whole
string is basically a sequence of one
character string a one character string
B and C so we're going to so we can pass
a string as a as an iterable to the map
function because it will apply the
operations on each of these characters
so let's see what happens when we do the
uppercase function uh we apply the
uppercase function using the map using
mapping to this string a b and c
so if you see it's created me a list
with a capital a capital B and capital c
as we had expected because we have
applied the list function to the map
object now in The Next Step what we're
going to do is we're going to do a very
similar thing we're just going to
instead of Simply mapping and creating a
list out of it we're going to store the
map object in a variable called map
iterator we're going to print what type
of object it is and then we're going to
print out each of the elements using the
print iterator function that we defined
here so let's do this now if you see the
class the type of object is of class map
and the objects elements inside the
object are a b and c Moving On Let's uh
let's look at now an example where we're
going to pass multiple arguments so
instead of one iterable we're going to
pass multiple iterables now and we're
going to apply some sort of an operation
so if you see here what we have done is
we've created Tool uh two two sequences
one is a list of some numbers and
another is a tuple of some numbers so
just to show you let me first copy this
here
um yeah so if you see here I have a list
and it you pull and I'm passing both of
these if you see to this map function
and before that I have defined a Lambda
function as the operation that I'm going
to apply and what this does is it takes
two arguments X and Y and it Returns the
product of both of these uh where does
it get X and Y from so the X it gets
from this uh this sequence which is a
list and it takes y from this sequence
which is a tuple so what it's going to
do is going to take X as 1 and then Y is
5 in the first step and it's going to
return the product S5 and then the next
step is going to take 2 as X and then y
as 6 and it's going to return the
product of that and we're going to get
12 and so on we're going to get 21 and
then 32.
um when we did and this is these values
are going to be stored in the map
iterator which is a map type object and
when we use the print dictator function
it's basically going to print out
whatever results we got through this
mapping so let's execute this and as you
can see this is the result we got 5 12
21 and 32 which is what we wanted so the
next part the next function that we're
going to discuss is the filter function
now now my filter function is basically
again it takes two two arguments a
function and a sequence and a function
basically tests if each element of a
sequence is true or not now a sequence
the sequence
um so this filter function will
basically take two arguments so one is
the function and this function is
basically going to test if each element
of a sequence is true or not and it's
going to take another argument called
sequence and this argument sequence is
the list or the Tuple or basically any
sequence and or iterable that needs to
be filtered and it can be as I mentioned
it can be sets less tuples or containers
of more iterators and what this function
will return is an iterator that is
already filtered um so let's look at an
example now so we have this list R which
you generated which is basically numbers
from -5 to 4. so if I create this list
here you can see it will create a list
of minus five to four now if I wanted to
extract only the values that are lesser
than 0 well I can use a for Loop and use
a if condition to check this right so if
I did this over here you can see it
gives me it returns me some list called
result which contains only the values
lesser than zero which is basically
check through this condition what if
there was a
neat or a more convenient or a more
organized approach to doing the same
thing instead of creating a loop
ourselves what if we defined a function
where we are going to do the test or we
are going to create the condition and
we're going to pass this to a particular
function and then apply that particular
operation on every object of some
sequence well just like mapping we have
a filter function to do this and in this
example what we're going to use is the
Lambda function which takes an argument
X and it checks for some condition X
lesser than 0 and where it's going to
get the X from is some sequence R which
which in our case is the numbers from -5
to 4 and the filter will basically
create a filter object type which
contains uh only the objects from r that
meet this condition that is X is lesser
than 0 and when we use the list
operation on top of it you will see it
creates it results in a list with the
values that have met my condition so for
a second example what we're going to do
is we're going to create a list which
contains a bunch of letters and we're
going to only extract the vowels from
these bunch of letters so let's look at
what we have here we have some letters d
a t j k o p l and we only want the
vowels from this so we want to filter
only the vowels so we can use that using
the filter function by first word
defining a function that returns true if
a check is met that
one of uh the letter matches one of
these letters in this list called
letters and if it doesn't it returns
false so this is our condition that
we've created once we create this
condition uh this function that checks
this we can pass this function and the
sequence into the filter function and
then we can list out whatever we get so
you can see our filtered list contains
only a and o which is basically the only
vowels that are present in our original
list
finally we have the reduce function this
reduce function is basically a func
tools it's in the func tools module of
python 3.0 and what the reduce function
does is it applies a function of two
arguments cumulatively to the elements
of an iterable and it optionally it
starts with an initial argument and it
returns a single result so let's first
import this function
and once we've imported it let's use it
in this example that we have here so in
this example what we're going to do is
we have some list called numbers right
what if we wanted to get the sum of each
element in this list well we can iterate
over it and store it in some variable
called total in each step right
um this is what we would typically
typically do and in this step what you
can see is the loop basically iterates
over every valuable in numbers and
accumulates them in total the final
result is the sum of all the values
which is the value of 10 over here in
this example the variable total is what
we call an accumulator and we can apply
the reduce function to do the same task
so how do we do it let's first of all
create a function called my ad where
we're going to take two variables uh two
arguments and we're going to return the
sum of it okay so let's define this
function and now we have we have a list
called numbers right which contains one
two three and four now let's do reduce
my add to numbers
now when I do this when I use this
function what it will do is it will
apply the function of my ad it will take
basically each and every element uh in a
sequence so it will take one and two
then add them together and then it will
create basically what it will do is it
will take one and two add them together
then we'll have three so it'll take
three and then the next element which is
3 again so it will create the sum which
is 6 and then it will take six and then
it will take the value 4 and it will
give us the result 10. so this is how
the reduce function would work so this
is how it will give us the result of 10.
as you can see here I've simply used
I've passed this function where I've
defined that I want two argument to be
passed to a function and then the return
should be basically the sum and then a
pass table list of like four numbers and
I've used a reduced function to
basically do this process for four
numbers in a step-by-step manner by
taking two at a time subsequently and my
result is as you can see is correct as
you can see here
so let's use the Lambda function now to
do the same topic just do the same task
so what I'm doing now is I'm going to
define a Lambda function and that's the
function I'm going to pass to this
reduce so when I pass this Lambda
function which basically takes two two
arguments X and Y and it's going to
return the sum of that as X Plus y now
where it's going to get X and Y from is
in a very in a very neat manner so it
will take first the first two elements
one and two it will then do the sum and
we get three then it will take the same
three and then take the next object
which is three again and then give us 6
then it will take six and then the next
element which is 4 and then give us 10
and then the reduce function will output
the the single result which is 10 to us
as you can see here
in this video we will be covering a sort
of a project side type of scenario which
is basically going to be a problem case
for you and it's going to be slightly
slightly difficult slightly tricky but
what we're going to do is we're going to
tackle a particular problem and we're
going to what I'm going to do is also
show you a solution to that problem
so let's start with this so this
question that we have is we have this
program that we have to write where we
compute the frequency of words that
exist in some input okay the program
should output after sorting the key
alphanumerically now this input can be
and it's basically a block of text right
so in our example we have um for example
if this was our input right what we want
to see is an output which is basically
saying that the word python has appeared
say well in this example it's appeared
five times and then the word read has
appeared one time and so on and so forth
like for each of these words we want to
see um how many times have they appeared
in this project particular block of text
so let's look at a particular example
now where we have done this so let's um
let's see here
so first of all I'm going to create a
dictionary so why am I creating a
dictionary is because I'm going to use
each unique word as a key and the number
of times they have appeared in a block
of text as the value to that key so um
I'm going to use a sample string which
is basically this long string that you
can see here which is stored in line so
this large chunk of text is what we're
going to be analyzing so how are we
going to do this it's pretty simple so
we have this now what we want to do is
um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here is we want to
um check word by word first of all we
want to see if it's a unique word and if
this word is before I encountered it for
the first time then we need to store a
new key in our dictionary called
frequent table or frequency table and if
it has already if there is a key already
with that particular name then we just
want to increment the count or the value
by one so let's see how we do this over
here so if you can see in my this the
solution is as simple as this but if you
see what's happening it's basically what
uh what it's doing is we're splitting up
this string uh using the split function
what this will do is it will split up
the string at every white space so it
will take this as one part I'll take
this part as another part it will create
an iterable with each word as the um
each iterable object in that container
so it's going to be a list of words like
python is one so on and so forth and
we're going to go one by one so we're
going to say forward in line dot split
now if this word is if it exists in
frequency table as a key then what we're
going to do is we're just going to
increase the count of the value of that
key by one but if it does not exist then
we're going to actually create a key
with the word as that unique word and
we're going to create its value
initialize its value to 1
so let me execute this
now if we want to once you've done this
we can sort it by the count of the words
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a another Tuple called sort of
tuples where we're going to use the
Lambda function out here uh to sort the
dictionary in terms of its values so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take the key the key being the Lambda
item item with index one index one is
basically the value so a particular key
has a value so the word python appears
so many times the word say scientist
appears so many times so we're going to
check which words have the highest
number of occurrences and we're going to
sort it in a descending order so that
that is basically what the reverse is
equal to True does so when we're going
to sort this when we are going to use
the sorted function when we say reverse
true it tells the sortic function to
sort this dictionary this dictionary
frequency table uh in terms of value
by the the descending order so whichever
word appears highest that would be the
first word in our uh sorted Tuple so
that's what we do in this slide and once
we execute this we're also going to
print so if you see the result of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word machine appears six times
learning appears six times then python
appears 510 and so on and so forth so
we've created a sorted Tuple where the
first object of the Tuple we've created
a list of sorted tuples where the first
object of the two each Tuple is the
unique word the second one is the number
of times it has appeared in this
particular example or this particular
string so yeah this was the first basic
project that we have tackled in this you
might have seen some examples of how we
do list operations and how we use the
Lambda function in sorting the
dictionary by the values of the key in
this video we will continue with what we
started in in terms of our project
number one what we're going to do is
we're going to tackle another slightly
complicated
um
a question or a situation we're going to
try to arrive at a solution so in this
what we have is some sort of a robot a
moving robot which moves on a Cartesian
plane a two coordinate plane
um is going to move in terms of up down
left and right okay and each each time
it moves up or down or left or right it
takes a certain number of steps in that
direction
um integral steps of course so what we
need to do is from a starting position
whatever its starting position is which
we are going to take as 0 comma 0 in
this example we're going to make it move
to a particular location with the
commands up down left and right followed
by certain steps and we're going to ask
what we're going to do is we're going to
calculate the distance between these two
points
um and we're going to calculate
different types of distances so you
might be introduced to New Concepts
um you know a distance Concepts in this
video as well so what we're going to be
using for distance calculation is the
minkowski district and that is we're
going to take so the minkowski distance
between two variables is basically the
absolute difference between these two
variables so these two points and we
take it to the power of something so if
we want to say uh calculate the
minkowski distance with in terms the
quadratic main cause citizens with
basically P2 so we are going to do x i
minus y i absolute difference to the
power 2 and then we're going to take the
second root of it after summing each and
every point so when we take p is equal
to 2 we we say the minkowski distance
behaves like the euclidean distance so
this is probably one of the most common
distances uh in case you've done basic
uh Cartesian geometry when you are asked
to find the distance between two points
on a plane
um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the absolute distances between
each point no roots no power is nothing
basically p is equal to one and because
that demand hat in distance so we're
going to take p is equal to 1 to n 3 in
each case and we're going to find the
distance between two points based on
these
measures so
this is just a visual representation
this is basically the eagle in
resistance basically the estimate of the
value between these two points if um
since this is a two coordinate system
whereas the Manhattan distance would be
the absolute distance in terms of if we
go up and then we go right between these
two like save this first and this was
another point so yeah let's move on to
the problem in this particular example
we are going to start from the starting
position 0 and 0 on a on a graph and we
are going to give the commands of up
five down three left three and right two
so first of all what we want to do is we
initialize the starting position as 0
and 0 and we also just for the sake of
this example we initialize the end
position as 0 and 0. so what we're going
to do first of all is let's execute this
much now we have this list list of
tuples
um it's we're going to call this actions
and this is the actions that we're
performing so the this the each Tuple
contains an action and the number of
steps in that direction so it contains
four actions up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps right by
two steps so now we're going to iterate
over this each Tuple and we're going to
get the direction first of all in this
line
um for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell
um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by this line and
we're going to find out the number of
steps in that direction which is stored
in this line so
once you've gotten this for each action
we have to update the end position right
so what happens is if you go up by a
particular direction so you are
basically changing the y y axis right
the the y-axis so we're going to change
end position and the first index which
is basically this part of the end
position coordinate point so we're going
to say if it's moving by up then we're
going to uh update by adding uh the
y-axis by the number of steps so
um and and if the direction is down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x axis right so we take n
position in the first index so we take
the x axis and if we're moving left it's
a negative uh it's a decrement and if
you're moving right it's an increment so
if there's any other like action like
any other action for example that was
given here we say pass so basically the
only valid
actions that we can pass is um up down
left and right otherwise we we just skip
that particular action so this is what
the this particular Loop will do it will
update our final position
so once we've done this if we if I
execute this what will get stored in the
end position is basically my end
position so now that I have my starting
position and my end position
um just to show you what the end
Position will look like right now let's
just do this so if you see here after
I've moved up by five steps down by
three steps left by three steps and then
right by two steps my final end position
is minus one and two
um my start position on the other hand
was
as you remember it should be 0 and 0. it
is 0 and 0. so now we're going to find
the distance between 0 and 0 and -1 and
2. so we're going to first of all create
a function called minkowski distance
which which does a basic function of
just calculate the uh the difference
between the what do you say um the end
position x coordinate and the N position
y coordinate times uh or to the power of
a root and we're basically going to do
this operation that you saw here we're
going to do this and um we're going to
use this root variable to specify to
like P is equal to one two or three like
what P value we want to take for this
minkowski distance so once you've done
this what this function will do is
basically store uh this much and it will
wait for us to uh it will basically wait
for us to give us a root so when we give
root 1 it will create these it will
check the distance between the end and
starting points
um with the p-value of one if we gave it
2 it will calculate euclidean distance
with p-value 2 similarly for three and
we can calculate for any Roots so we're
going to calculate for one two and three
roads and we're going to see what values
we get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 I print the
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1 is something and then root 2 it's
something root 3 is something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually 1.0 but
the euclidean distance between these two
points is 2.23 whereas the uh the cubic
minkowski distance with basically the
with root 3 is 1.91 so you see these
three different uh distance measures for
the same distance between two coins so
in this video you basically so in this
basically by doing this activity you
might must have you will learn how to um
basically how to iterate through loops
and perform these distance calculations
which you'll find pretty handy in many
activities related to data science and
machine learning in this video we will
be continuing tackling different
problems and problem cases in terms of a
project called project three where we're
going to be using regular Expressions to
validate whether certain passwords that
have been entered do they match certain
criterias or not so let's look into our
particular question we have a website
that requires users to input username
and password to register now we have to
write a program to check the validity of
passwords input by the users now the
criterias that the passwords have to
follow are that there is at least one
letter between a and z and one number
between 0 and 9. the third criteria is
that uh there's at least one letter
between capital A and capital c so this
first and third Point basically is
saying that there should be one
lowercase letter and there should be one
uppercase letter now there should be at
least one character from dollar sign
hash or the add simple it should have a
minimum length of 6 and the maximum
length of 12. so when we whatever
passwords that we enter into our example
they must be comma separated so if we're
going to have an input they're going to
ask us for an input where we're going to
have to input the different passwords in
a comma separated way so let's look
let's look at how do we tackle this so
for my example I'm going to use these
examples in terms of these are my
password examples if you're going to
check if these are valid passwords or
not so let's copy this first of all and
now let's import the re which import re
is basically the regular expression
module now in this step is going to ask
us to input the passwords as you can see
here so I will just Ctrl V so since this
is comma separated what it will do is it
will split up each of these uh by the
comma and it will store them in a list
so it will take this as one password
this has another password this has
another password and this has another
password once I press enter
now if I want to check what's in list I
mean what's in items what I can do is
just check over here what's the items
it's a list of whatever passwords I had
entered uh each object is separately
treated now in this list now I'm going
to create a an empty list called value
first of all once I've done that I'm
going to move on to the next step
so once I've created my list called
value what I'm going to do is now I'm
going to search and I'm going to check
for each condition using regular
expressions for whatever criteria that
we have initially so if you see here
what I'm going to do is first iterate by
each item in this to check for each
password now my first check will be a
basic check for the length of the
password if it's lesser than 6 or
greater than 12 then our basically our
password is illegal so we can't be using
this and we will just continue and we
won't check for anything else but if it
is within 6 and 12 the length 6 and 12
then we can continue with our check so
we can do we'll do an else statement for
pass which basically moves on to this
next block
now once you've done this what we will
do is this this first statement what
this is going to do is it's going to do
an re.search and re.search as you know
is going to look for at least one
instance of um
a letter occurring between
um A and Z so this re dot search
followed by this now this is the regular
expression that we have passed and what
this does us is basically the square in
the square brackets we're looking for
anything between uh A and Z in terms of
small letters so if this condition is
not met then again we continue and we
leave this particular search because one
of our criterias is not met all right
but if it is met then this if not
statement will not uh like we we won't
enter this block and we can move on to
the next check so now now we move to L
if not now again we're using if not
statement so this is basically checking
for a negative case so anytime one of
these cases have been met it basically
means that our password has been invalid
because these conditions are not being
met so when we're trying to eliminate
all conditions all of these conditions
so that we get a valid password so again
we move on to the next statement which
is basically going to do the search for
numbers
once again if we find a case a password
without any numbers we continue and we
don't
um check this password no more because
we already know it's a it's a an illegal
password now next check will be for
capital letters a to z and the next
check again will be for these particular
symbols the dollar the hash and the ad
one of these three symbols uh we're
going to search for a white space
character so if we actually do find a
white space character in our password
um that's an illegal password and we're
not going to continue checking for those
cases
so um so this is basically all our cases
lowercase letters numbers capital
letters b is one of these three symbols
and the existence of a white space so
once you've done all these checks if
none of these have been passed we move
on to this else statement where we just
pass and what we can do is we append the
value P to the uh the list call Value so
basically what happens is
um just to go through it again if this
condition is not met and this condition
is not met this is not met this is not
met this is not met and this is also not
met then we're fine so basically as long
as we have small letters as long as we
have a number as long as we have a
capital letter as long as we have one of
these three symbols and as long as we
don't have any uh White space characters
we can append e to this otherwise it
would continue and it will break out of
this for Loop completely that's what the
continued thing the continue statement
at the end of each of these blocks
checks any time this condition is met
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break through this
whole for Loop and we don't append P to
the value but uh if you actually get to
this stage then what we can do is simply
append uh P to value now finally what we
are going to do is uh we are going to
print out all the valid passwords so
just by a quick look you can see here
this is a valid password right so let's
execute this and let's see uh what we
get if you see here we only get one
valid password and let's look at why
some of these do not turn out to be
valid so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number and it has one of the
symbols either dollar sign or the hash
sign or the add sign in this case we
have two white spaces one over here and
one over here so this is an illegal
password similarly in this case also we
have an illegal password because it
begins with a space in this case it's
the same thing we begin with the space
and also it does not have any of those
symbols that we were looking for the
dollar or the hash or the ad so again so
these three are illegal passwords and
they do not get appended to Value
however this does get appended to Value
and that's why we get the result for
only one password which is the only
legal password welcome to web scraping
with python my name is Richard kirschner
with the simply learned team certainly
there are many reasons to be able to go
online and scrape different websites
they range everything from pulling out
different links to pulling data off of
website it's a data scientist you might
need to get some information off a
website that doesn't have a direct API
to pull that information and in Python
we have a wonderful tool when you talk
Python and you talk web scraping we're
talking beautiful suit which is a
package you add into your python that
you're running and we can come over here
to the website
www.crummi.com software beautiful soup
you can actually read a little bit about
it currently beautiful soup 4 is the
current version if you don't remember
the full website for you can always do
what I do which just go over and do a
search for beautiful soup official site
it almost always comes up right at the
top and you click on there and it'll
take you to the crummy.com software site
for beautiful soup now we're going to
use our whatever python interface you
want IDE I'm going to use Jupiter lab
which is built on Jupiter notebook
through Anaconda so when I open up my
anaconda Navigator you'll see that I
have my different tools available again
you might be using a different editor
and that's okay you might be in pie
charm or something like that we don't
need to do this and Jupiter lab is
Jupiter notebook with added tabs and
some added features it's basically in
beta testing so it's got a few little
glitches when you're saving things and
moving between projects but for the most
part it's a great upgrade to the jupyter
notebook and you can use them together
so you don't have to I mean it's built
on jupyter notebooks anything you do in
Jupiter notebook you can open up in
Jupiter lab and the first thing we need
to do is we need to go ahead in this
case I'm going under my environments
since it partitions the environments out
and I'm going to open up a terminal when
though we have to install some packages
in here to work with now there's a lot
of choices on this I because of the
Simplicity we'll be using conda install
now you can use pip install for the same
thing and we're going to install our
beautiful soup 4. you have to type out
the whole thing beautiful soup four and
you can use a pip install if you're
using a different environment and I am
using python version 3.6 although
according to beautiful soup they also
work on three seven all the way from two
seven through all of 3x now according to
the beautiful soup website the Beautiful
4 works on anything you can install
anything from python 2 7 all the way
through any of the Python 3 versions
this just happens to be python36 because
they do it there's a lot of other
packages that don't work on three seven
yet and we'll go ahead and run this
install on here and let it go through
its environmental setup and of course
with conda it goes in there and finds
all the dependencies PIP doesn't do as
much as far as finding dependencies but
you know exactly what's on there with
Pip so if you're doing a huge
distribution you probably want to use
your pip install so you can track what's
going on there with the conda I like to
just let it take over since this isn't a
major distributed package going out
another quick note between pip and conda
is that if you start on a project in one
of these environments and you're using
pip in there stick with Pip if you're
using conda stick with conda they track
the packages and you can run into some
issues where they're not tracking the
same packages and something gets
overwritten so it's important to stay
very consistent with your install on
your environments and we'll also need to
go ahead and install our numpy
environment and our pandas on here so go
ahead and do that if you haven't added
those packages in go ahead and install
those into your environment that you're
working in and of course pandas is just
simply install pandas and let's just
install a couple more packages in this
case let's get our install our map plot
library because we're going to plot at
the end since we're going to be
collecting data and for this project
that will be all the packages we'll need
so we can go ahead and close out of our
installer or whatever setup you have and
we'll go back to home and we'll just
launch our Jupiter lab and that will
open up in our browser window now if
you're coming from Jupiter notebooks the
first time in lab we can go ahead and
just create our first notebook python3
you can also do it under a file launcher
and you'll see new notebook it
automatically opens up and we can just
click right on there it'll pop open on
the left and I'll right click this and
we'll rename this we'll rename it just
beautiful and it is a
ipinb file on there so I should look for
here because that's the Jupiter notebook
file this is a new one now I have
multiple tabs and in the past I usually
hid this on the other computer all my
notes for the lesson today but this is
my notes going down and we'll go ahead
and just start going through this and
see what it looks like to do a data pull
from front to end and see how that works
as a data scientist pulling that
information in from the website and the
first thing I want to do is I want to go
ahead and close the side window that way
it looks get the nice full screen and we
can also up to size a little bit one of
the wonderful things about working in a
browser window just do that control plus
thing the packages we talked about is
pandas so we imported our pan as if you
haven't already that's our data frame if
you haven't done our pandas tutorial
definitely worthy of the time to go
through there and understand pandas
because it's such a powerful tool this
basically turns your data into a
spreadsheet data frame our numpy is our
number array so it kind of works with
pandas very closely as far as
manipulating data in arrays map we want
to go ahead and bring that in our PLT so
that we can plot the data at the end and
this line right here that says matplot
Library inline is for the jupyter
notebook specifically it tells it to
print that on this page a lot of the
newer versions don't actually require to
have that line they'll still print it on
the page we should still include that if
you're in the Jupiter lab setup and then
we have our URL library.request we're
going to import URL open for opening up
the website and then we have our bs4
that's your beautiful soup four we're
going to import beautiful suit and then
our last one is our re that is for
manipulating our regular expression so
when you get to that part of importing
our data we have to do a lot of
reformatting so it's something we can
use and the re is one of those tools
we'll go ahead and run this and just
bring all that in so this is all
imported all these packages are now into
our web scraping program we're going to
run now if we're going to dive in and
pull data we should have a nice website
to pull from and let's go ahead and
we'll use the uppertiming.com results
for the 2018 Martin Luther King race and
if we take this you can actually just
take this where did we get this from
well you can go in here and find the
website you're going to scrape from and
you'll see right here it says you just
copy that link right in there that HTTP
and this is a website that we're looking
at you can see right here all the
information that we're looking at let's
say we wonder to run some statistics on
this it sure would be nice to be able to
pull it off of here and if they don't
have a direct API that means we need to
pull it from their website some of these
will have a download although if you've
ever done a we have a download click and
maybe you're paging through 100 websites
in one case I was pulling all the
different United States bills that are
passed to track who voted on them for a
project and you can imagine that there's
you know hundreds and hundreds of those
thousands of these documents that they
voted on who voted on and it goes to the
Senate goes back to the Congress so I
opened up a website pull all the links
off of there that matched a certain
criteria and we'll look at that in just
a minute how we go through the HTML and
then I had to reformat them or I could
hand download each one one at a time
which would just be a nightmare so it's
nice to automate it in this case we're
going to be pulling up this chart we
want to figure out how to pull this
chart off of this website and so we go
back into our Jupiter notebook I've got
my URL just um our name for it and it's
just a string that's all this is nothing
fancy there you'll notice that on the
slashes we now have forward forward
slash you can do a single forward and
HTTP is a double forward this is just
how you have to switch it to match setup
in there and then it's going to go ahead
and use the HTML equals URL open URL and
that's from our URL Library request so
it's opening a link to that website or
at least pointing to it and if we run
this this just sets it up so this is all
set up and then once we've done our
setup let's go ahead and create an
object called soup this will be and if
you remember up here here's our
beautiful soup that we imported from the
bs4 and this is the package that we're
working with and so we're going to do
our beautiful soup on here and on this
we need to go ahead and send it our HTML
so it knows what it's opening and then
the second part is we have to tell it
how the format is coming in and the most
common one for your HTML polls is an L
XML setup and so almost all of them
you'll end up using the lxml there's a
few other options and because this is so
common uh in the newer versions a lot of
times they just leave it out just
because it's already on the default
we'll go ahead and leave it in here just
to remind us that it's there we'll go
ahead and run that and on the newer
versions uh they actually default it to
the XML setup and the HTML we'll just
leave it out and call it HTML so it's
just going to pull from this URL and
when we run that on here we've now
created an object soup that has pulled
the website into it so soup contains the
information along with information on
that website and what's going on so
let's just go over what we did real
quick before we start digging into the
actual soup before we start scooping out
stuff we imported our different modules
that we're going to use with our package
specifically the beautiful soup we did
install the beautiful soup remember
correctly you have to call it beautiful
soup 4 specifically so it knows what
you're bringing in and this line right
here is very key from bs4 because that's
how it installs the module we're
importing our beautiful soup and then we
found our URL in this case we're going
to go pull information from The Martin
Luther King dream run and then we set
our HTML to our URL open URL and you can
see right here we imported that so
here's our url.request import URL open
so we're requesting a connection and
once we send that connection into the
beautiful soup it creates an object
called suit and then this one of course
we chose soup just because it goes with
beautiful soup I guess we could have
chosen beautiful and now we can start
extracting information from our website
because we've pulled it down onto our
computer under soup now we can start by
looking at the title of the website
soup.title and if we print title dot
text you'll see this a lot in beautiful
soup because title contains all kinds of
information and if we want just the text
from that title you add the dot text on
the end and you can see right here we
have our 2018 MLK dream Run 5K race
results if you look at the tab that's
the actual title up here 2018 MLK dream
Run 5K race that's what the title is on
the website and then you might be
curious what's in title what's the whole
title that it's storing up there well
let's go ahead and print it out here's
print title and print title.txt and when
we run that you can see it has the HTML
tags title on it and then the forward
slash title the end it and so we're
really just pulling off this piece of
the HTML code and then we look at the
text inside that particular part of the
HTML and earlier I mentioned links what
if you want to get all the links off
this page oh that would that would be
fun uh we could do soup Dot and we'll do
find underscore all put this in bracket
and then quotation marks we're going to
put a a is the key find and you'll start
seeing a div and all the different
options you have for finding these
entities in a website and then let's go
ahead and just print our links and you
can see here that it now shows all the
different links in here that are marked
by eggs we did to find all a and then we
can also because this is a little bit
hard to pull off the H reference so we
can also add in our find all fine tune
that in this case the H reference equals
true will actually filter that out and
then finally we might do a four link in
links and we can simply do something
like this for each link we want to
actually find the H reference because we
know there's an H reference in it and if
I run this you can see it just comes
through and prints them out one at a
time some of these are really useful so
you might be looking for something that
has https in it and you know that's a
link running to something else or you
might be looking for the mailed two tags
you know that's all the mail addresses
but either way you can easily find all
the links in your HTML document that
you're paging through and of course any
packages that have evolved over time you
can also do link dot get H reference
which should do the same thing as our
other format and you can see it
certainly does we get the same printout
up here in this particular case we
really want to get the data off the page
so let's go ahead and do that let's see
what that looks like and in data let's
call it all rows there we go equals and
then we have our soup dot find
underscore all there's our brackets and
then if we're looking for each row in a
database you'll remember your HTML code
we're looking for the tag TRS we want to
find all TR and we can take this and
let's go ahead and just take all our
rows and do a print all rows and about
this time you're going to guess that
we're going to get a huge amount of
information just dumped onto our page
and sure enough we do if you look at
this it just kind of goes on forever but
this is an array each row is considered
an array so because of that we can do
something simply as putting brackets and
just print the first let's do the first
five rows so from beginning to five and
you can see here's our first five rows
on here I sometimes like to just do
let's just do row zero and we see that
row zero is finishers finisher is 191
and just out of curiosity which if
that's zero what's Row one male okay so
we're starting to see titles going
across here so if we come up here and we
do rows we did what up to ten let's just
take a look and see what 10 does again
and just take a look at that information
that comes across Place bib name gender
age city state chip chip Pace gender and
so on so it comes all the way down here
we kind of have an ending right here and
then we have one and then we actually it
looks like we start to have information
so we have our one our one 1191 Max
Randolph that must be the name male 29
and so on you start seeing how the
information is getting displayed going
down so the next thing we want to do
with this I'll go back up here and just
edit the space we're in so it starts to
make a little bit more sense keep it all
together and so we want to do for each
row in all rows we're looking at what
information are we looking at well we
have our th up here that's the header
our TD down here which looks like the
individual information and we really are
looking for the actual data so we're
looking for our TD tags in the rows and
we can do that because when remember
when it stores the row it also stores
the tags underneath that so all rows
have all the different tags in it and
you can see right here as you print each
one of those out and so we look at each
row we can create another variable and
we'll call it row list and we'll set
this equal to in this case row because
we've already pulled all the rows out of
soup so now we want to find for each row
and in there we want to find our TD and
if we go ahead and just print I'm going
to do it if you notice I changed the
indent so I'm just going to print row
list what this does is the last value to
go into row list our last row is going
to print now and of course make sure you
have an underscore instead of a period
when you're typing so row dot find
underscore all TD and if we print the
last row you can see I have all the data
coming across here we have our 191 our
1216 Zuma Oak choa I hope I said that
right female I believe that's age 40 and
so on and then we can take our row list
and there's a lot of things we can do
with the row list what we'll do for
let's do object or let's do just do cell
in row list and so we're going to look
at each cell because this is if you look
at this they have commas separated
between the different objects and then
we're going to go ahead and print cell
dot text let's just take a look and see
what that looks like and we can see here
for each row we get 191 there's our 191
there's our 12 16 12 16 our individual
who's in the race and so forth all the
way down for those different settings
let's go ahead and create a new variable
up here we'll call this all let's just
call it data we'll keep it simple so
here's our data and then we have our row
we take our row we break it up into
individual cells so we'll call this data
row we'll set this empty to an empty row
and we're going to take our cells to
have this we know that each cell
generates a text and so what we want to
do is I want to take my data row let's
just replace that let's take our data
row and let's append our cell dot text
so I'm going to add the each row is
going to be a row of the different text
on here and then once I create each row
I want my data which is going to be
everything to append each row and here's
our data row and then if we go ahead and
come down here and let's just print data
now if we were working with large data
we'd be very careful about just throwing
all our data on the page but you can see
here we throw the date on the page and
we get finishers 199 male 78 female 113
1 and so on and if you look at this this
is the headers on the file we have
finishers uh male females just like some
general statistics on the first one and
then we have actually
an empty data set and then we have our
data that continues which actually the
actual information we're looking for so
we have 1 1191 Max Randolph Mill 29
Washington DC runtime one of 78 and so
on on here so we could really quickly
get rid of that a number of different
ways to do that one of them is just to
do we're going to set we do data 2 on we
should get rid of everything we we want
to keep Randolph so make sure Randolph
is in there oh we lost Randolph let's
try one on there we go there's Max
Randolph on there so we can just simply
do redo our data on here and we can do
data probably want to do it in all rows
from one on but I'm just going to do my
data equals data one on down here and
there's reasons to split it this way in
data science sometimes you don't want to
touch the original data in case you need
it in case we do need the first row so
we'll put it down here and maybe we'll
just call this titles titles equals data
of zero and so we could do something
here where we print we'll print up our
titles and we'll print our data in this
case instead of one on let's go minus
two let's look at the last two rows of
data so here we have our titles and for
some reason just put in finishers of 191
I was expecting a little bit more up
there and we have our last couple people
and they look like the data on these
looks just fine on here turns out this
is just some generic statistics up here
so we'll get rid of titles completely
doesn't really do us any good but we
know that data comes in here and we can
look at our data and look at the very
end of the data too the minus 2 to the
end and we can see it pulls the data in
pretty good we don't have anything too
funky in here we're looking at it looks
pretty clean now you got to be a little
careful because at some point we might
have to come back here and clean up the
data if we get an error if we're running
a data analysis we might find out
there's some unusual characters or
something is missed set in the data
itself and you also notice that
everything is a string so when we're
bringing it in we might have to do some
conversions to test it out and convert
them to whatever kind of data format
we're working with so at this time we
want to go ahead and bring in our pandas
and let's go ahead and call this idea
for data frame we'll set it equal to and
if you remember correctly we imported
pandas as PD and that's standard you'll
see that in most code examples where
they call it the import pandas is PD and
it is capital D capital F for data frame
and we're just going to bring in our
data that's what we
and let's take this and we'll print now
when you're working with data frames
you're usually talking large amounts of
data and so you almost never want to
print the whole data frame out we're
going to go ahead and do that anyway
just so we can see what that looks like
and you can see in here brings in our
data frame coming in here and we just
have a mess of information this is our
data let's go ahead and print DF and see
what that looks like in the data frame
and this is nice because it organizes it
into a very easy to read table and we
have they set the label 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
and so on and then we have each row we
have Mel 78 none none going across when
we get all the way down here we'll see
Max Randall about number three and the
first thing this does is this Flags me
that I brought in a bunch of information
up here that we really didn't want it's
from 3 on that we want and we can clean
this up in one of two ways we can try to
clean it up under the data or we can
clean it up under the data frame
depending on what it is we're trying to
do and so to fix this
um I want to go ahead and just change it
up here in the actual data pull in we
don't need that information so I'll
rerun it reload our data from 4 on and
then when I run this we see we have Max
Randolph is right at the top of the list
like you should be and we have all the
data going down now with the data frame
remember I said we don't usually print
the whole data frame we'll go ahead and
do df.head and this prints the first
five rows and you can see that we have
13 columns here's Max Randall all the
way to Theo kinman and I use the also
print DF tell and the reason I like to
do these particular two setups I'm going
to change it just to two rows because
you can do that you can put as many rows
as you want is this good look at the
first part and the end because those are
usually where you have extra data
brought in something's messed up and you
can also see that we have 190 rows in
here and it comes in with our Zuma
Alicia and they're both on here on the
list so now we have a nice data frame
columns and rows we can easily look at
it we can see the setup on here and we
can look at the names and everything now
at some point you might be looking at
these individual columns and find
different information that needs to be
re-edited if you can you try to do it
with the whole column under pandas you
can up in the upper part of the code
where you went from cell to cell or row
to row you could look at individual
cells maybe find a marker in that cell
that's something specific like remove
all colons or semicolons or something in
there are brackets so there's a lot of
options in there but you'll find that
this one actually comes in pretty clean
on here all the way down and the next
thing we really want to do is we want to
look at the headers I don't know about
you but does it make any sense to me
when I have column one I don't know what
1191 is or 1080 need name Kaiser Runner
I'm guessing that's column two is names
third one looks like male or female
probably age but I don't want to guess I
want this to bring in my column so I
know exactly what I'm looking at so how
can we make beautiful soup do that for
us well let's take our column headers
and we're going to set that equal to our
soup find underscore all and then we're
going to look for our headers our th
files and since we're in Jupiter lab in
this case Jupiter notebook I can just
type out column headers if it's a last
variable I have listed it will
automatically print it just kind of a
shorthand and we can see right here we
have place I'm guessing that's bib name
gender age city state chip time chip
pace and so on so we have all our
headers right there I shouldn't have to
type them all in and we'll go ahead and
do it before we'll go ahead and do a
header list equals our empty array and
then we can do for a column in column
headers and we can take our header list
and just a pin and what do we want we
want the text from the column so we'll
just do column dot text and then if we
come down here and we print our header
list let's see what that looks like if
we did it right we should get a nice
list of all the different column
headings we want so we have placebib
name and so on and then pandas just
because pandas is so cool we can simply
do DF columns equals our header from our
header list we can simply said DF
columns set to DF headers and then if I
print DF dot head we'll take a look at
that and we'll see right here it has
nicely placed our values on here Place
bib name gender age and so on so very
quickly we've created this nice data
frame we have the data displayed in nice
rows and columns and easy to read and
then as a data scientist the first thing
we want to know is the info what is in
these columns and rows and headers and
you see right here they all come up with
non-null object there's a big flag so if
I want to do anything with this these
are all coming through as strings or an
object I usually mean strings in this
case that they're a string variable and
we have you can quickly read through
this 191 entries date columns total 14
columns there's a total of 14 columns in
the data and it shows you all the
different names and what type of column
they are and it's probably good also to
look at the shape of the data df.shape
we'll go ahead and just run that you see
it's 191 by 14 14 columns 191 entries
this is more like a we look at a numpy
array 191 by 14 for the shape and
remember this is a variable so if I put
it on if it's a last variable or last
value in the set of cells Jupiter
automatically prints it out so if you're
in a different IDE you want to go ahead
and use the print statement on here and
then one of the things you'd want to
also go through we'll create a second
one df2 equals DF dot drop in a now the
axis is automatically equal to zero so a
lot of times you'll see something like
X's equals zero comma How equals any
axis equals zero is default that means
we're looking at going down the rows you
could look at the column going across
let's remove the how index that's just
going to confuse you the axis is is
whether you're going down the columns or
if you're looking at a row by row by row
by row or you could be looking at it by
column by column by column this would
drop any column and it would drop off
the N A in any column and how equals and
we want any I always confuse all in any
because they both start with a all means
that all of them have to be non-value
where any means that any of them can be
there to drop it so this would drop any
column with a null value in it but we
want zero and it'll drop any value with
an null value and then because 0 is
always the default we'll just leave it
out and then as curious as to what the
shape is now did we lose anything was
there any null values in our df2 that we
dropped from the DF and we'll go ahead
and run that and we see 191 and 14. so
we didn't really drop anything but it's
always good to check there's other ways
you can also do are there let's see any
Nas you can detect dnas in here null
values infinite values that's another
one you got to watch out for we're
working with data that we're going to do
something with here in a minute so you
got to be a little careful also in the
conversions are you going to convert
something where people typed in weird
characters to describe the data a
certain way so now we've got to this
point where we have all our different
columns we have our different data and
at this point maybe you're asking or
maybe the shareholder the company is
asking hey can we look at the based on
the chip time here's our chip time can
we plot that versus gender how does
gender versus chip time compare and so
we can do that we can take that and the
first thing we look at is we say hey
well chip time came in as a string and
that's going to be an issue now there's
a number of ways you can change this one
of them is we could go all the way back
up here where we created the data and
find a way to tag it and say Hey
whenever this cell text maybe instead of
appending this I notice that anytime
there's two colons in it that's probably
a Time signal future and let's convert
all the time signatures to date time
filled or whatever A lot of times you
don't get that you don't get that option
and that's always a question in bringing
in data whether you convert the data
coming in at the beginning or do you
wait till you have it open it up and
then convert it when you go to use it
we're going to go ahead and convert it
after we got it into our data frame so
we have our df2 here we've dropped all
of our Nas we dropped our we have a
shape in fact let's do this since
there's no difference between DF and df2
well we'll just go ahead and use df2 so
let's go ahead and take our df2 and we
want to take those that specific field
and convert it into some kind of
numerical value we can use and let's add
another column A lot of times this is
something you want to do is where you
want to go ahead and keep all the
original columns and just add a new
column in there and this new column is
going to be based on the if we remember
correctly we had chip time that's what
we're going to look at okay we want chip
time versus gender if we go into our
pandas we find out we have pandas two
Delta and this is actually time Delta
and then we just want to take our df2
and we're going to use the chip time
column so this is going to say hey let's
look at let's convert everything in df2
chip time into a Time Delta format
that's the data type we're going to put
it as let me go ahead and just run this
and if we go in here and we do info df2
and we'll keep our we're going to look
at this particular column but we want to
keep it as a data frame so is a list of
other columns we want to we'll just do
that info on here and run that and we do
an info on that you can see it's now a
Time Delta 64 nanoseconds uh well we
really don't want nanoseconds we
actually probably want to do it in
minutes uh so let's take a look at that
and let's take this whole thing TF2
let's just set the df2 we have our df2
this is a column we're working with here
and we can use the as type property in
pandas and so we can set this equal to
df2 we'll take our same column in here
and we'll set it as type time Delta
second so it's still a Delta time here
so if I run this you'll see that it
still comes up as where is it well it
turns it into a float so we're now at a
float 64 so it's the number of seconds
in that Delta time and then finally we
want to go ahead and turn that from
seconds to say minutes and you know
there's 60 seconds in minutes and so now
we divide by 60 we still have a float we
have our info it shows us it's a float
and then we can go ahead and just do a
print df2 and let's just keep it small
we don't want to look at all our data we
just want to do the head of it and we
run this and you can see right here
where we go to it'll be the last one
here's our chip time in minutes and a
lot of times just to make life easy for
viewing since we're only looking at this
particular element we can do chip time
in minutes and now we just see that oops
we take off we'll go ahead and take off
our info done with that and we'll run
this and you can see we have our minutes
16.8 minutes 17.51 minutes and so on
it's a float number now keep in mind
this is 0.8 that's not a 16 minutes and
80 Seconds they can always throw you if
you're going through so many numbers you
forget it's important to remember that
and we're also going to look at the
other one we're looking at is what
gender you want to look at gender to
chip time in minutes and so we can see
here under the head we get mail mail
mail and a number of different setups
and this switch this to tell real quick
and just look at the end of it and here
we have female female male female female
so we have two different genders and we
have our chip time in minutes and if you
remember we brought in our PLT if you
haven't used the plot Library the
matplot library you have a drawing place
you're putting stuff on so we have our
PLT we're going to do a bar graph and we
just want to Simply use our df2 gender
and df2 Chip time in minutes so that's
going to plot the two bars and to make
it pretty we'll go ahead and give it the
X label gender the Y label chip time
minutes and that simply is I remember it
always plots X and it plots Y and we
have our gender our chip time give it a
nice title a comparison of average
minutes run by male and female and if we
go ahead and run this with the correct
titles in here and everything matches uh
you'll get a nice graph we can see here
the comparison of average minutes run by
male and female here's our chip time in
minutes the men seem to be Slackers in
this particular case and it's actually
there's a number of studies that show
that women tend to have as far as doing
cross-country there's a lot of women who
have a longer endurance than men so it's
not too surprising but we can see here
the average chip time around 70 and for
women over a hundred minutes and then
another really cool thing we can do is
we can describe the data so
df2.describe this again is a pandas
function just like info is we're going
to include NP number the numpy number
and if we run that you'll see here it
comes up and it says chip time in
minutes a count it gives you the average
or the means standard deviation the
minimum the maximum all the different
descriptive information you're going to
want from your data set on there and
just because there's all kinds of fun
ways let's do a box plot to display your
information we can do a box plot where
the column equals chip time in minutes
and let's go ahead and run that keep
mistyping my chip time in minutes you
can see it puts out a nice box plot
showing you the information we have our
different values and floaters this is
always interesting because this is a
nice way of seeing where we have these
floaters one up here and there's two up
above and of course you're they're a
nice spread on the box plot and we can
also modify this a little bit and we can
add in buy equals gender and then we'll
give it a we'll just give it a blank
title I don't know why we're giving it a
blank title uh we'll just add a y plot y
label on there for runtime and if we run
this you can see here box plot Group by
gender chip time in minutes and now we
have our female and male two different
areas and you can see how they vary you
have your two different your outlier up
here and you can also see how there's
such an overlap between the two
different values so if I was looking at
this I'd be like wow you know I really
could not draw a conclusive thing on
this saying that Women's Run time was
more in general because they overlapped
too much that would be one of the
conclusions I'd have to come up with
done here and then we get to maybe the
partners come in from the company and
say hey we'd like to know the age versus
chip time in minutes that'd be something
worth knowing on the statistics on this
and the first thought is we can simply
plot it and we can do this we can
actually plot the scatter plot chip time
versus a df2 of H those are X Y
coordinates but if you remember from df2
we did the info let's go way back up
here we're looking at a data object as
far as our chip time on this and our age
now we converted the chip time but we
also need to convert the age and if we
do it right here we just plot it and
it'll actually let us plot it it
shouldn't it should give us an error but
it does let us plot it you'll see the
Ages come up a mess over here because
they're converting it to weird float
numbers and all kinds of things so what
we want to do is we want to take our age
and we'll just call this age underscore
I so we're going to take our age and
we're going to create another column for
df2 age underscore I and the I is just
going to stand for integers our own
choice of values there is a number of
ways to do this but we're going to do a
pandas to Merrick is the best way in
pandas and the reason we're doing this
is that numeric creates a float value so
right off the bat we want all our stuff
converted converts it to the least
common denominator so if they're all
integers already you'll get integers as
you can see from here it's doing some
kind of conversion that converts it to a
float value the other thing that numeric
does is if there is a null value or they
put in like a blank line or a dash to
represent no information it'll convert
it to a null so it goes from like a
string to a null versus just having some
kind of made up number that python
somehow created for the graph we have
below and then we want to add our d ef2h
because that's what we're converting to
numeric and then we want to coerce it
and there's a couple different options
on this like you can have it where it
just doesn't process it in pandas but
coerce means that if it gets a weird
value that is a null value now and since
we're dealing with errors this is what
happens when you get an error converting
it we want to coerce it there we go and
put the end bracket on there and then
finally we want to go and round this off
so I'll put brackets around all the way
around it and this rounds off everything
in this series so we've done here is
I've taken df2h which is a d-type object
which in this case is mostly strings
with a couple of blank ones in there and
we're going to convert it to a numeric
which will automatically go to float and
then we're going to take wherever
there's an error wherever it says hey
this doesn't convert and usually that's
a blank screen like I said I've worked
with so many databases where they
someone puts down none someone types in
space sometimes in a dash to mean none
and you get this really weird conversion
coming up this covers all of that in
pandas so it's really a nice way of just
coercing it and saying hey if we don't
have a number in there let's make it a
null value and then we're going to round
it off and then finally let's go ahead
and take our df2 here's our df2 and
let's drop those null values drop in a
and we want how how equals any so that
means if there's any null values in the
data set now you can be this might get
you in trouble because you might have no
values in a different column and so you
might lose data that way at this point
we could also do like certain parts of
like Drop just certain columns with null
values there's all kinds of other
options in here but we're just going to
do how we're going to just drop any and
we want to do it in line equals true so
that means it's going to reassign it to
df2 so df2 now has rounded out so it's
rounded to the integer we didn't do any
places the age and it's going to be age
I and then we've dropped all our null
values that way we're not going to get
any errors and we try to plot a null
value and it also makes sure that data
by deleting out the rows because that's
what this does it automatically does
axis0 which is your rows axes one is
your columns by doing this it
automatically removes all the rows with
null values so it just cleans out the
rolls and then when we go ahead and plot
this we see we have a nice clean data
and we have age all the way up to 70. so
we have our chip time set and then our
age going across and it makes a nice
plot that you can easily show for
display and for the the and you can
easily show that to your shareholders or
whatever group you're working on it
makes it really nice and quick easy
display in this session we will discuss
the top tips and tricks in Python that
you can use to solve your problems first
let's understand what python really is
so python is a high-level open source
programming language developed in 1989
by Guido van Rossum
it has simple easy to use syntax
python can run on different platforms
such as Windows Linux and Unix
it has a large collection of libraries
and can be integrated with other
programming languages such as c c plus
and Java
companies use Python for web development
software development statistical
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
python tips and tricks will help you
optimize the code and reduce your time
and effort while writing codes for
solving problems
these tips and tricks are usually short
Snippets of python code with simple
illustrations to tell you how you can
perform a complex task easily
it can also serve as examples that allow
you to dive deep into understanding and
exploring how each concept works and
where it can be used
so in this video we'll be covering the
tips and tricks based on python lists
tuples sets and dictionaries we'll also
see how to effectively use loops
iterators and collections in Python
so let me take you to my jupyter
notebook where I'll show you the
different tips and tricks
so here is my jupyter notebook
so let's begin with our first trick
if you want to initialize a list or a
tuple filled with repetitive strings or
numbers written in the form of a string
we can do that using the multiplication
operator
so let me show you
so first I'll declare a list suppose a
is equal to within square brackets I'll
declare a string suppose India
and now if I use the multiplication
operator and suppose I say 10
then I'll print a
so this will print India 10 times if I
hit shift enter it will run that cell
you can see we have printed India 10
times
similarly
let's add another element to our list
or another item to our list
say India and then we have
France
I'll use the multiplication operator and
apply 10. so let me print my list again
for hit shift enter you can see India
and France have been printed 10 times
also
you can use
an integer as a string
and print as many times as you want
suppose I am printing 20 five times
I'll use the print statement
you can see we have printed 25 times
but if I pass an integer as my first
operand
it will result in the product of the two
numbers so for example if I use c equal
to
20 into 5
and if I print C
it will give me the product of 20 and 5
that is 100.
next let's see how you can reverse the
elements in a list for that we'll use
the list slicing method
let me first show you how you can
reverse a string
I'll declare my list as list 1 is equal
to
and inside this list I'll
pass in a few country names such as
India then we have
USA
let's say we have France
and then
Germany
and finally we have Spain now if you
want to reverse the order of this list
you can use the slicing method inside
the print statement so I'll write print
and I'll pass in my list that is list
one
and I'll use double colon
followed by
-1 so this will read my list from the
end
so if I hit shift enter you can see we
have reversed
our original list so now this pane comes
first then Germany France USA and India
likewise you can also reverse
a list of numbers
so
let's reverse a list of numbers
suppose this time I'll use list 2 is
equal to
I'll pass in few integers say 100 200
300 and 400.
now if I
print
my list
to
using colon colon -1 it will reverse
list two
you can see we have reboost our original
list two so now 400 comes first then 300
200 and 100.
now let me tell you how you can print
the elements in a list in any order that
you prefer suppose I have a list that
has values like 1 comma two three and
four
then I'll print this list
after that
I'll use four variables
such as e comma B comma C comma d
and assign it to our list
after that let me go ahead and print any
order that I want for example I'll use B
comma e comma D comma C
and hit shift enter you can see we have
printed our list in the order that we
wanted
so basically what this cell does is
we have assigned the value 1 from list
to a 2 to B 3 to C and 4 to D and we are
printing in an order b a d c
so this is the result you can see
now suppose you want to print in some
other order like
say I want C first
then I want B
a and then d
so this is the output
up next
we will discuss list comprehensions in
Python so list comprehension is an
effective way to define and create new
lists based on existing lists
so suppose you want to extract and
separate all the letters from the word
simply learn and add letters as items of
a list ideally you would use a for Loop
to do this task
so let's see how you can perform this
task using a for Loop I'll assign an
empty list say letters
is equal to
I'll use square brackets to assign my
empty list
then
and declare a for Loop so suppose for I
in
I'll pass in my string that is simply
learn
and
I'll append the letters
using the append function
now let me go ahead and
print the letters
if I hit shift enter you can see
this will print all individual letters
present in the word simply learn
but the same job
you can do it easily with the help of
list comprehensions
so let me show you how to do that
first I'll declare a variable say
letters
is equal to inside square brackets I'll
write I for
I in my string
simply learn
then I'll just
print the letters
you can see we have extracted all the
letters from the word simply learn
so this is how we use list comprehension
now similarly
if you were to find the square of
numbers you would like to create a user
defined function or use a for Loop to do
it so let me show you how you can
proceed
so
we were to define a function so first
I'll import
the math module present in Python
and then let's say I am defining a
function called Square
and I'll pass in a parameter as a
then I'll write e is equal to
I'll use the power function so I'll
first give in my module name that is
math and use the power function that is
pow
and I'll pass in my parameter that is a
and since we want to find the square
I'll give in 2
and I'll return my parameter that is a
if I hit shift enter now we have
successfully run our user defined
function now let me call that function
if I write
square of a
does given me 1 by default
now suppose I want to find the square
of integer 5
you can see it has given us the square
of 5 that is 25
now to find the square of a number you
can also create an empty list and use a
for Loop to iterate through a sequence
of numbers and append the square of
numbers to that empty list
so let me show you how you can do with
this process suppose I
declare an empty list called squares
I'll pass in my empty list
and then I'll use a for Loop say for
example for
I in
range
I'll give 10 as my range
and then
I'll append my Square value so I'll
pass in my empty list that is squares
Dot
append
so I'll use Quest dot append
and pass I into I
and then
I'll just
call my empty list squares if I hit
shift enter you can see
from 0 to 9 that is a range of 10 values
it has printed all the squares of those
integers
now these two methods that we just
discussed need at least three to four
lines of code but by using a list
comprehension you can find the square of
numbers in just a single line of code
so let's use a list comprehension to
find square of five whole numbers
between 0 and 20 having an interval of
four
so I'll use
squares
is equal to
I'll say X
double multiplication operator
into 2 for
X in
say range
I'll pass in my range that is from 0 to
with an interval of 4.
now I'll
print squares
if I hit shift enter you can see it has
printed the square of values so first
the number is 0 so 0 square is 0 then
the number was 4 so 4 square is 16 8
square is 64. then 12 square is 144 and
then 16 square is 256.
moving ahead in the next trick
I'll show you how you can keep track of
the index positions and the items in a
list
so for that we will use the enumerate
function to print the item values along
with the index positions
so let's see I have a list
that has items
say
294 I'm taking random integers
450 and say 243
and now if I
use a print statement suppose
I'll write using the
enumerate function
then I'll use a for Loop say for example
for
index comma
element
in
enumerate
I'll pass in my
list that is list underscore items
after that
I'll use a print statement
I'll pass in index
and then I'll give
a list and that will have my
index
followed by
the value
I'll use another comma and pass in the
element
now if I hit shift enter you can see we
have printed the index position as well
as the item value so at index 0 we have
310 at index 1 we have 294 similarly for
index 2 and 3
now moving ahead
let us understand how we can convert two
less into a dictionary so a dictionary
as you must be aware comes with a key
value pair
you can use the dictionary method and
pass the zip function with our list as
parameters
so let me Define our two lists say item
number and names
so I'll use item number
and give him some random whole numbers
and let's say 321
and I'll use my second list
that is names and let's say this list
has
some string values like phone
next is laptop
and then we have say tablet
now
I'll
assign a variables say item
dictionary
is equal to I'll use the dict function
and then pass in zip
and I'll pass in my parameters item
number and names
finally I'll print
my newly created dictionary that is item
dictionary
now let me run it
so you can see we have a dictionary
created out of the list
so our keys are 102 410 and 321 and the
item values are phone laptop and tablet
now you can check that in the following
way so I'll
pass in my dictionary
and then I'll use the keys function to
get the keys from the dictionary so you
see we have all the keys printed
similarly if you want to print the
values from the dictionary
I'll use the values function
so that will print all the values you
can see we have phone laptop and tablet
now we look at how you can find the
common elements in two lists
so let me declare my first list as list
underscore e that will be equal to
Davis
then let's say we have kerin
then we have John
we have Frank next and then let's see we
have another person say steep
and let me declare my list B so list
underscore B
is equal to I'll take Karen
next we have Davis
then suppose we have Jack
up next we have
George
and then say we have Steve again
now to find the common elements I'll use
variable let's say common
and I'll again
use a list comprehension say a for
a in
list a
then use for
B in
list B
then I'll use an if Clause so if E
equals to equals to B
then
I'll
print the common variable
if I run this you can see we have the
common elements printed from both the
list A and B so Dave is caring and Steve
are present in both list A and B
next let's see how you can remove the
duplicate items in a list such problems
you would often come across while doing
data analytics so the idea is very
simple you just need to convert the
items in a list into a set
so that will remove all the duplicate
items in a list
so suppose I have a list of numbers
let me take random whole numbers 20 22
4 so 26
then we have 28 repeated twice
and then again suppose we have 20
and we have 22
and let's see we have 30.
now
let me go ahead and print my list
so I'll say original list
equals to
and then I'll pass in my
list that is list numbers
after that
I'll convert my list that is list
numbers
into a set
so I'll first use the list function and
then inside of that I'll pass in my set
function and then declare
my list
that is list numbers
finally I'll
print my new list
so I'll type list after
removing duplicates
that will be equal to
I'll give a comma and then pass in my
variable
that is list numbers
if I run it
you can see our original list has all
the elements that has duplicate values
and the final list the output you can
see we have only the unique elements
printed
moving on
now let's have a look at how you can
merge two dictionaries
so there are two methods to do this
before that let's see how the code would
have looked like had you merged the
dictionaries using python 2 version or
Python 3.4 version and below
so let's see I have two dictionaries say
team a
I'll use curly braces to declare my
dictionary
I'll give my key as one and I'll take
Davis
I'll give my second key
and see I have Andrew in my team
and then let's say I have my
third key and let's see I have Karen
similarly let me declare my
Team B dictionary
I'll take
the next key as four
and the next person would be
say John
and then
I'll use my fifth key
we have Angela
and let's see I have my final member in
the team the sixth member
who is Suzanne
now
if you do it in Python 2 or Python 3.4
version and below I have to define a
function so let me say Define
merge underscore teams which will be my
function name
and I'll pass in two parameters say dict
one
and dict
two
then I have dict three
indict three
I'll use the
copy method so I'll
use dict
one
dot copy
then
let me go ahead and
use my dict three
Dot
update
I'll pass in my dick to
and then
see I'll return
my dict
three
finally
I'll print it so I'll use
merge underscore teams
then pass in my two parameters as team a
comma
TMP
if I run it oops there is a mistake I
have made so this should be dipped to
actually
so let me run it once again you can see
we have merged both our dictionaries
now you can see it has around six to
seven lines of code or even more
now if you want to do this task using
python 3.5 version and above you can use
the update method so let's see how we
can do
I have CE
is equal to
I'll pass in my dictionary
as
e has value of 1
say B has a value of
let's say B also has a value of 1
and my
second dictionary would have
key B again
and it has a value of 2
and Key C
will have a value of 1.
now if I write e Dot
update B
and if I print a let me run it you can
see we have merged
both the dictionaries here
now there's one more method which you
can use let me show you
so I'll copy paste my TMA and Team B
again
and then
let's say I'll declare
another variable called final team
that will be equal to
I'll use curly braces and then say
I'll give two star and then team a
comma
two stars again
and then Team B
then I'll print my
final team if I run it you can see we
have merged both our team A and B and
this is our final team that has
six elements
now before moving to the next trick if
you have enjoyed watching this video so
far then please consider subscribing to
our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to never miss an update
also if you want to get the source file
I am using in this live session then
please mention your email IDs in the
chat section we'll share the source code
with you over email
now let's move on
similar to a list comprehension you can
also create a dictionary comprehension
let me show you the trick
suppose I want to find the square of
numbers so I'll pass in my variable that
is square
and I'll use my dictionary comprehension
say x comma X
star star 2 this will find the square of
a number
for X in range
C5 so I want the square of the first
five numbers
then let me just call it
you can see it has printed a dictionary
that has the square of numbers from 0 to
4 that is five numbers so 0 square is 0
1 square is 1 2 square is 4 3 square is
9 and 4 square is 16.
now let's see the trick to check if all
the elements in a sequence are true or
false based on a condition
you can do this with the help of all
function all function in Python returns
true if all the items in an iterable are
true otherwise it returns false
so I'll directly use my all function so
I'll say all
now let's see I'll use a variable e
percentage 2 if it's equal to equal to 0
and I'll say for a
in
range
between 0 to 10 with an interval of 2
if I run it
it gives me true
because I have defined my range from 0
to 10 and an interval of 2 so the
numbers will range from 0
2 4 6 8 and so on
so all these numbers are divisible by 2
and the remainder is 0 so it gives us
true
now if I change the third parameter in
my range function see I'll make it 3
and I run it it gives me false
up next we look at a common programming
question that you often get to see in
any interview or programming test that
is swapping two numbers
let's see the trick to swap two numbers
in a single line of code
so I'll
declare two numbers c x and y
let's say we have xs10 and by s20
I'll use a print statement
say before
swap
give a comma and I'll declare my
variables X comma y
now to swap to variables I can simply
use x comma y equal to
y comma X
and then I'll again use a print
statement C
after swap
and I'll write X
equal to
say
X
and
y
will have the variable
if I run it
you see before swap X had 10 and 20 and
after swap you can see we have
X as 20 and Y as 10. so we have swapped
the values of the two variables
successfully
now moving on
the next trick I am going to show is how
you can concatenate a list containing
strings so we'll use the join function
for this
let's say I have a list characters
and it has a list of strings
say p comma y
comma t
comma h
comma o
and we have the final string that is n
now if you were to concatenate all the
list elements
I'll declare a variable called word and
double quotation marks
and then I'll use the dot operator and
join function
I'll pass in my list that is
character
then I'll
print my variable word
below you can see the resultant output
so we have successfully combined or
concatenated each element or item in the
list character so we have python printed
now let me show you how you can find the
most frequently occurring values in a
list
so
I'll declare a list called test and
suppose it has some random whole number
C1 comma 2 comma 3
four
two comma 2 then we have 3 comma 1 comma
4 comma 4 comma four
I'll use
print statement
and pass in my Max function
then I'll convert the list into
a set
give a comma and then I'll use key is
equal to test dot count
so what it basically does is it will
first count
the number of times each element is
occurring and then
find the maximum value out of it
if I hit shift enter you can see it has
given me 4 which means
the item 4 has occurred the most number
of times in my list you can see we have
four four times
moving forward the next step is how you
can use the if else statement using
ternary operators
ternary operators are commonly known as
conditional expressions in Python these
operators evaluate something based on a
condition being true or false
so I have my two variables e comma B
and it has values
10 and 20 respectively
now if I
use a print statement say both a
and B
odd
equal
if
a equals to equals to B
else
a
is
greater than b
if
a greater than
B
else
is
greater
than e
so first I am evaluating this condition
if a
is equal to equal to B then we'll print
both A and B are equal
else if a is greater than b we'll print
a is greater than b
if both the conditions are false we'll
print B is greater than a
so let me run this
we have the output B is greater than a
because
our B value is 20 and a is 10 so B is
greater than a
now let me create a numpy array and find
the cumulative sum in a sequence of
numbers for this you can use the come
sum function
first I have to import my numpy library
so I'll write
import
numpy as NP
then
I'll declare a variable
say res which is for result
I'll use a list function
and then
passing my come sum function
and let's say I'll give a range of 10.
finally I'll print the result
if I run this
you can see we have calculated the
cumulative sum of the numbers ranging
from 0 to 9
so the first element is 0 then the next
element is 1 so 0 plus 1 is 1. the next
element is 2 so 1 plus 2 is 3 then 3
plus 3 is 6 6 plus 4 is 10 10 plus 5 is
15 and so on
let's Now understand how you can use
iter tools in Python either tool is a
module in Python that implements a
number of iterator building blocks it
provides several functions that work on
iterators to produce complex iterators
we will see an example to find the list
of matches to be played between the
teams in a league here we consider each
team will play against all the other
teams in the league
so to use the iter tools I'll first
import it so I'll write import
iter tools
and then let me go ahead and declare a
list see
football
underscore clubs
let me take
a few Club names see Manchester United
then we have
Real Madrid
I'm taking the top clubs from Europe
just
the next club we have is say arsenal
followed by
Chelsea
then we have say Liverpool
and finally we have
Barcelona
then
I'll use my list function and
use another function that is present
inside the item tools library that is
combination
so it will give me all the possible
combinations
I'll pass in my
list
name that is football underscore clubs
and I'll give another parameter that is
r equal to 2
if I run it
you have all the matches that would be
played in this league
as I mentioned each team will play
against all the other teams
now we will see the trick to print the
total permutations in a given set of
numbers using the iter tool and its
functions
now to do this I'll use a
for Loop so I'll use for
p in
either tools
Dot I'll use permutations function
so
permutations
and then let's see I'll pass in my list
that has values 1 comma 2 comma 3 and 4.
I'll print it
I'll use print
then I'll use the
join function
convert it into a string
four
X in p
if I run it you can see below we have
all the permutations listed
up next let me tell you how you can
print all the false values present in a
list now to do this we can use the
filter false function present in the
iter tools module
so I'll use list
and then
use my iter tools
Dot
filter false function
I'll pass in
Bool as my
data type
let's say we have a list containing none
then we have false
we have one comma 0 comma 10.
if I run it
it will print all the false values
present in the list so we have none
false and zero
so if you have liked watching this video
so far then please subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon to
stay updated with all the trending
Technologies also if you want to get the
source file that I am using in this live
session then please mention your email
IDs in the chat section our team will
share the source code with you over
email
again if you have any questions related
to the tips and tricks we have discussed
so far then please put your queries in
the chat section our team will answer it
in the chat
up next let me show you the trick to
perform certain mathematical operations
inside a list containing pairs of tuples
first we look at how to add elements in
a list of tuples
so for that I'll import my iter tools
you can skip this step because we have
already imported a writer tools module
and then I'll import operator
we have
a list of tuples say A2 comma 5
then we have 10 comma 4
we have another pairs 60 comma 3.
now I'll use
list function and inside of it I'll use
my iter tools module
so I'll write iter tools Dot
star map function
and
I'll use my operator
add
comma
I'll pass in my list that is a
now if I run it
we have the addition of the pills of
tuples present in the list so first pair
is 2 comma 5 so the addition
is 7 then 10 plus 4 is 14 and 60 plus 3
is 63.
similarly you can also multiply the
pairs of tuples in a list I just copy
paste this code and here instead of ADD
I'll use
mul to multiply
if I run it
we have the output below
so 2 into 5 is 10 then the product of 10
and 4 is 40 and 60 and 3 is 180.
now let us explore a bit about the
collections module in Python so the
collections module implements
specialized container data types
containing alternatives to Python's
general purpose built-in containers such
as list Tuple dictionaries and set
I'll show you how to change the order of
the keys inserted in a dictionary using
the ordered dict function
so first I need to import the ordered
dict function from the collections
module
so I'll write from
collections
import
ordered
dict function
then
I'll say d is equal to
ordered
Dot
I'll use the from keys
and let's see
I have my key as e b c d e
then I'll
use another function called move
to
end
and let's say I want to move my key B to
the end
then
I'll use inverted commas
and pass in my join function
and inside that I'll say d dot
keys
if I run it
you can see we have shifted the key B to
the end
now if you want to move the key B to the
beginning
you can do something like this so let me
copy the last two lines of code from the
above cell
I'll paste it
now here I can give another
parameter that is lost
they'll see
false
if I run this
you can see we have the key B in the
beginning now
now the final trick I am going to show
you is how to perform mathematical
operations using a Lambda function in
Python
so Lambda is an anonymous function that
does not have a name
it can have any number of arguments but
only one expression
the expression is evaluated and the
result is returned
so let's see how to add and subtract
numbers in one line of code using the
Lambda function
so first I'll declare a variable say
function
is equal to
and I'll assign a dictionary
I'll pass in my
sum
and then
use the Lambda function
I'll pass in variables X comma y
and I'll add X Plus y
similarly
I'll now
subtract
I'll use the Lambda function again
pass in my variables X comma y
and I'll write x minus y
now
let me run it
so if you want to find the sum of two
numbers
so I have to call this first so I'll use
funk
and using square brackets I'll give my
sum
and then pass in my value say 10 comma 3
this will add 10 plus 3 and return the
result as 13. similarly
if you want to subtract two numbers
I'll just write subtract here instead of
sum
and it will return the result that is 10
minus 3 that which is 7.
I think with that we have covered all
the important tips and tricks that you
should know in Python welcome to python
interview questions certainly the
questions we're going to ask in here are
very general with a few specifics
towards data science since that's the
main direction that Python's going in
and you'd want to expand your questions
for your interview depending on the
domain that you're using the python in
specifically let's dive in and get
started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy.deep
copy creates a deep copy shallow copy
creates a different object and populates
it with the references of the child
objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change the channel one
and object one it will also make that
change in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in Python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
Works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python Global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading in Python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the Django
architecture so the Django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
Django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so when you
look at the architecture you can see
here we have a nice model drawn out
where the user initiates the Django
which initiates the URL which initiates
the view what they're going to view and
you have your model and your template so
the model of data whatever data model
you're pulling goes into the template
and then goes back up the pipeline to
the user and the important thing to note
is there's a template the front end of
the web page this is what they're going
to see there's a model the back end
where the data is stored so you can keep
the template and the looks and
everything looks the same but you can
swap out the underlying formation that
goes into that template then you have
your view which interacts with the model
and template and Maps it to the URL and
then the Django serves the page to the
user so your Django grabs it and says
okay thank you for the URL and here you
go user what advantage does numpy array
have over a nested list so numpy is a
module you import almost always see
numpy import numpy as NP numpy is
written in C such that all its
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module lists on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this makes number
arrays much faster than lists I would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our Jupiter notebook any IDE
will work if you're going to do a set of
these of interview questions taking a
quick look at code is always important
we have our import and of b as NP we'll
go and import time here's our list list
sub for Iron Range of 100 and what we're
doing is we're going to time it so we're
going to create a list then we're going
to create a numpy zeros array and you
can see here look how quick you can
create this numpy zeros array here we
are appending one zero at a time for a
regular python list and here we are with
numpy they're all zeros and they're all
of type integer I believe it's either
floater integer on this I'd have to
actually do a type and then so if we
take in and we create a tl1 time equals
time and then we do for I and range of
100 for J and range of 100 L of I J
equals L of i j plus 5. so we're just
doing a simple calculation on our array
and sub arrays this is an array of rays
and we'll do the same thing with tl2 tl2
time dot time tl1 equals so here we have
our final time on that and then we'll do
this with an array array op and this is
what I really love a equals a plus 10
and then you can just print it right out
so you can see right here with the numpy
array we're doing the same thing if I
run this our time is significantly
different here we have 0.09 and 0.003 so
you can see that the time drops
significantly when you're running this
on a numpy array versus a list array
also important to note these times
aren't going to be they'll change each
time I run it depending on what I have
running in the background so there we go
number five what is pickling and
unpickling Macy's how many M's I pickle
and unpickle something converting a
python object hierarchy to a byte stream
is called pickling pickling is also
referred to as serialization unpickling
converting a byte stream to a python
object hierarchy is also called
unpickling and pickling is also referred
to as deserialization so if you just
created a neural network model you can
now save that model to your hard drive
pickle it and then you can unpickle it
to bring it back into another software
program or to use at a later time how is
memory managed in Python number six
python has a private Heap space where it
stores all the objects the python memory
manager manages various aspects of this
Heap like sharing caching segmentation
and allocation the user has no control
over the Heap only the python
interpreter has the access you have a
nice little diagram here here's your
program there's your interpreter we have
our Heap memory management on the
garbage collector going off of there
number seven are arguments in Python
pass by value or by reference arguments
are passed in Python by reference this
means that any change made within a
function is reflected on the original
object so you can see here def function
of l l of zero equals three L equals one
two three four function L print L and
you're going to get three two three four
because we've passed l in there so it's
a pointer here we have def function l l
equals three two three four L equals one
two three four function of L print L
because in this function I have assigned
instead of operating on a piece of L the
list I've consigned a whole new value to
that list or L it then at that points
will create a new object so if I make
changes to the object it's going to
change it in the outside the definition
if I use a variable and I ass cited a
completely new value like L equals three
two three four that will not show up
when you're outside the function number
eight How would would you Generate
random numbers in Python to generate not
random numbers in Python you must first
import the random module the random
function generates a random float value
between 0 and 1. the random range
function generates a random number
within a given range and you can see
here one is the lower end times the
upper end and step two so it'd be one
three five and so on as far as the
options in the random generation number
nine what does the double forward slash
operator do in Python the forward slash
operator performs Division and Returns
the quotient in float for example five
over two returns 2.5 to do a double
forward slash operator on the other hand
Returns the quotient in integer for
example 5 double slash returns two five
divided by two and you drop the point
five number ten what does the is
operator do the is operator compares the
ID of the two objects and you can see in
here where list one equals brackets
around one two three list one equals
list two equals true and you have the
double equals in Python of course and
you can do list one is list two where
list two equals one two three is false
list two is not the brackets one two
three it equals it but it's not the
brackets and if we do list three equals
list one then list one is list three
equals true number eleven what is the
purpose of pass statement the past
statement is used when there's a
syntactic but not an operational
requirement for example the program
below prints a string ignoring the
spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learned we've added two
spaces in it for I and variable so it
goes through each eye if I equals space
do nothing else print I and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out Simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
I does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need to play placeholder for
that first logical set or that first
area you can also do a function like
this you could do function whatever your
def function name brackets colon pass so
it goes into the function and does
nothing but it's a placeholder number 12
how will you check all the characters in
a string are alphanumeric python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in The
String are alpha numeric and so you can
see here A B C D one two three is all
number output equals true and the second
line a b c d the at symbol one two three
the pound symbol is all new output
equals false so I really just want to
know about is all new all numerical
alphanumerical number 12 how will you
check if all characters in a string are
alphanumeric so here we go if you know
is all number which returns that the
characters in The String are
alphanumeric one can also use rejects
instead and so we have Boolean re man
much what's important about this is to
note your capital a dash to capital z a
lowercase to dash to Z 0 to 9 means that
that array includes all of those the way
they have it written out plus a dollar
sign and then we have well we're
comparing it to the string we're
comparing to the ABCD one two three and
so we can do an re dot match and if it
matches if all these things if all the
different entities in that array matches
the first one we get an output true and
if not an output false number 13 how
will you merge elements in a sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in Python there's lists tuples
and strings python equation makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your Tuple is the curve brackets
designates it and again just add them
together same thing with strings we have
simply learn S1 plus S2 equals simply
learn number 14 how will you remove all
leading white space in a string python
provides the inbuilt function L strip to
remove all leading access from a string
and you can see here space space python
dot L strip leading strip Python and you
can also do strip which relieves leading
and ending of course there's also the
ending set number 15 how will you
replace all occurrences of a substring
with a new string the replace function
can be used with strings for replacing a
substring with a given string syntax
string dot replace old comma new comma
count replace returns a new string
without modifying the original string
hey John how are you John question mark
replace John with capital j o h n one
and then you can see right here hey John
how are you and since we designated with
the one just says we're only going to
replace one of these 6 16 what is the
difference between Del and remove
brackets on lists Del for delete Dell
removes all elements of a list within a
given range syntax Dell list start to
end remove remove brackets removes the
first occurrence of a particular
character syntax list remove element and
we see a nice example over here if we
delete the list one to three it will
delete the first in this case b one two
it doesn't do three remember that one
two so it will delete B and C and you
end up with a d where if we do remove B
from the list and we have an a b b d
it's only going to remove the first B
number 17 how to display the contents of
text file in reverse order open the file
using the open function store the
contents of the file into a list reverse
the contents of the list run a for Loop
to iterate through the list number 18.
differential between append and extend
append adds an element to the end of the
list you can see right here we have a
list one two three four and we have
pinned four and we end up with an output
one two three four and extend adds an
element from an interval to the end of
the list and we have here list equals
one two three list dot extend four five
six output is one two three four five
six so if you want to append an array to
the end of another array you want to use
the extend number 19 what's the output
of the below code justify your answer
this is a great interview question
because these are the kind of things
that come up when you're proofing code
def add to list value and list so we
have value in and a list in or List
equals an empty in this case an empty
list list out of pin value return list
list one equals add to list one list two
equals add to list one two three empty
bracket list three equals add to list a
and then we want to print them list one
equals and you can see the formatting we
have a placeholder list one list two and
list three so when it prints list one we
to get 1 comma a and what you want to
notice here is that list one and list
three are equal why are they equal well
when we passed the information to the
add to list we passed value without
passing the list equals brackets without
passing a second value what this means
is that list as we have it if you don't
have a list it'll start off with empty
list which we append the one to the
second one list two we appended a value
to an empty list so we're only going to
be one two three doesn't matter what the
list was before we've already assigned
an empty list and then list three here's
the tricky one we're adding a to the
list but because we didn't designate the
list list is a shared value in other
words it doesn't reset it and we end up
with list one equals list three one
comma a default list is created only
once during the function and not during
its call number 20 what is the
difference between a list and a tuple
lists are mutable while tuples are
immutable and you can see an example
down here where I have list equals one
two three square brackets denote it's a
list list of two equals four and I print
it out I now have one two four if I do
the same thing with the two bolt I get
an error because you can't change the
Tuple one two three into one two four
you have to completely reassign Tuple to
a new value what is Doc string in Python
doc strings are used in providing
documentation to various python modules
classes functions and methods and so you
can see here we have def for a function
add a b and this is a doc string we have
the triple brackets on there you can add
carriage return in that so that you can
go multiple lines and it says this
function adds two numbers and then sum a
b returns some and so we have down here
two different ways of accessing this
function output accessing docstring
method one this function adds two
numbers accessing dockstring method two
help on function add in model main this
function adds two numbers and so you can
see the code down here has two very
different in values the second one is
basically a help menu there's our help
menu number 22 how to use print without
the new line the solution to this
depends on the python version you are
using in Python version 2 you can do
print Hi and then you add a comma
afterwards print how are you and you
have Hi how are you in version 3 print
hi comma end equals and it'll add a
space on the end there you can put
different characters in there but
generally you just want to put a space
put a space on the End Print how are you
and now we get Hi how are you number 23
how do you use the split function in
Python the split function splits a
string into a number of strings based on
a specific delimiter so we have string
split delimiter comma Max the maximum
number of splits the character based on
which the string is the split by default
is space so here we have an example we
have a variable red blue green orange
and we want to split it by commas and we
only want to do the first two so if we
print the list now you'll find it has
red blue and only spread it split it the
first two times and it gets to the third
one and just groups them all together
green and orange if you leave the two
off you'll split the whole thing number
24 is python object oriented or
functional programming python follows
object oriented Paradigm and you should
really know in depth what they mean by
object-oriented Paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which as inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming Paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports Lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
Paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is Def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for I and VAR print I so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a 1 function one two five six it'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
25 another line 6. number 26 what is
asterisk args and asterisks quarks args
used in function prototype to accept
varying number of arguments it's an
iterable object death function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if I send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma B comma C it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever I send to it and
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic quarks I can actually tell it
what I want to send so used in a
function prototype and to accept varying
number of keyworded arguments it's in
both our iterable objects so you can go
through them one at a time and the def
function chords you can now set like
color equals red units equal two so
you'll see that especially in machine
learning there's a lot of like they'll
have inline equals true that kind of
thing number 27 in Python functions are
first class objects what do you
understand from this this means I could
return a function if you went from
another function I could create a
function and treat it just like an
object I can assign it to a variable I
can pass them as arguments to other
functions number 28 what is the output
of print nay underscore underscore name
and justify your answer the double
underscore name double underscore is a
special variable that holds the name of
the current module program execution
starts from main or a code with zero
indentation thus double underscore name
double underscore name has a value
double underscore main double underscore
in the above case if the file is
imported from another module then double
underscore name underscore double
underscore holds the name of this module
number 29 what is a numpy array and we
briefly touched numpy array compared to
a list early in processing speed now
let's go ahead and look at some of the
more specifics a numpy array is a grid
of values all of the same type so if
they're either all float all integer all
string and is indexed by a tuple of
non-negative integers the number of
Dimensions is the rank of the array and
the shape of an array is a tuple of
integers giving the size of the ray
along each Dimension number 30 what is
the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as NP you don't
necessarily have to use MP but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an NP dot array of one
two three four five and then if we want
to get our indexes of n maximum values
in an empty array we can do one way to
do it is to take our array sort it then
do minus in colon that means we're going
to do once you've sorted it you can do
minus in in would equal then the number
of indices so it's not the actual letter
N colon and really this is about
understanding this notation that we can
sort it so it goes from lowest to
biggest and then we can get the top
values for n indexes and then we have
our final set of brackets with the minus
one on there number 32 how would you
obtain the resulting set from the train
set and the test set from below and
let's go ahead and look at the two
different variables we have train set
equals an array of one two three test
set equals a numpy of Ray of arrays we
have 0 1 2 1 2 3. what's important here
is that one it's a numpy so that leaves
a out and then we're stuck with three
other options and I'm going to say the D
is out none of these and let's look at
NP dot concatenate versus NP dot v stack
concatenate would put one set after the
other so you would end up with probably
give you an error because one set is one
two three and then we're going to
concatenate array 0 1 2 and 1 array one
two three the array of arrays onto the
end of that what we really want to do is
stack and by the ways you can actually
switch there's variables you can put
into concatenate obviously they can
change this so you could use the
concatenate with a lot of fudging around
but really we're looking for is v-stack
v stands for vertical versus the H stack
which is horizontal and if we do a
v-stack we can simply do train set comma
test set and stack them together and so
we have C resulting set equals np.v
stack train stack test set both option A
and B would do horizontal stacking but
we would like to have the vertical
stacking option she does this again you
could add the axes in and use the
concatenate to stack it the correct way
number 33 how would you import a
decision Tree classifier in sklearn We
have
sklearn.decision tree import decision
tree classifier from sklearn Ensemble
import decision tree classifier and we
look at these and they're all import
decision tree classifier that actually
last part happens to be correct and it's
really just a vocabulary knowing where
is the decision tree class specifier
stored what module is that a part of and
it is of course part of the sklearn.tree
number c number 34 you have uploaded the
data set in CSV format on Google
spreadsheet and shared it publicly how
can you access this in Python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
it here but you can there's actually a
number of ways to do this what's
important here is to know a couple
things one we have our link generated
from the Google Docs and spreadsheets
and then we can do a string IO dot
string IO request get link dot content
so there's our source and then finally
we know that pandas can read a CSV
there's obviously many ways to read a
CSV but data equals pd.read underscore
CSV Source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have DF name and DF
location colon comma brackets around
name comma where and then we have DF
equals PD data frame a b b x x u u comma
21 1650 33 columns equal name and age so
let's take a look and see what they're
looking at we have just glancing at the
questions they want to know is it the
original data frame or is it the copy of
the data frame and you can see here that
one is view the original data frame and
two is a copy of the original data frame
two is a view of the original data frame
and one is a copy of the original data
frame both are copies both are views and
if you're working with pandas you know
that unless you specifically in certain
things tell it to do it inline and a lot
of functions don't allow you that you're
always taking a slice and it is always a
copy so C both are copies of the
original data frame number 36 you get
the following error while trying to read
a file temp.csv using pandas which of
the following could correct it so here's
our error Trace back most recent call
last file input line one in module
Unicode encode error ASCII codex can't
encode character oh I hate it when that
one comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
that D doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is PD read CSV
has our file compression equals gzip
well gzip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again not encoding or coding setup and
then we have encoding equals utf-8 well
that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is Unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
Unicode and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with in a plot given below
so looking at this we have import
netplot Library Pi plot is PLT and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there
plt.plot1234 plot equals show and so
this is a little bit of a vocabulary
test the vocabulary is at width equals
three line width equals three LW equals
three or something else and the
vocabulary word that we're looking for
is LW equals three which stands for line
width in pi plot Library Pi plot Number
38 how would you reset the index of a
data frame to a given list so this is a
vocabulary Challenge and understanding
what re-indexing is re-indexing as we
have the different values here we have
the first one which is reset the index
well we're not really resetting the
index re-index number b means we're
double checking our indexes to the
column into the main index and so the
values match correctly where re-index
like now brings in a new index outside
of our data frame to a given list so
this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our key word
that is external and we have a data
frame to a given list number 39 how can
you copy objects in Python the functions
used to copy objects in Python we have
copy copy for shallow copying and copy
deep copying for deep copy number 40
what is the difference between range and
X range functions in Python well this is
a good one we have matrixes and arrays
with a matrix the range returns a python
list object X range returns an X range
object and with arrays an x-ray returns
an X range object X range creates values
as you need them through yielding the
key here is that X range Returns the
values as you need them so it actually
processes it post like if you have for x
or for a variable in X range it is
processing them as you need them zero to
nine it doesn't create an array zero to
nine it just hands you zero then one two
three four one at a time number 41 how
can can you check whether a panda's data
frame is empty or not the tribute
df.empty is used to check whether a
panda's data frame is empty or not and
so you can simply create a we have down
here import our pandas is PD we create
our pandas data frame equal to an empty
array and is DF dot empty comes out as
true one of the catches you got to
remember with these vocabularies is with
empty along with some other pandas set
up whether you need the brackets or not
at the end number 42 write the code to
sort an array in numpy by the N minus 1
column this can be achieved using ARG
sort function let's take an array X then
to sort the N minus one column the code
will be X to X to colon n minus two dot
args sort so let's see what that code
looks like we import numpy as NP we'll
create our array our numpy array which
is uh one two three zero five two two
three four so we have three different
entities with three different columns
and there and we go X of X and so we
take X of all the rows first entity well
in this case it's actually the second
one because it's 0 1 2 dot ARG sort so
that would be the second entity or minus
two would also be the same you could
also do instead of one you could also do
minus two there instead of the one ARG
sort and then we get an output of the
array one two three zero five two two
three four number 43 how to create a
series from a list numpy array and
dictionary so we'll go ahead and input
import our numpy our pandas and have my
list and you see here we have my list
equals list of a b c d e f g over all
the way through so my list now makes a
list of that for array we have NP dot a
range to 26 my dictionary will create a
dictionary with a zip my list my
arguments so I'll just use the numpy
array we just created with my array to
go into the dictionary and the solution
is simple with the PD dot series my list
pd.series my array PD dot series my
dictionary so it's all about knowing the
dot Capital s-e-r-i-e-s don't forget
that capitalization number 44 how to get
the items not common to both series a
and series B and you can see here we
have instead of series A and B we have
series one and two and we have one two
three four five four five six seven
eight the solution is we take a panda
series we have a series U equals a panda
series NP Union one dimension series one
series two so we can now make a union of
them we now have series one Panda series
with an intersection and then we can
remove one from the other series U is
series U dot is in series one so if the
union is not in the intersection then
you know it's a unique value a little
bit of logic going on there I'm playing
with three different terms to get the
answer we want 45 how to keep only the
top two most frequent values as it is
and replace everything else as other in
a series so again we're working with
pandas because if you're talking series
and data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as PD we'll go ahead and create
our Panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random State
100 so 100 in the numpy one and then we
have our Panda series you can see here
where random integer numpy random.random
integer one comma five by twelve and so
the solution for this is we go ahead and
we've created a PDF remember the capital
S Series solution we're going to print
the top two frequencies and that is our
series dot value counts and then we take
series values count dot index of up to
two so we're going to take everything up
to two and then we'll do the series is
in so if it's not in the first two then
it's going to equal other and this would
be something you'd want to write down on
paper if you're if it looks confusing
take a moment pause the video write this
down and see if you can figure out how
the logic came together and try to throw
yourself a couple other little logic
puzzles like this number 46 how to find
the positions of numbers that are
multiples of three from a series and in
here we're actually going to use a numpy
to solve it the first part series lets
you know it's going to be a panda series
and if we come down here we have NP dot
ARG where this is a vocabulary question
series with remember the percentile 3 is
the remainder so if the remainder equals
zero then we're going to generate that
ring where the object divided by three
equals zero has no remainder so then we
know it's a multiple of three number 47
how to compute the euclidean distance
between two series and this one's really
cool because we have our Panda series uh
p and Q and what I like about this one
is they give us two solutions you can go
with and really you should kind of know
both the first one would be yes you know
what the euclidean distance is and that
is we can take the first series minus
the second series squared and then sum
them up and then we do the square root
which is the same as taking the power to
0.5 doing the power to 0.5 is easier
than doing the square root so a lot of
times you'll see that as a switch but
you could have also done the square root
and use the math in there so there's
solution one you should know your
euclidean distance and then solution two
is the numpy solution so we have NPA dot
linag.norm that's how we're going to
compute our euclidean distance
P minus Q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it 5 minus one when
this creates a 25 by 25 data frame and
so our solution is to do the DFI
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon -1 so we're taking all the
rows all the columns minus one so our
stepping -1 going the reverse Direction
and then we're just going to use across
all the different columns on there let
me say that again the first colon is
going to be your row starting row
stopping row step minus one that's all
this is about is that step minus one
comma and then all the columns 49 if you
split your data into train test splits
is it possible to overfit your model and
the answer is yes is definitely possible
one common beginner mistake is retuning
a model or training new models with
different parameters after seeing its
performance on the test set my favorite
example of this is you have your script
put together and you keep hitting the
rerun button until you get the answer
you want not taking the answer it first
gave you or running it over an array and
recording all the answers to see how
they vary number 50 which python library
is built on top of matplot library and
pandas to ease data plotting the answer
this is Seaborn Seabourn is a data
visualization library in Python that
provides a high level interface for
drawing statistical information
informative graphs so thank you all for
watching this session on python
developer full course I hope this video
was useful and informative if you have
any questions then please feel free to
put them in the comment section A team
will help you solve your queries stay
safe and keep learning